this is jocko podcast number 347 with
echo charles and me jocko willik good
evening echo good evening
simply put
warrant officer nick lavery is a
warriors warrior
nick selflessly and repeatedly risked
his life for his nation his comrades and
arms and most importantly he
accomplished what our nation needed him
to do
every time he left our shores
nick is a hero in the truest sense
nick's chosen profession requires an
immersion
into some of the
nation's most difficult challenges often
in demanding complex and especially
uncertain environments
to answer the nation's call we seek men
and women who have the tenacity to
achieve the impossible
and the resiliency to do it again
and again
nick lavery's story is truly an exemplar
of that
and that right there is an excerpt from
a book the book is called objective
secure and the book is actually written
by
nick lavery
and the words in that excerpt were
spoken by lieutenant general francis but
francis beaudet who is the commander of
u.s army special operations
and the speech was given when nick
received an award for his service and
special operations and i think anyone
that hears that hears nick's story
will agree that
nick is exactly what the general said he
is a warrior who can absolutely
accomplish the impossible
and it is an honor to have nick with us
here tonight
to
talk us through his experiences and
share some of his lessons learned nick
thanks for coming down man thanks for
having me i wanted to read it really
quick intro so we could start talking
man yeah man let's do it that's where
i'm at
uh yeah freaking insane
you're like your life's been kind of
crazy thus far
um and we'll get into that let's let's
let's start from the beginning
all right normally when you've spoken
nine words everyone knows where you're
from
pretty quick yeah
yeah yeah boston mass is where i where i
claim home i guess more accurately
though is
is i'm a nomad of massachusetts
you know i moved
every 12 to 18 months as a kid all the
way up until eventually i got to college
and that's because you're what your
parents were just moving around
yeah a lot of it was
was financially related you know my both
my parents they had me and my younger
sister real young so struggling as young
parents and trying to just grind it out
with also my father
trying to pursue
his passion in life trying to figure out
what that is and go after it while he's
got you know two young kids he needs to
feed how old was he when he had you and
how old was your mom 20 and my mother
was 22. that's like old school
yeah my sister's two years younger than
me
so you know they do what they had to do
and uh
you know i love them and respect them
for it but that part of the story that
movement
is deeply rooted in a lot of what we're
going to get into here today right those
experiences
particularly me struggling socially
struggling to make friends and keep
friends and being the new kid in school
every year
in today's world what's known as
bullying you know back then wasn't as
looked at as it is today
so my my resiliency started from the
time that i you know was five years old
and went to kindergarten
that thing i mean we were just talking
about bullying yesterday as a matter of
fact because it is
we're talking about like everyone gets
bullied right well at least back in the
day when i grew up and you grew up when
echo group we all got bullied that was
going to happen because because no
matter what when you're 10 there's going
to be a 12 year old that's bigger than
you yeah and when you're 12 there's
gonna be a 14 year old that's bigger
than you
and when i got bullied and pushed around
and shoved into lockers and all those
things i kind of was just like that's it
to me it was just sort of the way things
went like oh yeah well i'm smaller right
now and i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
knocked around a bit because i'm smaller
i didn't think it was that big of a deal
i don't know it didn't like
hit me in some big emotional way i don't
know
yeah am i dumb
no you're you're just you bro you're
just you i i i definitely struggle with
it
more so than you did
um eventually i became conditioned to it
though
which you know took a few years then it
then then it became normal for me
i wasn't
i wasn't as
as
understanding of it as the way you just
put it but i just
my mind was conditioned to deal with the
pain and discomfort and embarrassment
so the effect was was less and less and
less over time early on
you know coming home with tears in my
eyes just about every day of school you
know and my parents are doing their best
to kind of mentor me and be like you
know you're going to be good just you
giving me some guidance
but then you know eight months later i'm
in a new location and it starts all over
again
but yeah
i guess i've never had that too because
i like basically grew up in the same
town with the same people all the time
everybody knew who who i was and knew
who my sisters were
whatever so i didn't have to go into
some new environment so i never really
experienced that
yeah it was tough but i look back now of
course
extremely grateful for that because a
lot of people you know they asked a lot
of the questions how'd you do this how'd
you do that i don't typically just dive
straight into into that portion of the
story but if i extract this thing all
the way down
that's deeply seated in that is there
anything that you remember do you
remember like one kid do you remember
you know i wrote a book about
bullying uh there's a there's a bully in
there named kenny williams you know
who's just bullying do you remember any
specific
like things that happened where it
really left the mark
i'd say the most
the clearest memory he comes back was a
kid who was maybe two years older than
me
and he you know he would beat on me just
about every day and one day
got dropped off the bus
uh he gave me an exceptionally good
baiting this particular day
so normally i come home i wouldn't be
like vis like visibly beat up and i
would i would hide it from my parents i
wouldn't let them know how often i was
getting like beat on because i even as a
young person i felt bad for them because
they're struggling and they're grinding
it out i didn't want to add to their
stress like we're getting kicked out of
this house we're moving to another house
like they're working their balls off i
could see that as a young person
so i would hide it
one particular day there was no there
was no hiding it right so i was like
busted up pretty good
walked in and uh you know my father got
home from work a little later and the
kid lived just down the street from us
so he grabbed me
and like drugged me down the street and
i'm begging him like no no let's not do
this you're gonna make it worse let's
not do this
that was in i don't know third grade so
i was probably i don't know seven or
eight ish i'm like dad no he's like no
no we're doing this
not you know knocks on the door and this
kid you know his parents weren't all
that put together you know father
answers the door
hippie looking dude but like big hairy
hairy big mustache
you know uh
shirtless answers the door and here my
father had some words where
it almost went physical between the two
of them right on this dude's doorstep
you know and the kid i was dealing with
is behind his father and he's now he's
yelling at me
about how i'm gonna get it worse and i'm
like this is not working out for anybody
ironically though however it did i do
remember that it did tone down after
that so it reached the precipice of
confrontation but it did kind of level
things off a little bit
yeah that's uh
that's that's a little bit crazy you
know that's that's what the dad wants to
do right yeah
echo charles what that was that was a
real strong reformative over there did
your dad get into it
back you up no no but i i don't know i'm
thinking like every time like i hear a
bully story yeah you know i have kids
now they're small
but if i you know you you imagine
them coming home with visible
damage bro oh yeah you want to go over
and kill everybody
like whoever was even a part of it we
had a kit we had a guy at this gym
uh and he worked here and he he did
sales
um
and but you know he was he's still he's
kind of you know like a
like a loudmouth you know always poking
fun always you know that kind of guy
and he did jiu jitsu he's a brown belt
you know
and
he used to roll with my son
and he would kind of like bully my son
you know when my son was a little kid
he'd like you know maybe slap him around
a little bit on the mats you know maybe
give the noogies right the cookies
and i remember one day when my kid was
maybe like 10 or 11 years old
we're leaving the gym and i i didn't
like painting mine to it you know he
would just get abused or whatever
bullied whatever while i was training or
something by you know he's trying to
train and this guy would grab and rough
him up
and one day we're walking out and and my
son goes hey dad and i go hey what's up
and he goes do you think that guy he's
like do you think he'll be here when i'm
like 20.
and i was like
i don't know but i could see he's
plotting wow i mean he's plotting on
this dude so that guy doesn't work here
anymore so he's probably gonna get away
with it but
that's the kind of thing where you think
like that left a mark
on my kid like oh when the time comes
i'm gonna train and i'm gonna work and
i'm gonna be bigger and stronger that
guy will come back when i'm 20.
how old was he when it happened it was
probably like i mean this happened for
years i mean we've had this gym since he
was since my son was like five
oh wow so this could have happened
anywhere between the ages of five and
fifteen you know he was forecasting yeah
a decade down the road but this was when
my son was like 10. he was thinking hey
he was yes he was forecasting by the
time i'm 20
that guy's gonna be old and i'm gonna be
ready in my prime yeah i think he is
about 20 minutes he's coming yeah
that clock is ticking
uh
i'm gonna go to the book here give you a
little childhood background here when i
was around nine years old my parents
bought me a dumbbell set
it had pairs of three five and eight
pounders i began constantly working out
my bedroom eventually i got to an age
when i could join a gym no matter where
i was living at the time i would scout
out a nearby place to train often my
oftentimes miles away i would ride my
bike there and back the progress wasn't
what i had hoped for neither did it have
much of an effect on my social life
but the desire to be big and strong
remained i caught the bug
mother nature eventually blessed me with
a growth spurt shooting me up over six
feet five and my consistent work in the
weight room paid off i introduced
different combat sports and martial arts
into my life i was no longer picked on
and as my social skills also developed i
was no longer without friends so
you started getting after it
[Music]
yeah you made that connection i don't
know if that was a a pre-planned segway
with yostan but that's i mean that's
perfect because
i didn't have a specific dude in mind
that i was targeting
a decade down the road it was really
everybody i was targeting
but the grind began then in order to you
know build up the
the confidence that i
wanted and needed
and so what when did you start wrestling
high school
yeah russell high school uh for my first
three years up until my senior year
which is when football became the only
sport that i would play our head coach
full head football coach was also also
the athletic director
of the program so i started getting
looked at to play football my junior
year
by college scouts so come senior year
he's like no no all you're doing here in
the weight room it's football you can
run with the track team to help you with
your speed and conditioning but you are
football 24 7. then you were down for
the cause on that right absolutely
yeah that became my primary sport
earlier than high school uh and then i
saw it as as a way to go to college
because i was not an academic
by any stretch you want to talk about
doing the bare minimum just to be able
to stay eligible to play sports that was
me man
so that was my only route to college uh
so i i was cool with that adjustment
when did you grow
i was a peanut
most of my life growing up i was a
massive baby i was born i was 12 pounds
9 ounces
as a baby
and my mother that's not a baby bro
that's like a
small child i said i set the record at
the hospital which has since closed so i
own that forever
my mother's you know she's a hippie and
she wanted to have this natural birth
process and the doctor's like no no no
you don't understand like we have to go
and remove this human from you because
he will split you in half
so that's the round i took and i was
massive as a as a baby and then i became
really really small like i wrestled at
123 you know my freshman year so little
i was maybe five five five six little
guy damn
it wasn't till i think it was between my
sophomore and junior year of high school
that i hit this massive growth spurt and
i shot up like six inches over a summer
and my my joints were all achy and i had
oz goods this is what it was called my
shirt
okay so i had that going and i was
gangly and awkward because i had gotten
so tall
came back my junior year and my football
coach all my coaches were like what do
we even do with you now you know because
you're you're growing so tall
but between that time and then the time
i graduated those two years was when i
shot up you know like over a foot over
the course of two years
that's insane it was wild man and it was
even it was stranger because my birthday
september 1st which is coming up here
pretty soon
i went to school early so everyone in my
class was a year ahead of me
so i started college for example at 17
years old was my freshman year of
college so i was already like a year
behind everybody in terms of my maturity
oh yeah and my puberty development so
even my buddies once i had them
their voices are dropping they're
getting hair in new places and i'm still
this little squeaky mouse
right you know trying to lift my eight
pound dumbbell set so i can stay you
know one of the one of the cool kids
so i was real late to the game with all
that stuff yeah that's why parents hold
their kids back that's a big deal man
holding the kids back so they're little
dominators in wrestling that's like the
way that's the way you know at least in
california kids are getting kids are
like 23. they're seeing
their senior year you know football in
texas oh yeah it's the same thing
freaking crazy you see these seniors in
high school with full-blown beards
like men right he's not kids man these
are men yeah
uh so you so you
must have started to like just
completely shine on in football because
you get huge
i didn't get huge like body mass wise
until i was in college so by the time i
graduated my senior year you know i was
a strong safety but i got so tall
that the scout started looking at me for
linebacker in college they're like
you're eventually going to fill out that
frame
we just need to maintain your speed and
stack on some muscle mass to go along
with your now new height that you have
so i was recruited to play
linebacker
and then the muscle mass really came
around you know
sophomore year college i spent my first
year in that summer just with the
strength coaches and the nutritionists
all within the program that we had at
the school
learning how to eat learn how to train
and that's when i really filled out my
frame so my sophomore year of college
you know i was eventually around like 2
25 2 30
whereas if i was born in texas or if my
father had half a brain and he had done
what he should have done right i would
have been more than likely d1 full ride
playing on sundays today i blame him for
for my current lifestyle
uh
what would did they put you on like a
straight up just dirty bulk is that the
proper term one of them dirty
i mean i imagine if you showed up to me
and you're you're a freshman in college
and you weigh whatever
185 pounds i'm like cool deadlift squat
and just eat did they put you on that
like you said nutritionist i thought the
nutritionist at that point would be
domino's just eat everything eat
everything no it wasn't it was more
dialed in i had a i had a regimented uh
meal plan that i would just show up to
the cafeteria and just give them my name
and then they would give me the food
but it wasn't just like pizza and like
hot pockets and [__] it was like real
food it was just a lot of it
i r there was a basketball player named
minute bowl who played for the
university of bridgeport he came from
africa and he was seven ten or something
crazy
and that when he got here he weighed you
know like some tiny amount and i read
some article that they were like hey
this they were just pizza and beer like
we just need this guy to eat everything
he can
to just get a little bit bigger because
he was too skinny
yeah that uh it's weird i mean we're in
the generation
they know a lot about nutrition nowadays
where even in our college where if they
would have guys gain weight it would be
good good okay yeah we had a program
called training table where all the the
football players would go and they'd eat
separate and it would be different food
and it's all like good food there's no
pizza there's no that kind of like
chicken veg potatoes potatoes yeah
yeah a lot of potatoes yeah but that was
really where i began learning about
nutrition and then i was seeing the
effects as it pertained to me on the
field and that was where i really fell
in love with with training and fitness
and you know continuing that through
today that was the foundation of that
knowledge was at that point
and then so how did how did it go how to
go in the football college career
it was good you know i played i played
d2 at umass and uh um and
you know my first freshman year you know
it didn't didn't get really any playing
time but i was still kind of growing and
developing sophomore i started playing a
little bit and then junior i was
starting
um i say junior yeah because that's the
way we normally break it down but for me
it was like more like my sophomore year
2.0 you know because
i wasn't in line with
the credits i needed to stay on track to
graduate in four years
right so
but my second or third year of playing
ball my third year in college
uh was when i was on the field and then
my fourth year
i took a i took a pretty nasty injury to
my back and that ended my season a
little early that was your senior year
yeah so what year was that
that would have been
2004 2005. oh okay so
where were you and what were you doing
when september 11th happened
that was my sophomore year
yeah sophomore year or my second year of
school
was 9 11. were you
is that what focused you may be thinking
about being in the military yeah i mean
that was certainly the
the
tipping point for me was that i started
looking at it in high school
around my freshman sophomore yeah in no
direction i skipped school one day i
went downtown boston and met with the
marine corps recruiter and i said i
think i want to be a marine and he's
like perfect finish high school and come
back and we got you we got you bro mike
great so i had like kind of an idea
because i hated school i liked athletics
but i was tiny there was no future in
that for me i wanted it again i wanted
to be respected i wanted to be feared in
a lot of way because i lived my life in
fear most of the time and the marine
corps was the route to give me what i
needed he's like cool graduate high
school come back did you take your
number or anything
i don't think so it might be too far
outside their window because they got to
get their quotas and all that i'm
at the same time like when they some you
walk in there it's like a going onto a
car dealership like they're ready to
take you yeah but i guess if you were
like 13 he's like no come back when you
graduate yeah i don't i don't remember
any any exchange of information
the only thing that detracted me from
going that route was was football it was
athletic so went to college you know
kind of plan b
uh and then sophomore year was yeah that
was 9 11 and then at that point i
struggled to stay in school because
i was really angry and i wanted to be
part of the response to that i struggled
to stay in school listen to some you
know family and friends and mentors
and decided to stay in and grind out the
rest of my degree and then look at
options to come in what did you what did
you get your degree in criminology
and then you so you know you're
graduating what you what you would you
say you graduated 2005. i graduated in
2007. oh no kidding so yeah you know
normally if you go to college for seven
years they call you doctor
me they it's just neck still
so you know a lot of different academic
probations and uh having to redo
semesters you know
it made it easy for me to be eligible
for football because it's played in the
fall
so all i needed to do was maintain i
think it was nine credits like three
classes
and just not
fail any of them if i could i could fill
all the rest of my classes after the
season was over and i didn't care
and that was the route i took right sure
i didn't i didn't care you know i look
back now and i'm like man you know what
if i just applied myself and now i enjoy
reading and learning and studying but
back then i didn't i didn't care so yeah
was when i finally received my degree
and then when did you talk to recruiter
so now did you still look at the marine
corps or how'd that go
i looked at the navy
oh okay graduated college
the wall was still going on now iraq is
kicked off as well so afghanistan iraq
are both surging it was prime for
someone to go in and get some and i'm
like yup here we go so
i maybe was a week after i graduated
college i went downtown boston
and in the same building they had
three branches they had the navy the
marines and the army in three separate
offices
and i went into the navy office first
and i said i want to be a seal you know
i knew i wanted to be in special
operations i want to be right at the
front of the fight and the seals comes
to mind really fast
today as then
of being the ultimate badass warrior so
i walk in i say i want to be a seal
and he said perfect
uh let's get you enlisted in the navy
and then you can request to go to buds
and go that route and i said okay thank
you and i left and i went and talked to
the marine corps recruiter and i got the
same answer when i went and talked to
the army i got a different answer they
said we have this program called the
special forces recruit contract option
known as the 18 x-ray which i'm sure
you're familiar with
gets you
straight into
the army special forces you bypass the
conventional army assuming you make it
all the way through
the
navy recruits the navy
brings in a lot of people
that want to be seals
that aren't going to be seals sure i
mean a lot of people
and it's it's interesting that you were
able to identify that that that what
they were offering you wasn't what you
actually wanted and there's there is a
pro there there are programs i'm
surprised that there are programs that
you get like a contract to go at least
get a shot at buzz those things do exist
when i came in that's what i did it was
at the time it was called the dive
fairer program i have no idea what that
means but it was like you are guaranteed
an opportunity to take the test to go to
buds and i was like yeah cool sign me up
but it sounds like that guy was
didn't even have that much to offer you
no no and i mean if he had chances out
things would look a little different
right now because i would have taken it
yeah because that was my goal was i want
to be a seal boom if he had said hey man
we got this option right here we'll get
you into buds within the first six
months whatever some kind of guarantee
yeah
i probably would have signed it right
there and then yeah
he
that's weird i wonder what was up with
that then the marine corps same thing
the marine corps used to be like hey you
joined the marines and you don't even
get of any kind of [__] you you're gonna
join the marines we'll give you a job
that's the way the marine corps it's
better now yeah
uh but the army has had that that 18
x-ray program has been freaking gold
mine for them yeah they kicked off you
know originally back in the day and then
uh and then it went away for a while and
they turned it back on in 2002 you know
post 911 yeah when the oda was getting
requested to do a whole bunch of stuff
like we need we need to get more
quality candidates let's start this
program back up again yeah i don't know
if you've heard some of the sog guys a
lot of those sog guys were off the
street straight into sf and
they'll defend the 18 extra they'll
we're all eight we're basically 18 x-ray
because they just came right in went and
went in and went to nom and got after it
yeah uh so that's what happened so you
end up
did you even think about an officer
program or was that just not happening i
mean it sounds like your grades weren't
stellar grades were not stella uh
it was offered to me it was brought up
to me by my recruiter but the x-ray 18
x-ray contracts not an option for
offices so ed immediately wiped that off
the table for me
also my interpretation of what offices
do back then was a little off there's
some
truth to it but in my mind then officers
strictly sat behind a desk and enlisted
guys with the actual guys that worked
and i wanted to be a worker i wanted to
get my hands dirty yeah and everything
else dirty i wanted to get into it like
i don't want to be the guy telling the
guy to do the thing i want to be the guy
doing the thing
and in soft that's that's obviously not
the case um
but because the x-ray option didn't
exist for os
that automatically made it a non-option
for me
what'd your parents think of this
uh
my father essentially tried to ground me
when i brought this to his attention you
know how old were you i was 24.
right 24 a lot of life experience
graduated college and i called them up
you know because i had done my homework
i didn't sign the x-ray contract right
there and then either i went home i said
thank you i didn't know what green
berets did
i'd seen you know rambo and john wayne
but i didn't know what an sf48 does what
a green bay really does so i did some
homework i was drawn to the mission i
was really attracted by the timeline
that's what ultimately made me pull the
trigger but once i did my homework made
my decision
i don't think i'd sign the contract yet
but i called my father
and i said hey dad i'm gonna that's what
i'm gonna do and he's like no you're not
and i'm like
listen dude i love you
you're my best friend in the world i'm
not asking you permission i'm 24. you
know
but you know it as an as a new father
now my kids are also are also young i
can put myself in his shoes right he
sees the news he sees what's going on he
knows where i'm trying to go and he's
just scared for me which is fine but
they were both totally against it to
begin with now you described your mom as
a hippie like is that like classic
definition of a hippie
she's a free spirit
yeah she's a free spirit she's got her
stones and she's got some crystals in
the bag got some crystals she's got a
dream catcher over the bed got some
incense burning okay she's she's in
there yeah man she's in there so she
must have been really freaking out
yeah she's less than my father my
father's much more like rigid and
objective and scientific my mother was
still kind of like well you need to you
know you need to choose your own journey
kind of thing
oh damn right but like i'd rather you
not
do that but like you need to be
who you need to be kind of thing okay
we'll take it i remember uh i just came
home and told my parents yeah i just
enlisted the navy you know
and my dad just looks at me he goes
you're gonna hate it
he said you don't you hate authority and
you don't listen to anybody and i said
i'm gonna be in the seal teams it's a
team
you don't know nothing old man do you
come from a military family back my
grandfather was in the army
my dad's dad was in the army for 20
years
my dad got kicked out of rotc
and he says that the military gene skips
a generation because my dad's not a very
militaristic dude but i was a real i was
a rebellious kid so my dad was just
looking at my but they were both like
cool you know get out of here that's
probably the best thing that could
happen as you go in the military instead
of staying around here causing trouble
being an idiot which i was doing a good
job of yeah
so rolled out and that was that but i
yeah i didn't i just came home and told
them i did it so they were i think they
overall they were like this is probably
a really good thing that this idiot's
getting out
getting off the payroll
that's right
um
let's jump back to the book here real
quick
august 13th 2007 was my first day in the
united states army
it began at the 30th adjutant general
reception battalion located in fort
benning georgia this is the first
location u.s army basic training
recruits arrive prior to the actual
start of basic training its purpose is
to receive prepare and train personnel
for what lies ahead while i am sure we
were given some classes the only things
i recalled during my time at the 30th ag
were doing paperwork eating our three
meals a day and waiting a lot of waiting
most of which was spent standing in
formation we stood in formation for
hours each day while in formation
waiting for what seemed like an eternity
we would sound off with several mantras
the soldiers creed the army song and the
warrior ethos are a few that come to
mind at any point a drill sergeant a
member of the command or any soldier in
the formation would simply yell the
warrior ethos
then the entire formation of soldiers
would sound off with that mantra
this served two purposes one it killed
time even it was only 30 seconds of time
it gave us something to do
two it ingrained these mantras into our
heads basic training in the art is the
army's method to break down an
individual into human clay in order to
then be remolded into a soldier
the same goes for other branches the
military the verbalization of mantras is
part of that process
the warrior ethos is one of them the
warrior ethos has four tenets
one i will always place the mission
first two i will never accept defeat
three i will never quit
four i will never leave a fallen comrade
so it's welcome to boot camp
how did you feel about boot camp when
you got there
it was annoying
more than anything else i mean i was
physically in phenomenal shape so
physically it was it was relatively easy
how long was it before between when you
enlisted and when you left
maybe three four months were you were
you did you shift your training to be
ready for oh yeah drastically pumping
rocks and yeah so because i finished
playing football
around 2004 2005. what'd you weigh when
you got done was your max weight
playing ball i would usually start the
season around 250 and i'd end up usually
around like 240 by the end of the season
so
i was done playing ball still more
college left and i just wanted to see
how big and strong i could get i didn't
need to be quite as athletic as i needed
to be as a football player so i got more
into strong man and power lifting type
stuff i was doing a little bit of boxing
a little bit of light wrestling but it
was mostly just like let's get big and
strong which worked for me because what
i was doing professionally was
vip security and nightclub security so
you know all my bosses liked you know a
big yoked up dude and a suit at the
front door so you know it helped me with
my what i was doing for work
and i enjoyed the training so by the
time i decided to by the time i
graduated college decided i was going to
enlist
i was close to 300 pounds damn
yeah i mean i was doing like 12 000
calories a day i mean it was just it was
just crazy
so there's no way i was in a condition
to go to basically does it take effort
for you to eat 12 000 calories in a day
yeah you got it was hot it's work yeah
i really disliked it
i'm like choking down you know chicken
breasts and dry potatoes with a gallon
of water you know my strength coach is
like hey this is what it's going to take
you know if you want an 800 pound
deadlift this is what you got to do
so i decided to enlist and you know i'm
i'm huge
so you're a 300 pound bouncer yeah did
you ever get a test as a bouncer that
you had any trouble with
no not really not at that point man i
mean i can just imagine you're six foot
five 300 pounds you wrestled like you
must have been a real quick uh
peacemaker in these scenarios yeah
at that point man you know i was so
comfortable with losing fights although
it had been a couple years since that
had happened at that point i'm the
biggest guy in the room i've been boxing
since i was a kid wrestling you know
some different martial arts like i was
well equipped
did you train you did you train jiu
jitsu yet no jiu jitsu didn't come on
until until uh i got into sf okay
actually did you know did you know how
to choke people
did you know like a did you know like
the sleeper hold yeah i knew but it was
a real naked joke yeah i knew basic i
knew basic stuff like as a bouncer you
occasionally had to put somebody to
sleep
yeah oh yeah okay and you know
i wasn't the most mature bouncer until i
got a little older you know some of the
places i worked some of the people i
worked for their methodology was let's
make let's punish this person so that
they don't think or no one else thinks
to act a fool in my place again
which i enjoyed
uh i look back with you know some regret
hurting some people i probably didn't
need to be hurt that way but i mean
that's just the nature of the business i
was in the way i went about doing it
so big boy yeah so you're 300 pounds or
almost 300 pounds yeah when you enlist
when i decide that the military is
definitely gonna happen okay by the time
that i signed the contract and then my
report date was like four months or so
after that point was when i started my
training program it was about a 16-week
program i did
where did you get that program did you
create it
i was working with a strength coach same
coach i work with today actually one of
them that i've been working with him now
you know close to 15 years he's so he
put it together for me and obviously it
was a wild shift from flipping tires and
moving atlas stones
to you know running rooking dynamic
crossfit style circuit training so i
sliced myself down over about 16 weeks
from you know 295 to about 245
about 50 pounds or so came off
which 245 6'5 is a big person right but
i was just diced because i had so much
mass on that i just sliced everything
off so by the time i showed up day one
i don't think this is in the book this
is no [__]
day one of boot camp of basic training
yeah you're just a savage i'm i'm a 24
year old six foot five 240 pound diced
dude
and i'm surrounded by a lot of you know
17 18 year old children who have never
left the house before
and you know you get your ass smoked
right of course for the first several
hours when you get there
after maybe four or five hours of just
doing push-ups and flooded kicks and
sit-ups i'm like pumped up my muscles
are like full
and then they do their tattoo inspection
which they strip you down
into your underwear and they just go
person to person to person and i don't
think they're really searching for
tattoos i think they just want to see
like your physique
and like expose you and just make you
feel uncomfortable
so all three drill sergeants are like
surrounding you and you're standing
there in your underwear
and they're just like looking you up and
down and just like getting into your
head
well the tattoos i have on me this is
latin for strength and honor i didn't
have a lot of these other tats on me at
the time
so these these stuck out and they look
at me and they're like
what's your deal
and i'm like i don't know how to answer
this question you know like why are you
here and i thought they were messing
with me
in retrospect i talked to these guys
late like years later they're like we
thought you were like an actual like
government project
that was going on
like you were created in a lab or
something like they didn't know what my
deal was
because and then they asked me about the
tattoos and i say it says it says
strength in honor and then they look up
at the wall and it's engraved in the
wall above the white board it says
strength and honor so now their wheels
are really spinning
like i'm some kind of an implant you're
from the movie soldier bro
and i didn't pick up on all this at the
time and eventually our head drill
instructor
later on that evening came over to me
and he's like no really man like did
someone send you here
and i'm like i can't i don't i don't
know what's happening right now dude i'm
trying to play the game but i don't know
what game we're playing right now
so it was more it was more uh i say it
was more annoying and frustrating
because i was babysitting kids i was put
in charge of my of my platoon on day one
like you're the guy
we're all going to leave for the night
you're going to make sure that everyone
that's in their beds right now are going
to stay in their beds so i was literally
chasing kids like down down the
stairwell that were trying to just leave
fort benning i don't know where they
thought they were going to go
but i'm like dragging kids back to their
beds you know
it wasn't very like tactful with my
approach it was very blunt like get your
ass back in your bed and stay there or
else you know so that was like 16 or 17
weeks and pretty much that yeah that's
classic dude you're not a normal dude to
be showing up
that's freaking awesome
uh so you do you go to basic and then
you go to do you go straight to ait
after that
well for us as an 18 x-ray you do the
infantry program which is called one
station unit training so they go basic
and ait back to back without any break
okay so it's boom boom right straight
through are you
just having fun this entire time no no
it wasn't fun at all it was i was just
like staring at the clock like get me
out of here you know like the runs like
the workouts they weren't all that like
stimulating and difficult i was trying
to play the game i did play the game you
know i wasn't like a rebel i was like
roger that i was a good soldier yeah i
was just like i want to get to the real
work which i know is at fort bragg so
like get me out of here
and then so
you make it through all this stuff did
you go to airborne school too yeah go
when you finish basic or ait and then
you go straight down the street to
airborne school get your airborne
shuffle on for three weeks oh yeah
do some plfs in the sawdust
um
and then it's then it's to uh where'd
you go softsee did they have sopsy at
this point yeah then it was to stop see
and
that's to get you ready for that's to
get you ready for selection right
correct you were kind of ready for
selection oh yeah yeah were you in worse
shape now than you were when you entered
just from being a boot camp and stuff or
were you able to maintain
no i was i i lost you know 20 25 pounds
in basic training just because i didn't
get i wasn't getting the calories i
needed you're they were starving you
yeah the freaking government project yes
they were trying to cut off
they wanted to tear me back down and
have me sent back to the lab for
for like a refit
so i i was in i would say i was in worse
shape for
selection specifically than i would have
been if i had just gone straight to that
without going to base training
but it was okay because you know by the
time i got to sopsie and or got to brag
to start stop seed then i could eat like
normal again and i put some mass back on
so
get back into more anaerobic
stuff with some resistance
to be ready for stop see so i was i was
good to go and how's sopsy when you get
there is it starting to start to
approach what you have in mind yeah it
definitely was i mean the way stops you
was back then i think it was five or six
weeks and you would stay at fort bragg
and then you'd go down to fort campbell
on monday and you would train and be in
sap c monday through friday and then you
would come back to brag for the weekend
and you would just do that for six weeks
and it was just a lot of pt
land nav like not tying some sf history
stuff but it was mostly physical to get
you ready for selection
well at the end of the first week so
it's friday
one week week one is done and now i'm
feeling like i'm playing the game with
like with like the big boys i got sf
guys that are now my cadre it's my first
time being introduced to them i'm
surrounded by a bunch of x-rays
i'm like okay now i feel like i'm in the
game
that first week ends and our lead
instructor comes down he says all right
check it out the upcoming selection
class
has some open slots
so we're going to send
volunteers
um
or we're going to just force those that
are in the top 10 percent
performance-wise to go and it starts on
monday
i raise my hand immediately i'm like yep
i'm i'm good i'm ready to go like let's
go my confidence was was really high so
it gave me a weekend to just get my
stuff ready my equipment make sure i had
everything i needed which i did because
i was part of sopsy so my sopsy
experience was was five days and then i
was in sfas the following monday and how
was how was that selection
selection when i went through was was 14
days long now it's back to 20 or so
uh it was 20 21 for a long time and then
mine was the second class after they
condensed it down into 14.
i can't tell you why they did that but
you would think that that meant they
removed like five or six days worth of
stuff but they didn't they just rammed
it into a shorter window so there was no
like white space in between stuff
everything was just it was much more
intense because you still had to check
all these blocks but just in a week
less of time what percentage of
attrition comes from that selection
yeah so
the time i went we started with around
or so candidates
and around 100 made it to the end and
then they selected
around
or so
god see that seems like a freaking crazy
roll of the dice if you're joining the
army to be as
an sf guy
that you can go through the training and
they can be like yeah
you're not what we're looking for is
that what it is
yeah i mean they you know i have some
buddies that are selection cadre now and
some that have been and now are back to
the unit uh you know they make it as
objective as i think they can but it
it's open to subjectivity because there
are human beings that are evaluating you
and when
if you're looking at purely
physical capability like how fast did
you run two miles that's that's
objective how many push-ups can you do
pull-ups whatever but when you're
evaluating people for
leadership
and their ability to work in a team
dynamic that gets subjective pretty
quick so it is a roll of the dice to a
degree because
you may just have a bad may have a bad
day or a bad week you're assaulted leta
you're assault performer you just didn't
perform when you needed to and that's
what the cadre had to go off of
so yeah you didn't make this round but
come back and try again how long do you
have to wait before you come back and
try again i think it's
i want to say it's like six months no
it's not too bad i think it's like six
months were there guys that you've
thought were like oh yeah that guy seems
like good to go and he didn't make it
yeah didn't get selected yeah yeah a few
a few my buddies that were actually in
um basic with me that made it all the
way to sopsy that came with me with that
first chunk because there were like 10
of us that left sopsy early
i think maybe five of us got selected
that first class and the other five i
would have said no these guys are these
guys are gonna be good to go i was
mostly looking at their physical
performance like their ruck times and
their pull-ups and they're like these
were physical studs
but for whatever reason they just didn't
display what they needed to do did the
cadre debrief a guy and be like hey man
you you were definitely not in the game
over here you fell short looked like you
had a big ego do they debrief guys
no damn
no
it's uh the cadre during selection are
like robots
it's not they're not in your face
they're not screaming and yelling ah
there's a couple times that they're
screaming and yelling log and rifle pt
are two iterations where they are
in your face and screaming and trying to
crack you physically and emotionally
mentally but the rest they're like
cyborgs it's very just here's this is
your task
this is your condition this is your
standard do you have any questions
execute that's it and if you if you
don't make it they're like okay go over
there there's nothing
they're not trying to
they're not trying to get you to quit
and they're also not
there to
tell you why you don't get picked up or
why you failed an event yeah they're
like cyborgs
that's wild because it seems like in
buds
really the whole first phase is to weed
people out but most of it happens first
second third fourth week the fourth week
is the fourth or fifth week depending is
is hell week you know and they'll get
rid of so many people
but uh
yeah that objectivity
i guess it happens a little bit
different in buds you know like the
instructors will see someone that's weak
and they'll kind of like
they'll start working on them and
they'll just break him you know and
that'll be that
um
was there anything that was a challenge
for you in this stuff because you're
like a freaking government experiment
was there anything that was hard for you
in selection yeah selection was
certainly challenging
um
i think what i struggled most with was
the team dynamic aspect although i grew
up playing team sports
you know you get put in these in these
scenarios where you have a mission to
execute as a small group
and they'll rotate who's in charge
you're in charge of this you're in
charge of that
and that's where they're assessing you
as leaders but they're also assessing
everyone else as a team player and their
ability to support a leader right to
kind of lead up the chain of command
kind of philosophy
well
as an aggressive
younger person
as whenever the leader made a decision
on how we're going to execute something
and i didn't agree with it i made that
note i'm like
no that's that's not gonna work like i
wanted to win
and these tasks that they're given to us
they're essentially impossible like
within the standards that are given to
you there's no way it's happening right
they know that it's not about can you be
get from a to b in the a lot of time
it's about how do you work together as a
unit how do you lead how do you
communicate how do you problem solve how
do you deal with stress that's what
they're looking at
i wanted to win
and homeboy came back with some like
crazy ridiculous strategy that i knew
wouldn't work i let him know that i'm
like no no that's not gonna work and now
this dude's in a like a tough spot he's
like dealing with someone who's like
bigger than him and angrier than him and
he's trying to you know do his job as a
leader and of course he's being
evaluated that
the cadre are standing right there
so i could have done a better job of
being a supportive
member of the team
um i didn't have the same leadership
philosophy and methodology and tools
that i have now so i struggled with that
because even in the moments i could tell
like i'm not handling this very well but
i want to win and and it's just it it
superseded my ability to stay you know
calm and tactful did they debrief you on
that or you just figured this out later
no they did so if you get selected you
sit down uh with a cadre after and they
go through your entire your entire
packet with all your scores and all
their inputs so that was the number one
thing that that was told to me was
you need to learn how to be more
supportive of a leader that's legit yeah
give you some legit feedback and you
were you uh
humble enough to
understand that at the time
i was humble enough to to accept it yeah
i didn't have the same mentality towards
leadership then as i do now where
now i look as leadership as very much a
skill like it's something that you can
learn but you have to deliberately train
on it
back then even even at that point so i'm
now 25 i just got selected whatever
i still looked at leadership as as a
talent as something that you either had
or didn't have and that was it so i just
took it like roger that sergeant i i
appreciate it but like this is who i am
and i don't have the leadership like
skill ingrained in me genetically i just
don't have it so i'm gonna have to get
better other ways to kind of make up the
difference
now i look you know my mentality towards
it is wildly different yeah i know
that's a that's a a lot of people make
that but a lot of people have that
attitude and you know we have a
leadership consulting company and
explaining to people that they can
actually
learn skills just like like i said the
example i was used as playing guitar or
shooting baskets in basketball like you
can't just pick up a basketball and beat
think you can make free throws it's like
not happening you can't pick up a guitar
and you think you're going to be able to
play you it's skill and leadership is
the same way and are there some people
that have a little bit of a tendency
that have better hand-eye coordination
they're gonna be able to pick up
basketball a little bit quicker yeah are
there people that have a certain ability
to recognize different notes when they
hear them yeah that's an actual thing
you can be born with
but regardless you still need to learn
the skills in order to get good at and
leadership's the same way you're going
to have some natural propensity for it
there's going to be some parts of it
you'll be good at there's going to be
some parts you'll suck at
you take advantage of the ones you're
good at you work on the ones you're not
but it's definitely everyone can get
better unless
they're a person that says i already
know everything right and then then
they're going to be a problem
um so then it's off to q course after
that yep get selected go into cue course
uh and back then it's different today
but back then
you know you go through these different
phases phase one two three four and in
between those
you would just be waiting at fort bragg
for there to be enough students that
they could lump together to stop the
next phase so a lot of white space in
between
you know phase one you go to down to cam
mccall you're there for three weeks
seven weeks whatever
come back to brag and reset well
sometimes those breaks could be
a month or three months
right what are you doing during those
breaks just working out pt formations um
they do like some lpd stuff with some of
the attacks that were back there at
bragg the guys that were like in charge
of us keeping accountability so we do
some like leadership type classes
but you were mostly just hanging out
waiting trying to stay out of trouble
and that's where actually a lot of guys
that's the reason why they're not green
berets today is because of that downtime
you know there's plenty of distractions
in fayetteville north carolina
plenty there's plenty they're all
actually all they're all there
all the vices and distractions that you
could want or hope didn't exist they're
all there
girls drugs booze nightlife fights
that is what got a lot of guys removed
from the program
because they just couldn't stay focused
for that amount of time
because it took me just the queue course
alone
about 18 months oh no kidding to get
through it yeah and how much of that
time was
i mean just just
how much was actually training maybe 12.
wow yeah
well when you were going through that
was there anything that was trouble for
you in there
language school
real hard yeah yeah language school was
hot
what language did you learn i learned
russian in the cucos which is six months
long do they have ours in russian they
have the r sound in russian because they
do but that aren't passing [__]
you talk about a confusing accent you
mix russian and boston together
literally no one knows what i'm saying
including me so everyone's left lost
what did you just say i'm like i don't
think i even know
that was tough uh how long is that how
long was the russian course six months
and that's all you do eight hours a day
headset on freaking they don't speak
english to you we have instructors so
you're in a classroom with like six
seven other guys uh eight hours a day
just learning russian
and it was even worse because we we
still don't maintain our jump status
during the cue course so we did a jump
like the week before i started language
school and i broke my tailbone
broke my coccus i came down i landed on
the on the uh on the runway bro those
shoots are not made for big dudes no man
i come down like a like an asteroid i
always did too yeah you know especially
with equipment i mean i forgot about
just a freaking disaster even at 1300
feet you know it's like by the time i
shoot opens i check my stuff i drop i'm
dropping my equipment pretty much
immediately and i'm smashing into the
earth yeah with a vapor trail behind me
you know so i came down i i
had some wind i couldn't stare couldn't
avoid it runway this is happening boom
broke my tailbone thought i thought i
paralyzed him i thought it was that's
freaking horrible yeah the scariest guys
have been paralyzed from that type of
accident yeah i couldn't move i couldn't
breathe i'm like okay uh this is the
rest of my life
fortunately it was just a broken
tailbone which is a is
not a convenient injury
you know no i've never had it but it
doesn't sound like there's no great you
can't cast it you know so you just have
to stay off of it and let it kind of
heal the best it can but i'm immediately
going into language school or i'm going
to be spending eight hours a day in a
classroom
so my first i don't know three four
months of language school i was either
on a knee or standing
because i couldn't sit
you know eventually i was coming to
class one of those donuts you know it
was inflatable things that's how i was
doing so i mean
also not an academic
trying to learn a new language which i'm
convinced is
in the same area of the artistic side of
people's brains like if you can play
music or if you can paint
that's the art form of learning a
language my wife's a great example she's
both like she's a musician she's a
phenomenal artist she can pick up
foreign languages like that for me
nah dude it was it was brutal it was
just forced reps like that's how you do
it
so i mean and you have to test out you
have to test out like at a certain level
yeah you got to test that what are you
going to test out at
what i would say would be like a like a
between a beginner and a novice level to
have a working knowledge i think is the
way they kind of describe it where where
is that language school footprint jack
uh what what what were you you were a 18
bravo were you a bravo that was your
brother and how was that's part of the
schooling that was great yeah the bravo
course was awesome you know just
learning
weapons and and a little bit into
tactics but uh you're just playing with
guns all day did you pick that is that
what you wanted yeah so i picked my i
picked my mos and my language which
determines your group everyone that gets
selected or at least back then
picked those two things requested mos
and requested language
and they would give
i think it was the top like 15 or 20 of
the performers would get what they what
they asked for and then the rest would
get whatever they you know they needed
to get
so i requested bravo and i wanted
russian because i wanted to stay at
that third group what made you want to
be bravo
they're the ass kickers on the team
you know
stereotypically but also in reality
because you kind of you kind of have to
be man
and here's why
you're yes you train
on weapons and maintenance and
troubleshooting but you're also the
primary tactician on the team or the
primary tactical advisor to the team
sergeant is that that's your support
function on a team so you're putting
together ranges you're executing
training
well
every sf guy every soft guy
thinks that he is a
perfect tactician and a perfect max man
the other skill sets medics como
demo
those are much easier for those guys to
teach their teammates because they don't
have the pride associated with not
knowing medicine i don't have the pride
associated with not knowing how to use
this this radio
you walk up to a guy and say you don't
know how to use your rifle
that they don't take that very well so
you have to have an aggressive dominant
personality to be able to break through
that barrier that your teammates have to
be able to do your job
yeah they're gonna take that very
personally they don't like that
you know i don't like that like your mom
you can't shoot
and you don't understand tactics you
tell that to a green beret or steel or a
ranger that it's not gonna go well
yeah they're gonna have good stuff
they're gonna have a little bit of an
ego flare in those scenarios yeah and
how was uh how was robin sage
ramen sage was good i mean aside from
the infill which is it's just i mean
horrible we didn't jump thank god my
buddies was a good buddy of mine today
he was on one of the teams that had to
jump in
because you're everyone on that on that
team is carrying about 120 pounds
in their ruck
to you know sustain off of to conduct on
conventional warfare in a denied area
that's what robin sage is
the teams that have to jump in man
no not no dude
if i jump in without equipment i'm
coming in hot yeah you throw 120 pounds
on me
so i avoided a mark in the earth putting
dent in the earth yeah
so fortunately i didn't have to jump but
you know the infill the infield's tough
uh no matter whether you jump in a knot
and you're humping miles through north
carolina
but once you get past that
then you're actually operating
with other mls's which is the first time
that you get to see that because
it's the last thing you do and they
bring so now you can see what medics do
you can see what the 18 charlies do you
can see what the camo guys can do you
see the alphas you see the the team
leaders
up until you go to mls everyone's just a
candidate then you learn your job and
then you come together to execute your
job with the other team with the other
mosses
so i remember just
when we were on infill i started
cramping up and i needed to take a short
hull because i needed to stretch because
otherwise i was going to go down
and one of my teammates
yelled the word medic
which is the first time i had heard that
like in real life you're gonna hear the
movies but someone actually yelled medic
and then a medic showed up and i was
like oh this is like a real thing
we actually have you guys i hadn't seen
it before you know so it was cool to see
those different jobs and how they
employed themselves within a team
dynamic so it was actually a lot of fun
once you got past you know getting to
your your site how long is the freaking
infill
it usually takes
like two to three days oh damn to get in
yeah i mean it every every route is
different
it's usually it's trains planes and
automobiles and a lot of walking so you
know horse trailer from here to here you
get there you walk you know 12 miles
through the wood line link up over here
jump on a boat move down this river you
know it's like a full-on
infill as if you're going into actual
denied area that's what they try to
replicate
you get done with that that's that's it
right that's when you get your
your designation your green beret that's
it yeah
did your parents come down for that oh
yeah did your mom put any crystals in
your green brain she probably did
she blew some incense on me do you have
like one green beret that you got that
one time
like and that's
the one that you get and the one that
you keep the actual head gear yeah so i
still have the same one as the one i
graduated with right so that's is that
pretty common i think that that's
most common unless a guy like loses it
we don't really wear it that often
though so there's there's no real need
to upgrade because you like destroyed it
it's kind of funny man you spend all
this time thinking about becoming one
and you want to earn this little green
hat more than anything it's on the top
of this mountain it means everything to
you you're willing to put it all on the
line
and then you get it
and then you never want to wear it
because it's just a pain in the ass to
put on your head
so we don't usually wear our uniform all
that often anyway
but when we do obviously it goes on so
i think that's part of the reason why
most guys the one that they had
originally is the one that they keep
throughout their career yeah no uniform
is always not fun i remember uh i always
thought to myself man i'm like a i'm
like a 30 35 38 year old dude i go to
work all day don't have to wear a shirt
man this is the this is the life i'm
freaking good to go yeah uh but your
parents came down to graduation and all
that absolutely
how'd they feel about that because now
what year is it
2010.
okay
so iraq is kind of chilled out by now
so you must just be eyeing afghanistan
at this point yeah so at this point i
know i'm going to third group which is
at bragg which is the one i wanted to go
to because third group owned afghanistan
for the for the groups for the sf groups
that's all third group did the other
groups would filter in and support but
third group owned afghanistan that's
where i wanted to go that's why i chose
that language that's where i ended up
going so
from my parents perspective of course
they were proud
of the work
and happy for me for being successful
but also petrified because they knew
what was coming and this was 2010 you
joined in 2007. damn that's a long
freaking pipeline yeah
yeah that's a long pipeline now it's
much more streamlined so the current q
course they've cut that white space in
between so they give guys maybe it's a
week or two or so off and it's it's a
much faster turnover rate got it yeah
so you get how was it checking into to
the battalion
it was i mean i showed up
never having been like a real unit
before other than as a student
and you don't get a whole lot of
guidance it's like report the third
group on this day it's like over there
somewhere i'm like okay
so you find it right and then i walk
into like group headquarters building
and there's like some e5 working the cq
desk
and i'm like hi i'm here to report to
first battalion he's like okay
it's over there i'm like all right roger
that so i got meander over there and the
funny story is i'm walking around
the battalion
trying to get all these little boxes
checked off right check in with s1 which
is your admin section check in with s2
your intel section like get yourself
administratively within the unit
i've never heard of s4 i don't know what
it is
like what's okay it's over here i find
it what do i need from you guys classic
so i'm meaning around pretty lost
clearly i was lost because dude comes up
to me in pt's and he's like you need
help finding something and i'm like yeah
man i'm looking for this like s6 thing
he's like yeah it's over there
and as soon as i start talking he's like
you from boston i'm like yeah he's like
i'm from boston i'm like oh no kid so we
start talking about the socks and the
pats
where you're from which neighborhood
whatever we're just like bullshitting
and he's like come on let me show you
something
following this guy i have no idea who it
is he brings me into it into an office
he's got red sox pictures on the walls
all this memorabilia
we're just we're chopping it up
and i realize
i'm in the battalion commander's office
oh dang i haven't dropped a single sir
yeah
i have no idea what i'm talking about
and it's like dawning on me
and i'm like all right but i'm just
going to keep going with this because
like he seems cool with it maybe this is
just the way it is i don't know it's my
first day in the eunuch
and then i just hear this bellowing
voice
from the the office next to it
and this was sergeant major spratt oh
command sergeant major spratt who had
just left swick
which is where the q course in selection
is
and came back to third group
and he had some
specific language about you know asking
very politely who was talking to the
battalion commander that way
and he walked in the office and he's an
old school sf guy man old school like
big mustache big chest right walks in
yelling at me
i look over the side commander like are
you gonna are you gonna step in here and
he's just laughing i thought we were
boys i thought we were buddies you know
he's he hangs me out to dry completely
so spratt's like you know looking at my
name he's like i heard you he's like you
know he's like you're one of those
combatives guys right you're one of
those like mma fighter type dudes and i
was like uh i don't know if i should say
yes to this
i feel like you may want to challenge me
out back and i don't know how that will
go
i'm like yes
yeah that is me and he's like okay well
basically uh don't ever talk to the boss
like that again and like get out of here
and like go find your company what gave
you that reputation as being an mma guy
because what just because you wrestled
or were you did you pick up jiu jitsu
and stuff along the way so i ended up
getting uh macp which is the army
combatives program cert
one and two during basic training that
they offered to just like guys that were
proficient with
um combat sports so i showed up to the
unit um that with that
and then uh or during the q course
and then actually
when i was in robin sage um alan shabaro
who's a
jiu-jitsu black belt former third group
sf guy he was a cadre for a different
field team out robin stage
and uh he came over one night randomly
and was like hey uh you know i heard
you're into like combatives and stuff
like that you know come check out my gym
once you get out of here and you
graduate and whatnot that was my intro
into into jiu jitsu
so i've been training with him a little
bit before i actually showed up on day
one i just think maybe word kind of just
traveled kind of quick you know or
whatever but
so that's your welcome aboard you
freaking bro out with the battalion
commander and then get your ass shoot
yeah jude
and how long does it take for you before
you get into
like an oda
i was on my first team probably
probably a week or two after that
because the timing was interesting my
entire company
was forward in afghanistan but they only
had about a month left before they were
coming back
every team except for one of them was
forward and there was a team that was uh
that deployed offset from the rest of
the company in the battalion because it
was a specialized team
so it took my company sergeant major a
little bit of time a couple days to
think about
where to put me because i met him that
day my very first day i made him over
the company met the sergeant major
introduced himself
he said cool man like what are your
goals i said i want to get in
afghanistan like now he's like of course
you do but like the entire company's
coming back it doesn't make any sense by
the time you get there and get situated
you're going to just be packing things
up and come home so the timing's not
there
but i do have this team that's set to go
forward in a few months
i'm like cool can i go to that one he's
like well it's it's a different type of
team so like let me think about it
he did eventually i sat down with the
with the team sergeant of that team and
this team focused on preparation of the
environment it's the task that we were
assigned
so kind of like left of bang type stuff
which isn't exactly what i wanted to do
i wanted to go kick down doors and shoot
bags in the face this team was not
designed to do that
but it was more designed to find the bad
guys so that someone can go kick him in
the face
it's designed to facilitate the door
kick is to get to the guy or get to the
area right so i mean that was that type
of work
and it was a very senior team because
most guys would go spend you know a few
years on a standard oda and then they
would migrate over into this type of
stuff so senior dudes
um but eventually that's the route that
i went when i was on that team within a
couple weeks of getting a group i mean
i'm just gonna say like you're a new guy
you're checking in you get a chance to
go to afghanistan in in a more rapid
manner they could probably told you like
hey we need to cook to go to afghanistan
in a month you'd have been like i'm in
roger that at least i know i would have
been i'm like cool where's the freaking
uh spatula where's the ladle
yeah
let's do this
uh
did you have any time to like prep was
there any type of work up were they
already done with all that
no there was a workup um i think maybe
yeah like i said i think i was on the
team about four months before we we
infilled so i went and i learned dari
which is a prominent language in
afghanistan so i spent six months in the
queue course getting my ass kicked
learning russian show it to my group
and they're like welcome go learn diary
like
kidding me i can't get away from this
language thing man which
i understand the value of it now
actually even once i was able to employ
it
so it was three months of that and then
some like preparatory
collective training that we did
but it was pretty fast and furious
before i was out the door
and then you how was that deployment
what was it like when you got there
it was amazing um
you know initially i wanted to come in
do my five-year contract get some
payback for 911 learn some skills and
then get out this was not going to be
like my profession or my career and then
i got to the ground i got on the ground
in afghanistan it was a nine month
rotation mostly down in kandahar
we were mostly doing split team stuff uh
so one team was on the [__] border and
the other team was in like downtown
kandahar so i was getting a chance to
see
more rural and urban environment and
because of the team i was on i was
seeing
the more overt stuff where we get in
like mounted gun trucks to go support a
particular op to being in a soft skin
corolla driving through downtown
kandahar and civilian clothes so i was
exposed to a lot of what odas can do
what sf guys can do
aside from the thing i really wanted to
do
you know so we did end up getting into a
couple little things
somewhat by accident but
it was in that deployment that i uh i
couldn't imagine doing anything else i
decided like this is what i'm gonna do
for my career and i reenlisted actually
in afghanistan for like another six i
think it was beyond
my current contract i was on
so it was great man so was the op tempo
good where you were working all the time
busy busy yeah yeah no no like sitting
around for long periods of time you were
getting after it all the time no no it
was it was super busy
and that's cool you get to get exposed
to a wide spectrum of different
things that are happening you get to see
a lot you know that's a freaking great
first deployment for you yeah and i was
again i was with all these senior guys
so i was an e5 and everyone else was e7
or eight or an officer
so i'm just learning from these dudes
that have been around for a really long
time and you know some of them were on
their fifth sixth afghanistan pump so
i'm just i'm drinking from a fire hose
but
um just the knowledge that was coming in
from these dudes it just
got caught the bug and i was like yeah
this is it this is this is for me
you get done with that deployment um
you said you got into some things i mean
you get you getting some gun fights you
guys got a few gun fights over there on
that one yeah yeah but not nothing that
like uh was too major no no it was
nothing anything all that serious but
what's what's funny about it is because
the mission that we were on is not
designed for us to be in those
environments
but you know there would be like a lures
unit or like a another unit over here
that was going out to this area for
whatever mission they had and we're like
well maybe there's something out there
we can check out that is in line with
that mission i don't know maybe i can
talk to someone over there
maybe there's i don't know something
so we would just get added on yeah
and then some things would happen but
because of our team and our reporting
channels it was different than the other
units in the ao
so even though we had been in these
engagements there was no like reporting
of it happening
at one point the commander that we
actually worked for
heard about some stuff and he showed up
to our site
we were working under uh nsw so like it
was a seal05 that showed up
and he's like
how's everything going blah blah blah
first time i met him he's like okay so
just so you know i know what you guys
are doing
and you need to stop
i'm like roger that's there so check
yeah
trying to keep the boys trying to keep
the boys down come on
uh so you come home from that deployment
what's next
a ton of
schools and training
individual schools
at that time we were doing
usually with six months on nine months
off before we would re-rotate uh for me
i think it was ended up being around
nine or ten i was back in the states but
it was just individual school one after
another
and then um
i went back over on afghanistan for a
short period of time with on a tasking
from another unit that needed some
support and so i went over there for a
quick little thing
and came back and then
like how long was that when you say a
quick little thing was it like months or
was it like four months like 90 days
okay 90 maybe 120 days somewhere between
three and four months
all right now are you still with the the
same
oda this whole time yeah so you still
are kind of focused on the same type of
mission
yes until i get back from afghanistan
and then my company sergeant major
decides he wants to put me on a standard
oda or a direct action-focused oda so
this is after your sec after that 90-day
stint yeah so on the 90-day stint you're
over there did you get some good lessons
learned from that deployment oh yeah
what'd you take back from that one
that there are
other units within the socom enterprise
that operate at an entire different
stratosphere
which i could tell even as a junior
green beret working on you know around
oda guys
there are other people out there that
are really good at what they do
and they know how to do it so i was a
i was a
a riding on the side of this thing they
just needed some support it was first
psd stuff okay
it came over the third group because
we're cola we're on fort bragg and they
needed like a bigger combatives psd type
dude just to like
take orders and not talk or ask
questions and i was the guy that got man
i got this all day i didn't know really
like what i was doing i understood like
psd work yeah but
who i was with and what we were doing it
took me like a while
to like figure that out
but i learned a ton
and that was really what sunk my teeth
into what my next thing would be post
oda time
did you are you still are you training
jiu jitsu all the time now yeah
so when you got back and what about when
you're on deployment are you training at
all do you have time oh yeah you're like
make time yeah
yeah every trip i've been on i've built
a built a little fight house yeah even
into like austere stuff we're getting
into the next actual rotation we're in
the mountains
doing vso when i built us a fight house
up there
so that's so you come back from the
90-day stint where you're doing psd type
work
and then you get put in now this one
you're getting put into like a d.a type
oda yeah yeah i get back and my my deal
was i would do two rotations on the
first team i was on
and i committed to that uh because
there's a lot of time they spent in
training you know how to do certain
stuff so i was like yeah there's no
problem
sergeant major came in um right after i
got back and he's like uh
hey man i'm gonna talk to your team
sergeant but i think you need to be on
like a like a da team you know you're
like you don't fit in
in this team you're on now you don't
blend you're like you're like anywhere
you're the worst low visibility guy in
the history of freaking special forces
yeah man so it didn't make sense from
that lens and i was young and hungry and
he wanted to like you know maximize on
that leverage that get me into the fight
for a more traditional sense so
he met with my team side team sounds
like cool man this is what he wants this
is what's best for him roger that so he
let me go and then i went to a d.a team
uh this is now in
like early 2012
and i was with them just in time to go
through a full
train up nice of that type of work
before we went in on what was my second
actual combat rotation
in the fall of 2012.
and so how's that how's that working out
it was it was night and day man my first
pump
doing what we were doing we were living
kush
we were living
everyone had their own shoe i had air
conditioning i had a full-size bed i had
a plasma tv
two different chow halls two different
gyms
full-blown fight house because i one of
our camps was in the was like on the
back end
of a mass of a bigger fob
so we had all the fob stuff but then we
had our own our own stuff you know oga
camp was right next to us they had a
whole bunch of good cool stuff so i was
but that was no that was just the way it
was yep my first trip yeah like this is
the way this isn't living off the land
are you kidding me i haven't had to kill
a single snake yet
these snake eaters
i got two chow halls to choose from
when i switched teams and went to the
d.a team
we went in to do via vso
village stability operations
and that by design is very austere you
actually have limitations on what you
can do to build up your physical
infrastructure to keep it within line
with what your partner force
or those within that area with how they
live when we assimilate to them
which is exactly the mission we wanted
but when you get dropped off on you know
mountaintop helicopter zero three
and you're the first team that's
occupied this site
there's nothing
and it was like oh this is what
odas do this is okay this is what this
so it was a night and day
shift from my first trip to my second so
now you're out in the middle of where
are you wardak you're so you're in
wardak
just your oda team in the middle of
nowhere so there were three teams that
they inserted into wardak along the
chalk valley um two on one side one on
the other but it was really just us to
mutually support each other
and you are
starting from scratch building out what
you're going to build out
because there's no pre-existing team
there at all there's no turnover or
nothing there was a turnover only
because the team
that was on the ground when we got there
they had closed down their site which is
where we were originally planning on
going but as things changed
operationally they shut that site down
they packed up all their stuff they
moved to
this secondary location
they were on the ground for 24 hours
before we landed
so so there's nothing there there's
nothing there there was a team there but
they hadn't been working out of that
site right so then you guys start
building out do you have a partner force
that's there yeah so they handed over
their partner force to us which was a an
a sf team so the regiment the army
special forces had created
an afghan national army special forces
unit and they looked structurally the
same way as us same moss's same
breakdown and they had 12 guys or
whatever
12 guys just like ours
so you show up there
you get settled in and is the ao how hot
is the
ao it was it was it was busy it was hot
um
we
got our footprint you know we're like
patrol base activities for the first
like 48 until we got some semblance of
some force pro going
and then on maybe day three or four
we uh we went to drive down the street
to uh afghan local police checkpoint
which you could see from our camp it was
maybe 400 meters down the road
i think we had a four vehicle convoy i
was in the trail vehicle working out of
a hatch
and by the time a second vehicle got on
the road we were ambushed
so at this point we've got like some
ratty chain-link fence and some
half-filled hesco as like force pro
there's nothing you know other than guys
that are
up there with 240s
so
and i'm like what i don't know what's
happening what kind of vehicles we were
in matt vs um and then ig 33 ig-31 so
i'm a bombered you know they're legit
yeah
but even though i had been around a
couple you know engagements prior
it was nothing like this like we were
like ambushed this wasn't some you know
[__] who got creative with an ak-47 who
wanted to get his jihad on for a second
and then drop his gun and run away this
was like a no [__]
we're going to fight right now
so
this is you're not even all the way out
of the gate no
no it's all right there so we they
dropped us off into a hornet's nest you
know which we kind of knew although we
were prepping for location a
we ended up at location b but they were
relatively close where a lot about intel
and prep in terms of personalities and
leadership and cells and who he would be
targeting
was still considered the same
i didn't realize it was going to be
quite that level of
of beehive
so zero white space uh which became our
primary mission
was just to open that up
so every day or every other day whenever
we rolled it was just like move to
contact like that's the that's the
mission for today that's what we're
doing let's go find the ambush and like
set it off and you're going out with
your team plus the
afghan sf team so you got like 20 25
guys
so we also had uh an infantry
squad that was there as an uplift so
about 20 22 um sorry maybe about 15
dudes you're all super young minus their
their squad leader most of them were
just fresh out of basic right on young
and hungry though oh yeah i can work
with that all day you can give me a
blank canvas i i love me some blank
canvas so it was it was there there was
studs like savages eventually we created
some savages
afghan national army sf team was i was i
dedicated patent force eventually within
i said the first month or so we started
doing
bigger ops and we'd bring in
afghan national army guys or another
commando element or afghan national
police guys
and this leads to you know me me
eventually getting shot up
with an insider attack is because when
you start getting
all these different dudes from different
units
there's no practical way to establish a
baseline with these with these guys you
know if you're living with somebody you
get to know that way you can tell if
something's off like the spidey sense
can start to go off
because it's different
when you're getting new bodies as
frequent as eventually we were
uh it drastically opens up the risk
for an insider threat yeah
uh you end up do you get wounded early
huh in this deployment is this when you
get wounded for the first time yeah what
happened there yeah um i eventually i
ended up taking some shrapnel to to the
back of my shoulder we were on the
ground for
i don't know just a few weeks
we you know we drove the contact we
actually had an actual mission other
than like let's go find a fight to get
into
we did get ambushed on the way uh from
what ended up being
what we considered to be the taliban
strong point village within our
immediate ao
it was the first time that we actually
maneuvered into it
and uh my team sergeant would tell you
himself like he made a he made an
aggressive
decision that's gonna piss some people
off to go in there
yeah um and we were way over our heads
and we were outgunned and outmanned you
know because he just took myself one of
my teammates and then a handful of uh of
our patent force guys and we maneuvered
dismounted into the into the village
just like the six of us
we had swore by fire machine gun coming
from the trucks and some mortars but
like we were in a village now you're in
like a more urban environment with three
u.s three patented force we've been on
the ground just a few weeks
you know an era and he'll tell you the
same thing like it was a mistake
me actually getting hurt may have
may have saved that because we fought
our way to
a two-story structure where we were
taking disk of fire from up to the road
so the guys are engaged in that way
there's some other dudes on some
rooftops and there's six of us
maneuvering through
an urban environment an afghanistan
urban environment different than like
iraq but you're still dealing with
buildings and multiple level structures
and windows and doors and all the
hallways and alleyways all the things
right so
i even noticed at one point
i'm like we shouldn't be here right now
you know we shouldn't be here right now
this is a mistake i didn't voice that i
was like roger that like let's keep
going and we made it to
the structure that we were trying to
breach to deal with the with the disc
that was coming out of the second story
and um we had been receiving some some
indirect that were coming in and uh
dudes were dropping grenades out of
structures as well
so we're at the breach point to enter
the courtyard into this structure that
is still actively engaging
and something just blows up behind me
there's a grenade and it just it ripped
into the back of my shoulder and it was
like getting hit with a
sledgehammer
you think about
shrapnel penetrating your body you may
think it's like this like piercing
stabbing sensation like a piece of metal
going into you but it's more just impact
someone just hits you with a bat
and then i look back
and there's just like a lemon-sized hole
in the back of my shoulder i'm like oh
okay
this just happened
so
uh i immediately just like no i'm fine
now adrenaline's pumping
it's a shock but there's no real pain
that sets in
i'm like we're good my team sergeant
comes over and he's like no no so he
grabs my other teammate he starts
putting some we get into like a little
strong point
he got he gauzes it up is the disc is
still firing
yes that's good times yep so that's
still going off
the boys on the trucks are really the
ones that are getting it um
and our partner force had dead sending a
separate dismount just themselves to
stop moving in towards the building as
well
so they're they're treating me some
gauze comp you know pressure dressing
wrap it up
and uh
my team's not just like
we're we're aborting this mission right
now again we're getting back to trucks
and i'm like no no i'm fine like let's
go we just fought our way all the way to
this door that we're in front of now
like let's let's get in there
he's like no no no
this is
we're in alvarez
so that was the that was the trigger for
him to be like yep let's detach and take
a look at what i'm doing
uh so a lot of ways i think i'm grateful
because i don't know what was on the
other side of that door but those guys
were still getting it and it could have
been it could have been a lot of
different things yeah
you know
yeah i
sometimes the things just pile up
where you know i used to joke you know
you have the no-go criteria like hey
this is no-go criteria we don't have
aircraft or we don't have this we don't
have that and i used to joke and say hey
we just have go-go criteria because
we're [__] going like that was like
you know my attitude but then
this thing would happen something else
would happen something else would happen
and it would be like this is a sign like
these one sign i can overlook two signs
maybe i'll ignore but now we got three
four things that are going on that don't
seem right it's like hey we're getting
out of here this is a bad call and it
sounds like he came to that conclusion
yeah which you know you got one wounded
guy you got a bunkered freaking disc
elements maneuvering through this city
yeah
could go sideways real quick i mean
uh how much different does that impact
does that shrapnel have to hit you where
all of a sudden you're not just a
wounded guy you're a dead guy or you're
a severely wounded guy i mean two inches
freaking it's ridiculous how those
little things can change
uh the whole the whole scenario
how bad were you actually hurt once you
guys pulled out
it it wasn't it wasn't bad you know i
get back to the trucks and uh we
we itb and my medic takes a look at it
he's like dude you're good but
it's like a pretty good hole here man so
this was the first time anyone had been
wounded we'd have been in the ground
maybe just like a few weeks like i said
and so he he gets medevaced out
and i throw a temper tantrum
at the camp i'm like i'm not going
anywhere and my team said it's like yes
you are i'm like
so i i think i'm going to germany i
think i'm going home like we just got
here this is where i need to be
you know i'm really childish
in my response to that
but i do and i get back to they sent me
to one of the
one of the outstations where there
actually was a was a forward surgical
team and they treated it and the way
they treat that is they pack it with
this antiseptic gauze because they can't
just sew it shut because it'll leave
this open cavity no it'll get infected
for infection so they pack it and then
you just change that dressing out you
know three four times a day so it closes
from the inside out
it was it really wasn't a big deal i was
supposed to stay at that location
until it was completely healed
the head the head dock who was at bagram
was made aware of my wound and he said
nick will stay where you are
until it's closed to make sure there's
no infection how'd that work out
[Laughter]
yeah
after about
final three four days i start getting
anxious
and the only rotary wing flights that
were going into my site where my team
was was coming out of bagram so either
way i had to get to bagram before i
could initiate movement back to jalrez
which is where we were
well i grabbed one of my buddies who's
on that support team that was there and
i said bring me down to the tarmac which
he does
and i go from one c-130 to another one
until i find one that's going to boggle
just hitch in a ride and i go up to the
top i'm like hey you guys going to bag
room it was like the third plane i
walked on and they're like yeah we're
taking off in like 10 minutes i'm like
can i come with you they're like sure so
i just jump in the plane i don't tell
anybody where i'm going
land at bagram i had been to bagram
before that's where we originally landed
when we got there but i was only on
bagram for like a day until we just got
all the stuff together and then we flew
out to our site
so i wasn't familiar with bagram at all
which back then it was like a city i
mean bagram's huge
so i land i have no idea really where i
am i know that the special ops camp is
in the vicinity of this so i find my way
over there
and i walk into the jock
and it was my first time actually being
in like a real jock i hadn't seen one
before with all the tvs and all the
different staff sections and they're all
wired in it was like
this is kind of cool i hadn't seen it
before and i walk in and the
sodif commander who's my battalion level
command team they're the ones that are
running the sodif special operations
task force
he's like
hey what are you what are you doing here
and i'm like hey sir how you doing you
know i need a ride back to uh to jarez
this dude's from boston
so he starts going off he had actually
brought in
a
bleacher seat chair that he bought that
used to be in fenway park
as his like battle chair
hell yeah so because they refurbished
fenway and they sold a bunch of stuff so
he brings this over with him to
afghanistan so rather than focus on why
i am there he just wants to show me his
chair he's like dude look at the chair
i've broken this crate this one used to
be out you know fenway park whatever and
i'm kind of like yeah sir that's awesome
that's an awesome yeah well then the
then this sort of command sergeant major
walks over and he's like no really what
are you doing here
i like how you can always snow the
officers but they're freaking an e dogs
man they're on to your
[__]
there was no any jedi thing happening
with him he's like why are you here and
i'm like coming up with some [__]
that doesn't float and then the phone
rings
and
he picks it up
and i hear the yelling on the other end
of the phone
and it's my company sachimedia who is at
the location that i had just left from i
have been gone maybe
three hours or something four hours
and i hear him screaming and csm is like
oh no he's right here in front of me
and i'm like okay now i know this is
about me
am i going to get court-martialed like
what happens i don't know i know i'm in
trouble
so he hands me the phone and
my company sergeant major just loses his
mind on me you know
for like 10 minutes and i'm just like
roger that roger that a lot of that
going on and at the end he's like okay
dude listen like i get it
i get it i've been there before i get it
but like don't ever do that again
i said roger that hang up
well
now everyone's kind of joking about it a
little bit csm thinks it's kind of cool
but he's also trying to be professional
there's a lot of people around i've
clearly just done something and
subordinate
it was it was the the commander
eventually gets switched on he's like oh
wait what did you really just do that
well
my team's on a mission right at that
point my first time in a jock i just got
yelled at which is fine
we're kind of joking and uh i look up
red lights that's going off you know
essential personnel only inside the jock
people are leaving people are coming in
people are getting spun up i can tell
something's going on
and it's my team on and off and my team
sergeant takes a round to the abdomen
and i'm watching this for the first time
through the lens of you know an isr feed
i've never seen it before
and it takes me a minute to realize
what's happening and i put two and two
together and i have you know an
emotional breakdown of like rage and i'm
like throwing chairs uh immature
completely emotionally charged
response a reaction
and i'm like you guys need to give me a
ride
now
i'm going back
and i get pulled out of the jock and uh
the dock shows up
and i'm with the
group or the
sodif commander
and the sort of csm and the dock comes
over and uh
he's like why are you here you need to
wait till you're healed you're not going
back
and i start yelling at him
and then the commander's like listen doc
i don't think you want to tell this dude
like no
like he's
he just like
jumped on a plane and flew here like
he's like he's getting he's going back
so they overrode that decision and i was
back on a bird the next day or the day
after that
back out with the team and what happened
to you the guy that got wounded
would you say that was your team
sergeant yep so he came in i was there
to meet him at the hospital when he
showed up to bagram which was good he
went into surgery he was medevac out of
country he was over in germany i don't
think he ended up going back to the
states because he returned back in
to the team he was out of the game for
maybe a month or two
and then he came back over
do you guys have any kind of backfill
plan i mean you only got 12 dudes
someone get when someone gets hit that's
like a freaking significant amount of
the force
yeah every dude does play a big role
um
we didn't get
outfitted with the with the new team
sergeant just the next senior guy on the
team
picked it up yep
um
oftentimes we will get augmented by
by one of the support teams that's in
the area yeah cause i mean you got 12
guys like that's
that's a freaking an important gun i'm
just like legit like just a gunner
even vehicles like whatever you're doing
that's freaking crazy to think about
that you lose two or three guys like
you're almost
you need replacement sometimes oh yeah
uh so you get back up there now how
often are you what's your op tempo like
like how often are you guys going out
yeah we're going out
probably three four times a week
and and most of the time do you have
things that you're doing are you trying
to do civil affairs out there or are you
going out patrol to contact like what
are you guys actually trying to do yeah
so our mission was to
open up
uh
white space open up freedom of maneuver
so that some of the other units in the
entire ao had the ability to begin their
ex-fill process
so this is 2012 going into 2013.
the writings on the wall that we're
about to close down afghanistan so the
units on the ground are making those
preparations
to be able to get men with weapons and
equipment to
bagram into kandahar so we needed to
open up some lanes so does that mean
you're are you setting up combat
outposts out there or you just going out
clearing and then leaving what are you
doing no so the afghan local police
concept was built specifically for this
where we would
build and or
reinforce
checkpoints along the major avenues
throughout the ao so there were these
afghan local police checkpoints
that were all down the major roads so we
were rather building those out
validating the ones that were already
there
training the guys that were there or
bringing in like resources and stuff to
make them more effective so let's say
you might oh we got this checkpoint down
there checkpoint four we're gonna go out
there today we're gonna check their
first structure we're gonna meet with
their people we're going to give them
some pistol training and then we're
going to come back yep that's kind of
like the type of stuff that you were
doing yeah that and then we were tied
also into the local and regional
government officials
um to help them with their structure and
their building out and just gaining more
control of the area from like a civil
and diplomatic perspective which
it's a tough task to do that in
afghanistan so we mostly focused on
afghan local police
enhancement via checkpoints along the
major routes what's the local populist
populists think of you
hit or miss
in an area like that you're really
putting the local populace in a
lose-lose scenario
we come in big big white guys big
american guys tatted up with all the
guns and the stuff and we come in and be
like you're going to help us
were they going to say no
well the problem is when they say yes
the actual dudes that run the show in
that whole area they're going to come
back
so you know it's it's tough and they
know those those americans they know
that they're going to leave someday the
local populace like oh you're here now
but
the taliban's going to be here forever
yeah
so it's it's impossible
is it is the biggest threat on the
ground ieds at this point
at this point the biggest threat on the
ground was ieds and then a close second
would be the insider attack
which once that happened to us
uh in
what it ended up being early 2013 on the
same deployment that was kind of the
catalyst that drove that threat up to
supersede ieds within that immediate
area because it was just so effective
you ended up getting shot again right or
you get shot
yeah in the what in the face in the face
yep i took an ak round um which sounds
worse than it was it really just grazed
my cheek and you know
ripped the chunk open it did clip an
artery so it bled a bit but
i didn't know that i had been shot for
like
an hour or two after the fact because it
was the result of a
a massive id that hit our lead vehicle
decimated the truck
and when i showed up
to that vehicle
there were some dismounts that had
showed up as well this was a full-on
ambush so we'll talk us through it so
you're out on patrol how many vehicles
you got with you so we had i think it
was four trucks and a couple
side-by-side raises
uh on that we were returning to base
from the from the thing we just did like
a kle a key leader engagement how how
far away are you from like what are
these are these like four mile five mile
transits are they shorter than that this
one was a little longer this one we
drove out along the main road maybe nine
miles 10 miles
and we were on the way back
when
we hit this and we had driven down this
road multiple times before
um and this thing had been in place
before all that they just did they never
set it off
lead vehicle which has my team leader in
it he uh that that vehicle gets just
decimated what vehicle are you in i'm in
vehicle four working out of a hatch
and i see it go off in front of me and
we had hit a bunch of small ieds before
so i was familiar with it but this thing
was it the the biggest and the most
accurately timed it just boom it was
perfect
picks up the truck and just launches it
off the side of the road down into this
apple apple orchard off to the side and
it was down this little ravine
uh off the side of the road and that was
the initiation of a complex ambush so
pkm uh ipg
some indirect are all coming in
and uh
you know i know what
react to ideas we have that sop
established
and i don't do my job it's an important
note
instead i jump out of this hatch the
vehicle's still moving and i take off on
foot towards the truck
which is you know a couple hundred
meters away from me
not a tactical movement by me like rifle
in hand and i'm just at a dead sprint
to the vehicle
and i slide down off the side of the
road into this into this orchard
and i i know you're solo this is a solo
yeah yeah i'm just going by myself
i know everyone's dead right there's no
way anyone survived that level of
destruction the truck is on its side so
driver's side door is pinned against the
ground passenger side door would be
facing the sky
and i i slept off the road and i trip
and fall
and what i had tripped over was my
teammate who was in the turret of that
truck who was ejected
and
landed about 30 meters from the vehicle
i didn't see him i trip over him look
back and it's him and he's alive i can't
believe it his legs snapped in half just
below his knee
uh he's got a whole bunch of other like
lacerations on his face
but he's alive he's suffering from
immediate blast injury for sure he's
incoherent but he's alive he's breathing
he's not bleeding from anywhere
profusely so
i do like a quick
assessment of him and then i start
hearing different rounds impacting the
truck which is behind me about 30 meters
and some dismounts that showed up and
they were just kind of
randomly shooting at the vehicle this
they're shooting at the blown-up vehicle
yeah so just ting ting ting i turn
around
just three of them
um so i smoked two the third one takes
off running and this isn't again an
apple orchard but it's in october or
it's in november so there's not a lot of
vegetation there's just mostly trees and
branches so you can i can see kinda but
there's just a lot of so i'm maneuvering
through this
he's running away from me
on an angle with his ak over his
shoulder
firing been my general direction while
running away
and next thing you know i'm looking up
at the sky boom i felt an impact i'm
looking up at the sky and i thought that
i had
run into a branch from a tree and it
just knocked me over
so i pop up
and i like kind of look around and i'm
fine
and
i go to re-engage on this dude and i
noticed the vehicle
is on fire and i hadn't checked the
vehicle i had only i've only seen one of
my buddies
so as bad as i really want to go kill
this dude i was like i'm gonna go check
the vehicle instead so
fortunately the passenger door which
against facing the sky had been blown
off the hinges
because the truck had basically
collapsed on itself so the turret was
you couldn't there was no access point
inside the cab other than that door
climb up the vehicle
uh
look in and my team leader is buried
kind of where the driver's seat would be
and he's trying to establish comms
which just says a lot about like
training and like just doing what you
need to do regardless of how bad it gets
i mean he's in an exploded vehicle and
he's a mess
uh both his legs are nasty he's a below
the knee amputee now both his legs are
completely mangled
he's got an arterial bleed through his
arm his face is completely
riddled with spall
and he's on the radio in a destroyed
decimated truck trying to establish
comps communicate to high uh what's
going on says a lot about that dude
well i'm looking inside this vehicle you
know we're still taking pkm and rpg now
our trucks are set up they're returning
fire we got a couple about 60 millimeter
motors out their return of fire
team sergeant uh who uh our acting team
sergeant at the time he's got a maneuver
element that's maneuvering on the ambush
line
i don't think anyone really knew like
where i even was
because i'm in the middle of all this
that's happening
i look inside the truck i see him okay
truck's on fire it's burning from the
back towards the cab
i look inside the rounds from inside the
vehicle are starting to pop off from the
heat
so it's like looking into a like a
popcorn bag pop pop pop pop rounds are
still taking off the front of the truck
from the enemy machine gun fire i'm like
this is a really bad day here and
that this is where it ends
there's no way either one of us are
making out of this
my team leader played offensive line at
west point
big cat this is the dude that's legs are
cr smangled yep trying to make calms on
the on the radio yeah a captain so he's
a big jack dude big boy i wouldn't say
jacked but like just a hoss
six seven about god about 290 225
without without kit
big boy with kid he's well over 300
pounds
and we used to joke about this
you know which is kind of ironic that he
and i could never
be in the same vehicle because
we were the only ones big enough to move
the other guy
if we needed to
which is what played out so i see him in
there big dude wedged in a pile of metal
that's on fire rounds outside the
vehicle rounds inside the vehicle anyone
else inside the vehicle no
how is that
so
it it seemed like
two got ejected
uh or three got ejected there were two
in the back the guy in the turret
and then the driver
managed to
i think scamper out of that of that
doorway
before i got there
were they afghans or americans those are
all americans
all americans except for want to buy
terps what about interpreters what's in
that truck
god i can't believe these guys made it
out of there yeah that's freaking crazy
it is it is crazy uh because i assume
they all lived but i assumed that
everyone would be dead based on the
level of damage
so i jump in the truck and uh
i kind of just like wedge him up a
little bit out of the out of the area
where he was kind of pressed him into
the into the dash
and then i climbed myself back out and
then just grabbed his kit and just like
dead lifted him out of this thing
and just chucked him over the side of
the truck and at this point some of our
partner force guys had showed up a
couple of my teammates had showed up so
they took him
busted out a litter began you know
moving him
the truck pretty much burnt up
completely you know within like a minute
or so after we were both out
and then we just circled around to find
scoop up all the rest of the guys that
were just in like random areas
around set up a ccp and then
you know finished the fight and then
went to you know my med course action
how far back was it to
get back to base
we were maybe three four miles out so
did you go back before you casual back
the guys
no we set up an hlz right there um bird
came in we pushed out the dudes they did
launch a ground qrf element from one of
the sister teams that was in the valley
with us they showed up on the ground
we met evac to five or six guys that
were in that truck
right from there
and um
then eventually i got medevaced out
after do you guys gotta do you guys blow
that freaking truck in place or did it
burn so much that you didn't even have
to do anything i charlie they strapped a
couple charges to it um
but it was pretty much destroyed anyway
they recovered some of the combo stuff
and then dipped like the rest
but i was treating one of the guys in
the vehicle once we established a
ccp his uh one of our attachments one of
our nerdier attachments although
important
his eye had come out of his head so his
eye was like dangling down where his
cheek is so i was treating him you know
put the eye back in the socket and i'm
wrapping it up with gauze
and one of my teammates comes over and
just slaps some gauze against the side
of my face
and this is like 90 minutes after
initial contact and i'm looking up at
him like what are you doing
and he's like bro you're like gushing
blood
i'm like really
i'm like all right so he's holding this
thing against my face i'm putting this
guy's eye back in his head
and
then i you know stand up i take a look
at it i didn't take a look at it i'm
like talking to i'm talking to him
and uh my medic was like yeah i think
we're gonna need to get you out of here
to get that looked at
and uh
you know i threw another childish
type of tantrum right there i refused to
leave until the other guys were out and
then qrs showed up so they showed up
situation under control they were going
to escort them back to base
um
there was one bird that had come back in
so i jumped on that and then i was
backed up
and then how was it was the results of
that i mean what'd they do stitch it up
no they had to cauterize it
um i think just because it clipped an
artery so they sent me to bagram which
is where the rest of the guys were at
and
uh i wanted to just be with those dudes
i wasn't sure if some of them were gonna
live i mean some of them were like real
banged up so i wanted to get there and
be with them and
i had a little bit of a situation with
some of the army staff that were at the
at the hospital they have this protocol
where they don't allow a kit grenades
weapons like they secure all that stuff
into like a separate area i had never
been in a hospital like this before and
i just come blasting in the front door
angry looking for my teammates and you
know two or three of these little
like e3 med kids
were like stop physically like getting
in my way to try to take my weapons and
kit from me
and i did not appreciate that
at all fortunately one another another
sf guy that was there
came over and grabbed me and pulled me
in real tight and was like you need to
calm down man
so i gave him my my stuff
and uh there happened to be a
army reservist doctor was in bagram
who in his day-to-day job owns a plastic
surgery clinic so he's an ami doctor and
then he's a plastic surgeon in civilian
life he was the guy that treated me so
he pulls me over and he's like hey man i
gotta
i'm gonna cauterize your wound and then
i'm gonna i'm gonna sew it back up
um
i'm gonna get you on some pain
management stuff
like now like
intravenously
and i'm like no you're not doing that
and uh he's like no it's like gonna it's
gonna be unpleasant i'm like dude listen
doc like hit me with some lidocaine if
you want that's fine some like numb it
up
but you're not gonna put me out of my
mind i'm not going to be
stoned and drifting around this place in
pixie land
two of my teammates are in surgery three
other ones are bedside right there you
need to hurry up and do whatever this is
so i can go do my job which is to be
next to those guys right now
so the sort of commander had showed up
because there's six or now i think seven
of us wounded he shows up and
the doctor looks over at him
and
sort of command is like just just go
ahead and do it
so i'm laying down on my side and he
just this little medical welder that
goes in and you know like burns it back
together and then sews it shut and
you know it sucked but i was so angry
uh and filled with just rage and concern
that it really wasn't that big of a deal
and then you said all the guys that got
wounded they lived yeah
yeah
and yet how many of them got kazzabacked
out of country
all of them
so now how many guys you got left on
your freaking team
so
out of the out of the six only two were
sf guys okay our captain and our another
one of my weapons guys another one
another bravo the guy was in the turret
so they replaced
my our captain they gave us a new
captain
who was already in country he was
working as like a staff support officer
in one of the other locations they
pushed him to us
and then it's back to business
yeah
you get back up
and
it's like uh
you gotta adjust to this new captain
you gotta
work through the guys that you did lose
the other guys that that left even
though they weren't they weren't uh
attached to your oda but you gotta
replace them somehow so you can start
figuring the stuff out how how long did
it take for you guys we're going back
out on ops yeah there was definitely a
lag
that was the end of november so
right around early december was when the
snow came in anyway
and when you're at 75 78 100 feet in the
mountains i mean that's like real snow
like feet of snow
so the timing
was kind of good for us because
no one can move when you've got nine
feet of snow outside in the mountains so
everything just kind of goes on pause
for a little bit from like december
through like the end of january that's
where we got our new captain
we got plushed up with a couple more
attachments to backfill the dudes that
we had lost
so we had you know eight nine weeks
together just to kind of get our stuff
together bring the new captain up to
speed
so by the time we were ready to kind of
get back into it come early february
time frame he was
he was good to go
and then you start doing ops again yeah
um
and now you're working like you were
talking about earlier
you're starting to do some bigger ops
and you got a bunch of other afghans
coming in from different areas
different units
and that could be sketchy yeah and you
guys know it's sketchy
yeah
we
we prefer to keep our
our uh our task org with our internal
unit because we lit we lived with this a
asf team and we're talking about
like a broken down clay you know
structures like when i say we were
living together i mean we were living
together right so you you gain that bond
with those with those guys and you learn
them you learn their personalities their
character their their quirks
when you start throwing you know 100
random dudes at us because we're gonna
go do some massive village clearance
you don't know any of these guys we have
been training them like randomly
within our training cycle where we would
run through you know a couple days with
the afghan national army a couple days
with the afghan national police couple
days with the alp the local police guys
our own guys so there was a there was a
a system in place but they're still just
sending us whoever they wanted to go to
train in that day and
you know you said you mentioned earlier
like the threat ied threat started to
be
surpassed by the threat of an insider
attack
so
was there insider attacks before you
guys had yours yeah
and so you guys are full aware like this
[__] can happen yeah we were um
we didn't take it as seriously as we
should have
um
[Music]
we didn't prioritize it enough to
instill
greater mitigation criteria we had some
stuff in place but
we got we were sloppy i think as a
detachment
it's it's not anything you can prevent
by any means but
we could have done a better job to
mitigate it you know and a lot of the
lessons that have gone out from the
event with us which is still considered
the most catastrophic insider attack
since 9 11
is uh the lessons learned from that are
being employed now really much is like
as like pretty much a baseline
for all the guys that work with within
ditch
all right so so let's get there it's
march 11 2013
and you guys are getting ready for
some kind of a big operation what were
you doing to clearance what were you
planning to do
yeah we were doing a larger
village clearance i believe
my memory is
terrible during this whole time frame
because of me getting banged up that day
but i believe we were going to do
like a
48-hour
clearance with a with iran and we would
sit tight i think it was more of an alp
checkpoint establishment
mission to like begin building something
from nothing and so this is one of those
ops where you have a bunch of other
afghans that you don't know maybe you've
seen him sporadically
but i mean look you get a freaking group
of 100 afghans that you saw
three months ago
you know like who knows who these might
as well just been right anyone random uh
so you guys had some some standard
operating procedures as far as
what you would how you would conduct
these operations because you knew it you
know it is a threat you know that an
insider attack is there's some level of
threat to it so you have some standard
operating procedures about
how you're treating the afghans correct
and
keeping them some keeping some kind of
distance
and so what is basically like you would
only allow the leadership into the
compound that was kind of the standard
operating procedure yeah so our compound
had two layers to it internal which is
where we lived and where our op center
was
and then we had outside that perimeter
was where our motor pool was so we kept
on vehicles fuel weapons are not weapons
but other storage
so
our sop was
for an op
the units would show up they would stay
outside of our entire perimeter
the leadership would come into our motor
pool area
um
so we could brief them on what we were
doing
standard practice is you want to keep
that window where you notify your
partner force where you're going as
narrow as you can because they talk
so in an attempt to reduce
uh that word getting out we would just
tell them right there and then and then
we would roll
and that worked for us you know in the
bravo section the 18 bravo section
is responsible for base defense
right
so me my team and i are my section and i
we're the ones that put this together
team sergeant obviously is the one that
says yes
that's what we rolled with and it worked
um
that entire time
on this particular day
leadership comes in
and a ford ranger pickup truck
rolls in
and i immediately see it obviously it
sticks out to me because it's a
violation of the sop that we developed
and we've been executing two three times
a week for five and a half months
is it like a technical does it have a
mounted machine gun in it i wouldn't
call it a technical but there was a
mounted pkm in the back
i think a technical i mean i was in
eastern africa there's like different
kinds of like
mad max technicals yeah so it's not an
upgraded technical it's like the lowest
yeah form of a technical possible yeah
you know but but a mounted pkm in the
back 100 mounted pcam in the back that a
machine gunner could operate from a
standing position
uh
that rolls in with two dudes and i see
it and my first response wasn't
oh [__] this is a threat it was
you know these idiots just can't follow
instruction which is
pretty common in afghanistan so my first
response was just i'm annoyed that
you're you're doing this
and now i'm at a crossroads man and it's
either
do i address this problem right now and
error on the side of security
or do i let it ride
i go the more diplomatic route
where
my team sergeant talks to his leadership
or my commander talks to his leadership
and like we handle it after the fact
i went with
the more diplomatic options and you've
been working i mean you've had this sop
it's worked you've been working with a
bunch of afghans like all these idiots
it's all just kind of leaning you in
that direction of like oh these people
are stupid and
you know i'll square this away when
we're done with the brief yeah you know
and it's easy to look back and and judge
which i do to myself about how how easy
you can get complacent
which is true
but when you've seen so many things that
could have gone wrong that didn't
you become conditioned to
these types of mistakes or these types
these types of acts by your partner
force it's not they don't jump out as
these glaring red flashing holy [__]
lights but i noticed it and i'm like you
know what i'll deal with this later
let's just get through let's just get
through this mission
and we'll address it
uh after the fact
and uh
this is the perfect storm because we we
do the mission brief get our partner
force leadership up to speed on what
we're doing
and then we're doing our own team
internal comms checks so we're in a
circle
and you know you go around you go around
the circle right like alpha up bravo one
up bravo two up everyone's just checking
comms
the trucks are all pretty much right
behind me they're all up and running
comms are good in the truck weapons are
good in the truck first thing we do well
when i got our vehicle set up
i had
left my go bag
my rifle
and then my screw surf all inside the
vehicle
important lesson
to note
i have my glock on me and i'm over doing
mission brief and final comps checks
okay
my radio's good to go and i immediately
turn start walking towards my truck
right kind of
insubordinate because you're really
supposed to stay there until everyone's
good to go well i'm like i'm good i can
hear you you can hear me i'm gonna go
get to get in my vehicle
and i'm walking away
from the group and that's when i hear
the rounds crack off from behind me
and my first thought again was
one of our afghan partners had just
indeed their weapon just negligently
discharged their weapon which also
wouldn't be unheard of
but after the second round third round
fourth round
you know i can tell it's coming from a
belt-fed machine gun like no no
someone's deliberately shooting at
something
and i snapped my head around
and one of those guys sure enough that
jumped up on the back of that four
ranger and was just opening up into the
crowd
perfect
setup for that we're all lumped together
and he's you know 20 feet away
with a pkm
ripping into the crew
so i see that and
my first thought is move to cover
eliminate the threat like just react to
near ambush
and although i've played this game now
i don't know infinite amount of times in
my mind i wonder if i had my primary
weapon system on me would i have done
what i am supposed to do
because i had cover right there there
were four or five armored trucks right
next to me
take a couple steps over weapon system
comes up problem goes away and we move
on with life
what i see
after i see the shooter is one of our
infantry uplift
soldiers who was scheduled to be a
driver for us that day
frozen and he's maybe eight feet in
front of me and he's like a deer in
headlights and he's staring at a guy
with a machine gun shooting in his
direction
15 20 feet in front of him
i see that and
although i know what i'm supposed to do
my
love of a teammate
superseded me doing my actual job
so instead of moving to some cover and
eliminating the threat
i move towards this kid
and
i take maybe just like three four
aggressive steps i'm coming in pretty
hot
and i get my back to the gunner and i
get in front of this kid
and that's when i'm hit for the first
time just below my right ass cheek upper
thigh boom
knocks me down on top of
this soldier
and then i feel another two three
impacts to my legs
so i know i'm hit
i don't know the
i don't know the severity of it but i've
been hit before i'm hit again okay
we'll deal with this here in a second
and i
dragged myself and this kid you know
maybe four or five feet behind the front
corner of another truck to get us a
little bit of cover
people are dropping all around us people
are scrambling
i get to this this next location
i don't have my rifle on me
there was a rifle laying on the ground
next to me that our senior medic it was
his weapon he had been hit
i roll over i grab that
i throw that into action i'm laying on
my back
uh i put a couple horribly placed rounds
towards this threat who's still engaging
and then one of my teammates comes in
and and smokes this dude
this was the initiation of a complex
ambush so we start taking machine gun
fire and rockets from outside of the
outside of the camp
so immediate threat's been removed
i can tell that we're in a fire fight
but i'm in no position to address any of
those problems so i go to my next course
action and i check this soldier who i'm
still kind of laying on top of who's
just in shock but there's no holes in
him and he can
breathe so no master no massive
hemorrhaging he got an airway okay we're
good
i now look to see how bad my damage is
so i rip my pant leg open
and my my right leg is just
mangled right they doc's estimated it
was probably four or five rounds i took
to that leg
i took one to my lower left leg which i
didn't even know about for like weeks
weeks later
the right leg was definitely the problem
and the river of blood that was flowing
from me to where i had initially been
hit
was substantial so i know my femoral
lottery has been clipped
so time is uh is of the essence right i
know due to training i have probably
maybe eight to 12 minutes before i'm
completely bled out
so i grab a k grab a tourniquet off my
kid i slap that on wrench it down lock
in the windlass
bleeding doesn't stop
second one goes on
i put a second one on myself put that
down looks like the bleeding may have
slowed down a little bit
um
but i can tell i'm still bleeding
teammate gets to me
and he's like
you're in bad [__] like the look on his
face said everything i needed to know
he puts on a third tourniquet
and then he gets iv access for blood or
from meds or whatever
and i was trying to like get him away
from me originally like i know i'm dead
like i'm in the expecting category like
i don't know who's doing triage right
now but i need to be
with the group that isn't gonna make it
i'm with the group that you don't waste
your time on because i know there's a
lot of people that are down right now
and i know that i'm not one that can be
saved so get like get away from me
he ignores me and does what he needs to
do
third tourniquet iv access and then his
work was pretty much done
so he moves on
well
i'm still confident that i'm still
bleeding out
so i'm thinking man have i done
everything i can do
so i decided to grab some gauze out of
my kit
and uh ball it up it's called a little
powerball just taking gauze and creating
this little ball out of it
i loosen up one of the tourniquets
and i just wedge this gauze up into my
thigh and i'm kind of reaching up
towards my hip
looking for the
to feel the pulse of the artery
and we do training to be able to do this
but
it's on something else other than you
know you
and when you're bleeding at that volume
all the blood starts to shunt inwards to
your organs to protect your body to
survive as long as you can
so my hands are real numb i can't really
feel anything
i think i feel something i'm brushing
past broken femur my femur was shattered
so now the pain is really kicking in for
the first time
and i'm trying to stay conscious
i feel something i think i just
wedge down as hard as i can
press that gauze in feed the rest of the
guns and on top of it re-secure the
tourniquet on top lock that in
and then uh
my work there was pretty much done
you cover that in the book
you say this is gonna hurt
i ram the powerball into my leg reaching
up toward my hip it hurts i'm feeling
for the femoral artery it needs direct
pressure to pinch the bleeding off
the problem is the remaining blood in my
system is shunting away from my
extremities to protect my vital organs
my hands feel like meat mittens
zero dexterity or fine motor skills in
my fingers the only way way i can tell
i'm brushing past my shattered femur is
the shearing shock wave it sends through
my body
going unconscious seems inevitable
there it is i think i feel a pulse
inside my leg no way to be sure but the
clock is ticking
only a matter of minutes if that until i
am completely bled out
and only matter of seconds before i pass
out i ram the powerball down as hard as
i can the pain rips through my body
attempting to eject from my eyeballs
i feed more gauze on top of the
powerball just as our medics taught us
i re-secure the tourniquet on top of it
tighten the strap twist the windlass
lock it in
and pass out
i wake up what i think is just a few
moments later i wasn't out for long
i look at my leg and determine my work
here is done
alright that's enough sleeping on the
job get back to work be there for your
brothers
i dragged myself maybe six feet to a
teammate he is taken around through the
calf nothing life threatening although
certainly painful
the guys have applied some interventions
already including a tourniquet which
seems to have stopped the bleeding but
he's in severe pain note tourniquets
save lives an essential tool but that
comes with some impressive pain for the
patient
i do what i can to distract him provide
some verbal relief
my efforts create minimal effects but it
is what i feel to be the best use of
whatever time i have left
which i am certain is not long
at some point i go unconscious again
when i come to i'm being carried out on
a stretcher
seems like they are preparing me for
medevac
i am right
how long has it been
how long was i unconscious
it doesn't matter i'm still alive
still in the fight
the bird touches down my teammates load
me on
one of them grabs my face looks me in
the eyes and says i love you brother
my heart is full what an honor to have
served with such men
what an honor to die alongside such
warriors
our uh
our
medevacs and our docs and our medical uh
military
operations are so good
that
a lot of time it's like oh if you get on
the bird if you're alive getting on the
bird
there's a really good chance you're
gonna make it
it doesn't sound like you're thinking
that way
no
i uh
just hearing that you read that like
puts me back in that place man
um
i wasn't sure how long i had been
still on the ground but i knew it was it
was quite a bit of time so
i was surprised that i was still
even alive at that point
um
i was convinced that that was it though
that was where it was ending
um
your boys put cass all over that valley
by the way and
drop all kinds of bombs um you're on the
first medevac bird out obviously
uh
you get to the aob surgery clinic
and and this is this is freaking nuts
you get you need a blood transfusion
because you've lost a ton of blood
and
somehow
there you end up with the wrong type of
blood
wrong type of blood transfusion which is
horrible
um
do you remember any of that you're not
you're not conscious at this point are
you i remember being at that aid station
it's spotty
but i do remember getting pulled off the
bird and getting thrown on the table
uh and then just you know the the med
staff scrambling to work on me
so the next they get you stable enough
or at least they think they get you
stable enough
to get you from the aid station to
bagram
they don't know what the problem is with
me other than i'm crashing
hot
so
they put me on a helicopter to send me
to bagram where there's a scale hospital
at this location that i was at first was
a forward surgical team
that certainly has
medical capability
but once they put me on that transfusion
everything began shutting down they
didn't know why but they knew i needed
to get to bagram immediately
it was while i was flying to bagram
which was maybe a nine ten minute flight
that they realized what happened with
the blood because they were giving my
teammate my blood type and they were
giving me his
we have very similar last names
they both begin with l a so they just
switched up the names
well they're pumping him full of o
positive which is my blood type which is
i'm a universal donut i can give blood
to anybody so he's fine but when they
looked to see what they were giving him
they were like
wait a minute and they look to check to
see what they just gave me and it was
like eight units i mean it was a ton
that's what they when that's when they
realized what happened so i'm airborne
and they call bagram and they say we
just pump nick full of a b negative
there's no way he survives this flight i
was already in like critical condition
to begin with
there's no way he survives the flight
just be prepared to receive his body
when he gets there
and in a lot of ways they were right i
mean i coded on that flight
and to your point the the flight medics
were getting real creative
with keeping me alive so panels and the
whole thing is out
i think they were hitting me with like
shots of adrenaline and just like
whatever tools they had
uh to keep me clinging on
pull me off the bird get me into surgery
they take my foot off immediately
uh really i mean it was it was probably
dead at that point because now we're
talking 90 minutes close to two hours
since the point of injury
but really it was just try to try to
minimize how much damage my body was
trying to recover from
and then uh
innovated
dialysis
transfusion machines are just keeping me
alive you know at this point
and that was the that was the case for
like three or four days
at park room
what's the first thing that you remember
when you come back
where are you
i remember um
coming to at bagram a couple times and i
was restrained to the bed
because i had been trying to
rip the
breathing tube out when i would wake up
when you're when you're innovated
you know a machine is breathing free for
you but when you try to breathe yourself
against that it can throw off the timing
of the machine so it feels like you're
like suffocating
it's a horrible feeling
so i was trying to get this tube out of
my mouth when i would come too
i don't remember doing that but i just
remember coming to and being like
restrained to a bed
and wanting to for someone to put me out
of my misery
and then when when do you come to again
like what's your next memory when's your
first full
when do they take you out of coma when
do they bring you back and let you start
talking and thinking and
yes so does that happen i remember um my
now wife who was
deployed and working at a bagram i
remember coming to a couple times and
seeing her bedside
uh i remember my
sort of commander being bedside a lot
talking to me
um but my last real memory is when they
were moving me from bagram to load me on
to a fixed-wing bird to fly me to
germany which took about five days for
them to stabilize me enough to survive
the flight to germany
remember getting loaded on that bird
which is wild those those c-130s that
are outfitted it's like a hospital on
you know with wings
i remember getting on that flight
um
i don't remember much from germany i was
i was only there a day do you know that
you lost your leg at this point no or
your foot no no
nope um
no recollection of that no knowledge of
that they took my leg up to the knee at
germany and then they flew me from there
to walter reed the next day
and i get to walter reed and my father
was there my mother was there
i went straight into the intensive care
unit
which is where i spent the next like six
weeks because it was still real touch
and go
and it was around that it was at that
point that i realized my leg was
was gone or at least that part of it was
gone
did you think you were gonna be did they
think was it when you realized you had
lost your leg was it above the knee or
below the knee
by the time i realized it was already
above the knee
um
they had taken it above the knee at
walter reed
and
the chief of ortho came in to the
intensive care unit
and he he looks at me and i'm whacked
out i'm on ketamine and allotted you
know i'm i'm on a high cocktail of pain
management meds but he looks at me and
he's like hey man i'm dr so-and-so
chief of ortho
here's the situation
you've been here about three or four
days
your leg
most of your leg is gone
what's left of it is riddled with
bacteria and infection
any one of these things could kill you
so my staff wants to take you into
surgery right now
and amputate your leg at the hip
and just get rid of this problem that
could kill you and just get you on with
life
but i think i can save more of your leg
it's just going to be a street fight and
i need you like in the fight with me
and i just met this guy you know he's
telling me that
this problem could kill me at any moment
but he wants to like slug it out with me
and i don't think i really processed
medically what he was saying i just
heard like let's get into a fight
together
do you want to do that
and i was like yes
we take it yeah yeah right whose car we
taking we're gonna hurt some people and
you can have asked me about it again
whose car we
that was that was it i think i just
heard that and i said let's do that
and he said okay
so
that began
my regimen
of
surgeries three or four times a week and
they were just going in and amputating
more and more and more cutting out dead
tissue cutting out more bone
monday wednesday friday was kind of my
typical
routine and then flushing me with
antibiotics
hoping that the infection would get
taken care of and then it was just rinse
and repeat like that for
you know a month or so five weeks six
weeks something like that until the
infection eventually stopped
which left me with pretty much what i
have today
oh yeah let's do it um
you got a section in here where you're
talking about as you begin
as you begin rehab
so
um you get right into it
it says on one particular day i was
walking my laps around the track so i'm
fast forward a little bit right um
obviously there's and when you get the
book you can get some of these other
details i'm fast forward a little bit
one particular day i was walking my laps
around the track one step at a time
it was packed in fact
in fact a bunch of new york yankees were
there visiting service members i
typically avoided these meet and greet
moments like the plague when i was
working kelly knew this and kelly was
your uh your uh rehab physical therapist
physical therapist
kelly knew this and did an amazing job
of shielding me from unnecessary
distractions i'm pretty sure she
literally hissed a dude one time like an
angry cat given that on this day it was
the yankees i was even less interested
go socks
i was in a good stride my prosthetic had
had a solid fit that day and i needed to
push it i decided to hold a 90 pound
barbell straight overhead in order to
increase the difficulty
off i went shoulders burning core
burning glutes burning perfect we were
working i picked up speed i didn't have
a set number of laps in mind i just
planned on going until i couldn't go
anymore my body began to twitch
uncontrollably fatigue set in i was
right at muscle failure i got one more
lap in me let's go i rounded the corner
of the track and lost my balance i
already knew how this was going to play
out my wipeout was of epic proportions
the barbell went one way my body the
other and my prosthetic detached
completely it was a total yard sale the
barbell slammed on the floor clanging
around looking for a target it found the
legs of a physical therapist who was
coaching a patient through a stationary
bike workout the therapist fell on her
back with a thud knocking the wind out
of her my body went flailing into a rack
of medicine balls neatly organized
according to weight the heavier ones at
the bottom the lighter ones at top all
of which were now bouncing or rolling in
all directions through the facility the
photo op with the yankees stopped the
stretches stopped all conversation
stopped everything stopped as i lay on
the ground i conducted a quick damage
assessment fingers arms leg head
everything seemed to be functioning the
therapist i knocked over regained her
breathing ability i asked if she was all
right
she was fine and asked the same of me i
looked around the gym to see that nobody
had moved an inch nobody including kelly
had made the slightest attempt to either
slow me down before i wrecked or come to
my aid once i did it was business as
usual i strapped my leg back on and
staggered over to kelly the only damage
was to my pride you good she asked
yeah i'm good
think i didn't swing completely through
and my foot hit the ground behind me
yeah that sounds right now go pick up
those med balls and meet me over at the
squat rack
so you're freaking get how long was it
how long was it that you were like laid
up you're getting the surgeries before
you got fitted for a prosthetic and all
that yeah i got fitted for my first
prosthetic probably
10 12 weeks after getting there
and which is you know a monumental step
in the process
unfortunately this is quite common i
needed a couple surgical revisions after
that had happened which is really
difficult to deal with because it pretty
much puts you back at square one you
know your leg changes shape
if the swelling sets in you have to wait
until you can get recasted for another
prosthetic
it kind of starts that clock all over
again i had to go through that twice
you know and those setbacks and i talk
about this often you know like that's
what separates those that can continue
to make the strides
and oftentimes is what just derails
people they just can't deal with that
with that setback how long about is this
like a five week eight week setback yeah
no i'd say maybe around three or four
okay
man that's freaking you know yeah it's
tough because you're making that you can
see the progress you're making and that
boom you're back to where you were and
this is like a revision they do surgery
they fit you with a prosthetic you start
walking on almost and like the way your
bone is is jacked up or it's sticking
out or something and they got to go in
there and shave that thing down yep
exactly that
and then you got to get all healed up
and
[Music]
start again yeah so what you just read
was probably around july time frame
where i was done with surgeries
and i was really making substantial
progress working with my prosthetic
i got to the hospital in march so
you know a few months after that was
when i was done with surgeries
completely and i was
i was really getting after it freaking
walking around with a with a prosthetic
with 90 pound barbell over your head
yeah
dude you were going freaking hard i was
i was i mean my level of obsession
uh because i could already see where i
was going like i knew what was in front
of me
was getting back to the team that
happened in the hospital even before i
was on a prosthetic i was like i'm going
back to my lifestyle and my profession
so these training sessions this was this
was my life yeah you immediately knew
you're going to go back to an oda 100
which by the way uh in case this wasn't
clear you have no leg
right and you're saying i'm going back
to an oda right
um
people are actually trying to get you to
freaking chill out
and trying to
you know that's kind of a
funny way of saying it but people were
actually trying to get you to adjust
your expectations for your life
and you have a section in here where uh
it's one of those scenarios
um
april 2013 my father tells this story
better than i do as i heard it only
second hand but on one particular day a
psych came in to visit me and i had just
been wheeled out for surgery my father
told the doc the deal and they began
talking a bit the psych explained to my
father that i was continuously talking
about returning to my job on an sf
detachment doing the same things i had
done before etc he further explained to
my father that he felt i was perhaps in
a state of shock or denial
simply due to the drugs not yet aware of
the severity of my situation
he essentially warned my father that at
some point i would be made aware of how
badly i was injured and that the
likelihood of me doing what i intended
to do was extraordinarily unlikely
perhaps impossible he simply wanted my
father to be prepared to deal with what
could potentially be a dramatic severe
fall into depression
in hindsight i may have had the same
thoughts and concerns as he did after
all i was on an enormous amount of
medication i was in surgery three times
a week and i had expressed my intentions
were unpre and my expressed intentions
were unprecedented additionally i am
positive
he had seen this cause and effect happen
throughout his medical career so i get
it no hard feelings doc
my father expressed his appreciation for
the information and analysis before
telling the psych that he didn't like
that he didn't see that as likely to
happen my father explained that he felt
i knew what was going on i had amazingly
accepted the reality of my situation and
just as quickly had already focused on
the next evolution he told the doc this
is just who nick is
my father knows me as well as anybody
he's my best friend in this world he
knew that he knew that i knew my current
situation
and that even while doped up with enough
painkillers and anesthesia to kill a
horse
i was already formulating a plan
freaking ready to rock man
uh
you were there just mentally there
yeah man that was it
how long are you in walter reed before
about a year total
um
and that
you just
uh
you report in here that
date was great for you like
the medical support that you got the
people there the people that were
training you were just
freaking good to go
amazing um
how is it happening how does it progress
like what happens when the chain of
command hears that you want to come back
what are they saying
so i mean i was in communication with
them while i was in the hospital and you
know they come visit me every now and
then and we just maintain calms but it
wasn't so much about
tell me what your what your goals are
when you get back it was just how are
you doing do you need anything how's
your family right that was the focus
when i left walter reed and got back to
brag
i've reported back over to third group
and i met with the group command team
uh the first day in their office you
know and of course they're like welcome
back you look great
i'm still early on in the process you
know i've been an amputee for about a
year so
i'm no physical specimen i'm still
hobbling you know i'm still limping i'm
still trying to figure out how to live
life with one leg
and i'm sitting in their office
and they eventually asked me so like
what are your goals
what are you looking to do
and i told them that i'm going back to
the team
and
they just said
okay
is that something that you think you can
do now and i said no no no i have a lot
of work i still need to do
but that's where things are going
in the interim you know i need a job i
need to provide value here
so i requested to go to the combatives
committee to work as an instructor
which is a great fit you know a long
time like combatives dude and uh
and they granted that
they granted that request
i haven't talked to these guys you know
years later about this exact moment
they'll they'll they'll have all told me
like we had to do everything in our
power to hold back
like the crazy one-eyed look like what
did you just say
or
go down the expectation management kind
of brief
that i was getting quite a bit at the
hospital they had to fight the urge to
do both of those things
and just stay kind of
cool and neutral because they wanted to
be supportive of me right um but as a
leader right like you also want to be
practical to a degree so you know i
understand that
um
[Music]
they didn't think that what i
intended to do was
was possible i didn't think that that
was gonna happen
but uh
they did grant me the request to work as
an instructor and that's when the game
really like went up significantly
because as amazing as the staff as a
walter reed their job is to keep you
alive and then get you as functional as
you can be to live the rest of your life
with whatever condition you're dealing
with
they're not there to train someone to go
back to an oda that's not their job the
guys in my unit that is their job
so i knew i needed to get back to brag
asap
to begin training with those guys and
gals
um
first i needed a job which my unit gave
me and then i knew i needed to fight
this thing administratively which i
didn't know what that looked like but i
knew it was going to trigger a medical
evaluation board
which i refer to as a
military eviction board because that's
really what they're like
programmed to do and in their defense
most of the guys or gals or service
members that they see are looking to
transition out so they do place a lot of
emphasis on
let's make sure we get your va rating
where it needs to be all the
documentation
get you maybe an internship for what
life looks like as a civilian that's
what they're there to do
and i walked in and i'm like i'm going
back to the team
and the first person i got linked up
with that kind of quarterbacks you
through that process
just didn't get it
uh he just didn't get it and uh i i
fired that guy which i didn't know i
could do
uh but i threw enough of a temper
tantrum
and talked to his boss
and i was like you either need to get me
someone who's on the same page as me or
i'm just gonna do this myself so
he was cool he linked me up with this
girl who was amazing her name was rachel
and she had worked with some sf guys
that
remained on active duty so she was she
became my girl and she was on the same
page as me
so uh
the admin fight happened at that point
which took about eight months a time
so i'm working as an instructor
day to day
and i've really just taken the same
mentality i had at walter reed which is
in a lot of ways is easier to maintain
this because you're living in this
bubble where your only job is to go to
these appointments and you're like
living at walter reed once you get home
you got you know your friends in my in
my instance i had my girl who i moved in
with like the these other factors that
part of your life
that can distract you or detract from
the mission
so i had to take the same mentality i
had in the hospital and apply that to a
normal living environment
and with just within the first week of
being home
i had to make some real hard choices
and eliminate
anything that didn't need to be there
complete and total re-evaluation of how
i spend every single minute of my day
and if you didn't need to be there if it
didn't need to be there both tasks and
people it was removed
and with tasks i think it's
it's easier to say i'm not gonna watch
netflix anymore but when you start
talking about removing relationships
from your life that can
that can be real difficult to do
and i sat down with my now wife
and this is like the courting phase of
our relationship
right like she was in afghanistan when i
got banged up and what was what was she
doing in afghanistan what was her job
she's active duty um at the time she was
doing psychological
operations but we hadn't spent any like
real time together you know and then i
move in with her and within the first
week i sit down with her
i said hey babe here's the deal
uh i'm i'm going all in hey just real
quick
when you're communicating with your
significant other
a good way to not start this
conversation is hey look here's the deal
so we're getting off to a good start bro
yeah all right here's the deal
it was the truth though like there was
no alternative this is the deal this
isn't like of course action this is the
way it's going to be
i just wanted to be transparent
um
i'm going all in on this like complete
and total burn the boats like i'm either
going to be successful or i'm going to
die trying that's it non-negotiable i
have to do this
and uh what that means on the tactical
level is that there are no dinners
there's no we're going to go to this
wedding there's no like nothing
nothing everything's gone
let's eat sleep train repeat until i get
successful or
they kick me out of the army that's it
and uh
i look back at that conversation now
with the family we have we're married
now six years
two young kids
the highlight of my life most important
thing in in my life by a mile and all
that could have very easily just
non-existed
if she didn't have the
the strength to
be okay with the somewhat craziness that
i was
communicating to her
so i'm incredibly grateful that that
happened
you know it's like it can be tough to
talk about because uh
it could have all have just not not been
a thing
she was like okay
roger that you know and and i think what
enabled that was
she was also uh aggressively pursuing
kind of her next echelon her next
evolution in her career so she was
really dialed in professionally as well
so we were both kind of going down
in parallel
these uh hyper-focused roads towards our
professional ambitions at the same time
which helped because you know she had
stuff she needed to do stuff i needed to
do we'd come together when we could but
it was it was an interesting you know
introduction to our relationship with
all this was going on
so eight month process of a med board
i'm working as an instructor and i'm
just i'm living just this completely and
total dialed in you know minute to
minute howard
hour lifestyle uh obviously a lot of
physical training was involved
and uh
you know after after about eight months
med board complete
the army allowed me to stay in on active
duty
then that check that that box was
checked and then it was okay now i need
to get back to the team and now i need
to figure out how to go about doing that
and it sounds like there's a really
specific
list of things that you needed to be
able to do like like is it some kind of
test like a fit for duty tests is that
is that like there was certain tasks you
had to be able to do
and
where's that list come from
it was created in in real time by my
chain of command
there wasn't this laid out pipeline
um
it started off simple it was go do an
army physical fitness test okay you did
that and then
they threw every
army physical fitness program of record
at me
and once i checked all those blocks
then they started just throwing other
stuff at me
so they had me i was getting evaluated
cognitively um
proficiency they ran me back over to the
18 bravo committee which is where i
learned how to be an 18 bravo they threw
me back over there for like a one week
two week
train up evaluation to see if i could
still do my job as a bravo
they uh they put me in front of psych
screening which
no one's admitted this to me yet
directly but
i'm confident when i say i was i was
operating at such an insane pace
in intensity that people thought i was
like legitimately crazy
you know people thought i had like a
diagnosable problem well that was
delusional or like psychopathic
like we need to get this guy's mental
well-being checked out because i think
he's insane and needs like treatment
the site came back and was like yeah
he's no crazier than he was before
so he's
so good at this time you're teaching
combatives which is who are you teaching
combatives to is it within your own
battalion or is it like who are you
teaching compatible the group so they're
a group so third group you're teaching
combatives
you're and then you're just pt to try
and get to be able to do this job yep pt
and doing a ton of jiu jitsu um
competing in jiu jitsu as well which is
a huge part of this overall journey is
what is that piece of it that not just
from a training perspective but just
mentality and structure and like
technical focus on what i'm doing
adaptation to how do i how do i do this
with just one limb now one leg now were
you like a purple belt when this thing
kicked off
no i was a
white belt a white belt i got my blue
and my purple after i lost my leg check
but you trained before you lost your leg
i did yeah yeah i trained i got into jiu
jitsu right after i really i graduated
the q course so i did that on two legs
for a while
and then my jujitsu journey as an
amputee started at walter reed they had
a local black belt who owned a studio
downtown washington who would come to
the hospital one day a week who's that
jose
i think it's like ortiz was his name
good on him awesome dude i met him at
the hospital and then i began training
he invited me over to his in his dojo so
i began training there like three four
nights a week
you know one thing that you and i forget
if i'm going to cover this or not in the
book but i want to talk about anyways um
you got this thing that really like
struck a chord with me so
you explain that when you got a
prosthetic
when you put that thing on
there's a clock that starts
because you can only wear it for so long
and there's a bunch of factors if it's
hot out what activity you're doing
and it made you that was one of the
things that kind of drove this this
efficiency in you because you go okay
when i get this thing on i have x amount
of hours to operate
walking around and after that i got to
take it off
and it that's that was one of the things
you said okay as soon as i get this
thing on here's what i got to get done
and that
struck a chord with me because like
that's the attitude you should have
regardless uh in life is like oh you're
gonna wake up today you only have so
many hours but that put a put an
exclamation point on that for you
yeah i'd say that you know being having
been in the military in special ops for
for a bit before this i i was used to
living you know structured disciplined
lifestyle but
the forcing function of knowing i needed
to be able to execute at the highest
possible level
in order to do that i needed to be as
efficient as possible you said it was
about efficiency how do i maximize every
moment i have
upright on two legs
and i got i developed a bit of ocd on
that because if i would
if i would go to leave my house and i
would leave something and i'd walk 12
steps before i realized i forgot it
that would that would irritate me
because now that's that's 24 steps i'm
not getting back
so there's a there's a glitch in my
system there's a glitch in my in my
protocol
things aren't prepped where they need to
be this mistake can't happen again
because i just lost 24 steps
so i mean i was dissecting like where i
put my phone my keys my like like to the
like to the inch
within my life so that i didn't lose 24
steps ever again
you were freaking committed to this
thing
how what was the what was the biggest
challenge as you as they threw all these
different tests at you
right they're throwing the army pt test
at you they throw this other test at you
what was something that uh
really was a challenger
what was the hardest thing yeah the
final the final physical evaluation uh
which was my final overall evaluation
was that was by far the hottest one this
was at the end of about 12 weeks
where i was doing one or two assessments
a week
and third group again
only operated in afghanistan they were
dealing with a lot of injuries so third
group took it upon themselves to create
what they called originally the return
to duty physical fitness assessment and
that was specifically for guys that were
wounded that wanted to go back to
operational status
they spent months putting this thing
together this was while i was at the
hospital
and they were telling me about it
a little bit
and
they developed it out they ran you know
able-bodied guys through it to develop
their standards and it was more of
more tasks that were more in line with a
combat scenario so as opposed to just
you know push-ups sit-ups and running
it was
tactical tasks like move to cover type
drills everything is done with a
50-pound weighted vest to simulate kit
most were done with a rubber duck rifle
so it was more tactical tasks
12 events in total
well the day before i took mine this was
like my super bowl
and my my training for about six weeks
or so leading up to that point
was mostly focused on those particular
tasks
the day before
i went in the gym just to loosen up get
some blood flow get ready for my next
for for the test that happened the
following morning
and the group command sergeant major
and
another dude who had been shot through
the hand who was trying to go back to
the team they both took it that morning
so i walk in the gym to loosen up and
they're both sprawled out on the turf
drenched and exhausted
group command sergeant major's name is
mark ecked he just recently retired he
was the most recent
uh use of sock csm
he's a stud he's a pt stud able-bodied
dude stud he's out on the on the turf
both of them are
and i walk over and hey sergeant-major
you doing he's like
uh not great because that test just
kicked my ass he's like you're taking
this thing tomorrow morning i said yeah
he's like
this thing's no joke and i knew it was
it was it was brutal i had never taken
it entirely in its entirety
to standard once because i knew it was
gonna break me off so in my training i
was playing around with different
resistances
but i would just lump together different
groups of them and go back to back to
back in repetition
i said yeah tomorrow morning he's like
okay well i'll be here you know good
luck i said thank you so i showed up the
next morning
group command team battalion command
team company command team and about 50
other dudes are all there there's a
massive entourage they basically closed
the gym
um or at least no one was training
because everyone was just they had to
just to watch this my teammates are
there
and uh
i knocked that out
and the the final event on this thing is
it doesn't sound bad but it's actually
quite miserable the 12th event and i
think you had i think it was two minutes
in between each
event
the final one the twelfth one
is just as a walk on an ink on a
treadmill and it starts off flat and
then every two minutes it increases in
elevation
so at the final point you're walking at
a 45 degree angle which is steep
it's at a slow pace you know it's like a
fast like a brisk walk so you're doing
this 50 pound weighted vest 12th event
well my issue similar to the way i wiped
out there at walter reed was because the
lack of range of motion i have in my hip
when the angle is that steep i can't get
my foot out in front of me
so i had to develop a technique where
once it hit a certain degree of
elevation i would rotate my body
laterally
and i would laterally shuffle
up hill
so my aunt my prosthetic is the trail
leg my sound leg is the uphill leg and
that's essentially just pulling me up so
i'm doing this little sidewards lateral
gallop
up this hill
which just looks crazy
so
i finish
event complete
i'm on the verge of passing out i'm on
the verge of going to see the wizard i'm
losing peripheral vision it's getting
real
sparkly around me and i'm standing there
trying to look tough
like i could do it again if i needed to
and uh group csn comes over and he says
hey man you know i just took this test
yesterday and it kicked my ass he's like
if i wasn't here to witness you just do
what you just did
i would never believe that that was
possible
and this is at the end of 12 weeks and
i'm like
all right dude thank you but like what
else do you need from me
you know which my teammates were kind of
laughing i'm talking to the group
command sergeant major and i'm like
thanks for the thanks for that but like
what like what's next come on man what
else
what else is it gonna take
he looks over the group commander
and he just goes hey mark this is your
decision but i don't know how we're to
tell this dude no after what we just put
him through
so he
mark echoed looked at me and he goes all
right man um you'll have your orders
come monday and you'll be back
back on the team
uh you have a section here in the book
you got a few sections like this in the
book where you where you have
other people that knew you or that know
you chime in you got a section here
about this this is by uh master sergeant
jimmy rooney
and he writes
the ort is an extremely difficult
assessment even for able-bodied men some
events are arguably arguably impossible
for an above-the-knee amputee such as
the depth drop
in this event an individual must climb
up a four foot platform wearing 50-pound
weighted vest jump off make an athletic
landing without touching the ground with
his hands
nick's mechanical knee was incapable of
articulating in a dynamic fashion and
prevented him from sticking the landing
for weeks nick drilled this event
starting on one foot platform with no
additional weight and gradually
increasing height and weight over time
the method he developed to complete this
event was to land in a pistol squat
position essentially a single leg squat
landing
the guys and i watched him practice this
over and over again the mere thought of
doing this myself made my knees and hips
hurt but nick insisted it was possible
he meticulously measured out the
distance from the platform to where his
heel needed to land marking it with tape
on the ground too far forward he'd fall
backward upon landing too close to the
platform and his knee may explode he
approached this event like a science
experiment a problem that needed to be
solved through trial error and work on
the day of nick's final physical
assessment the ort it felt as if the
entire unit was present nick was
attempting to make history as the first
above the knee amputee to return not
just to an oda but to an oda set once
again to deploy to afghanistan to
conduct combat operations
everybody was in all watching him
perform when he completed the last event
with our entire command and attendance
he was given approval to return to the
team it was one of the most memorable
moments we shared
so how did nick put his mind and body in
such a positive motivated and
influential place to become so well
known as not only one of the most
aggressive warriors but also a life
coach teacher and mentor i believe
nick's outlook on his environment is
where it started he had to determine
what it was that he wanted in life and
set a plan to achieve it nick could have
easily become negative and bitter and
could have medically retired out of the
military nobody would have thought less
of him for doing so he had been
through a lot instead nick chose to
pursue what he identified as his purpose
i feel the key to nick's success is that
he clearly stated his intent and it gave
him a reason to get out of bed every
morning this only grew as he continued
achieving goals along the way and nick
may not realize it but he became a model
for success in every aspect of being a
phenomenal green beret and leader
his fear his sphere of positive
influence and capulet encapsulates
everybody he comes in contact with
complaining around nick is impossible
giving anything less than 100 percent
around nick is not an option
his actions raise the bar for the rest
of us to match his presence makes us
better
what did nick do to get where he is
today plain and simple nick embodies
intestinal fortitude and cares about the
men
and the mission
[Applause]
hell yeah
freaking
insane right
jumping off the forefoot thing landing
on one leg come on man
that's freaking savage
uh what was your mock max squat when you
had two legs do you know
back in my when i was like big big
before i came in the military um i was
around i was in the 600s
what do you think your one leg like
is it stronger now than it was then
my one leg yeah oh yeah yeah that thing
is just like freaking savage yeah that's
the most savage leg on the planet yeah
it has to be you know
yeah it has to be
uh
so
you know there's there's one more thing
i want to read about this uh before we
get into some of your other you know
moving on from here
um
it's just going back it's a little
reflection on the whole scenario but i
think it's important thing to read
you say on march 11 2013 we were set to
conduct a routine operation as always
our partner force gathered outside our
camp the leadership entered the wire to
receive the mission brief only this time
a truck also drove in i noticed
immediately that it wasn't right i was
pissed do i address this now i thought
to myself it seems obvious that the
answer was emphatically in the
affirmative
why wouldn't i
the answer to that question is rapport
this is a tough balance and arguably the
most critical factor for an oda's
success fostering and maintaining
relationships are the keys when
conducting partnered operations i
decided to hold off
i would address this with my detachment
commander after and he would address it
with the partner force leadership this
was a decision
i must live with
for the rest of my life
this truck was a ford ranger with a
mounted pkm in the bed
this is the weapon that would moments
later rip my body to shreds drastically
altering the rest of my life
but this result is not the reason for my
regret
the loss of my leg is not why i spring
up sweating in the middle of the night
living the rest of my life as an amputee
is not why i continue to re-analyze my
decision-making process on that day
our detachment commander
captain andrew peterson keel our
infantry uplift squad leader staff
sergeant rex shad and our military
working dog back
were all killed in action
as a result of my decision
it took years to be able to look at this
event and extract positive value the
pain was too great
i couldn't see past my anger and the
disappointment with myself i couldn't
see past the faces of my brothers who
paid the ultimate sacrifice
it took time
it took a lot of reflection
it was hard but i owed them this effort
so their deaths were not for nothing
gradually i was able to gather the
lessons learned
internal security sops partner force
relationship dynamics and john boyd's
ooda loop cycle are just a few examples
of what was extracted we used our
experience to better educate ourselves
and those around us in order to minimize
the likelihood of a future similar
tragedy
the loss of these men brought value to
those who remain in the fight
how many lives have been saved because
of their sacrifice
there's no way to ever know but i am
certain it is substantial
the insider attack on march 11 2013 is
considered to this day the most
catastrophic insider attack since the
start of the global war on terrorism
it is referenced in schools and training
events throughout the soft community
as painful as it remains we have managed
to pull the positive value from this
tragedy
we must get better
we owe this to the fallen
um
yeah you know you you and i were talking
when we weren't recording
uh
you know for me i i had a blue on blue
incident in ramadi that i was in charge
of a friendly iraqi soldier was killed
several more were wounded one of my guys
was wounded
and
like what i did when i got home was
debrief that event to every seal team on
the west coast that was going on
deployment and
i had many times
guys come back and say hey i was in the
situation we had this element over here
that element over here if i wouldn't
have known and trained
to avoid blue on blues the 100 would
have happened
and you know i was just saying to you
that you're telling this story
look man there's there's there's special
operations guys
working around the world right now as we
speak with
countless partner forces all over the
place
and
this is a lesson that
everybody will will not forget
and you know i know that the blue on
blue that we had early in deployment
saved lives later in deployment because
we would have had
you know i mean there's there's other
things i talk about in extreme ownership
you know i had freaking bradley
want to put 25 millimeter chain gun on
uh what they thought was enemy
enemy element on a rooftop and that
enemy element was actually my guys
you know uh leif talks about in there he
had chris kyle
identify hey there's there's i see a
person with a scoped weapon in this
building do you want me to shoot him
and lace checking with the army do you
guys have anyone in this building and
they're like no kill that sniper and
chris didn't feel comfortable taking the
shot and didn't take it and luckily he
didn't
because we were so sensitive to blue on
blue
and and so the lessons coming away from
this
um
guaranteed you know you say you don't
know how many lives they've saved and i
will never be able to know how many
lives they've saved but no doubt
the level of caution
and making sure that assessment is
happening all the time
um that's what we got to take away from
these things for sure have to
um
you know another thing that that i
breezed over a little bit is
the fact that
as you
[Music]
are focused on you
and you're focused on your goal of like
hey i'm gonna get back to an oda team
at at some point along that journey
before you took that final physical test
you
looked in the mirror and thought to
yourself wait a second
this isn't about me
and
you know you're going over
if you can't do your job
it's not just about you it's about the
guys you might let down it's about do
they want me on the team do they want do
do do they feel like there's going to be
slack that that they're going to have to
pick up for me
uh
talk about that kind of you had some you
had some legit heart-to-heart
conversations with the guys that you
would be working with
about
the situation that you were in and
whether you should proceed down that
path because it wasn't just about you
you got 11 other guys that are counting
on you to be able to carry the weight
yeah and not not just the 11 but the
families
as well and
you're right i was i was in a tunnel
my tunnel vision
during that first phase about it was
about me
being successful doing what i what i
knew i needed to do
proving that they say is wrong proving
myself right all that kind of stuff it
was about me
and once i began going through this
assessment
i'm knocking one out after another boom
boom boom
right around that time
uh i woke up in the middle of the night
in a panic
because i realized in that moment that i
was going back to a team
and i hadn't thought thought about them
once before
and these are guys that are around me
they're in the gym we're training
together i'm seeing them all the time
but i was so target fixated on me doing
what i needed to do that i didn't
consider them
and uh it just it scared the hell out of
me
so the very that that day
at work i tracked down a couple of the
guys that were that were local
had some phone conversations with some
guys that were off site doing some stuff
and uh i was like guys you know i
apologize for having not even done this
up until this point but
is this what's in the best interest of
the team you guys are supportive and
you're in my corner but are you doing
that just because you
care about me and you want me to be
happy have you guys thought about this
because i haven't
and i i don't think i can give this an
objective look because i'm so obsessed
with success i need you guys there to do
that
and this was maybe four or five
different conversations
and i got pretty much the same answer
from all of them and they said listen
dude
we've already all talked about this
already amongst ourselves and
the the hard truth is is we don't know
if this is gonna work
but what i can promise you is
we want you to keep working towards it
we will be the ones to tell you if this
isn't gonna work if you're able to make
it back
we'll assess the situation then
um and we'll make that hard call for you
so you don't have to
so i put my trust into them and to my
teammates to be able to look at it
objectively that way
and jimmy rooney who you just read about
he was set to take the team as the team
sachin
um
he may have already taken it at that
point but he and i were working together
when i was working as an instructor he
was the head instructor of our sephora
committee special forces advanced urban
combat committee and we work at our
offices right down the hall we worked
together
that committee and the combatives
committee so we had a working
relationship
and it wasn't until
much farther down the road that he told
me he was going to take
take two six take my team
and uh he was the last one i talked to
on that day at work
and we had a you know a candid
emotional conversation and he said the
same thing and hearing it from him as
the guy that i know
is going to put the best interest of the
team above all else because that's his
job
i can trust him and the guys
to give me that that no [__] objective
feedback
so once i made that switch
about
wanting to pursue my own goal versus
and the reason behind that
to it being about them
and when i'm walking into my fourth
training session for the day and i'm
exhausted and tired and beat up
rather than thinking about taking those
first steps off the plane in afghanistan
with my arms raising the uh
i was thinking about my teammate's son i
was thinking about my teammate's wife
and i needed to annihilate this workout
right now there's no other option
for them for that kid or for that woman
and it took what was already an
extraordinarily intense
and
rigid
lifestyle
to another level
and you could i i could even feel the
additional energy surging through me it
was like electric now i'm walking into
these training sessions it was just that
much easier to get up at zero three it
was just that much easier to do those
extra two three reps when everything in
my body and my mind is telling me to
stop
the image of my teammates five-year-old
is what fueled that to happen
yeah
freaking um
i guess we get some of that beat into us
you know like you do you just
never want to let down your friends and
then you throw the family on top of that
yeah that's heavy
um
and
you make it back you make it back to a
team you
end up going back to afghanistan
and
it's august it's fighting season it's
hot
what do you think when you show up there
man
there was a you know there was it was a
quick you know celebration that i had
just with myself um
the boy collectively we were it was all
business but i did have that that
glorifying moment that i dreamed of
taking the steps off the plane that was
real short-lived because i realized how
fast
um
we were in the game
and
how f how many gaps i had
so
we landed this is 2015. we landed c-17
lands it's taxiing
it stops
the tailgate hasn't even dropped yet and
the sodif command team is running onto
the plane
which is unusual
and they run over to our team leadership
and they have a little huddle on the
plane
so we're all looking around we had a
horrible infill i mean we went through
like five different countries delays and
flights it was a mess it took us like a
week to get in so we're all on operating
on random time zone times coming off of
ambien you know half asleep like okay we
finally made it and this this meeting is
happening on the plane
uh we we get the equipment off and our
team leadership's like we need to go
into the into the meeting briefing room
like now
we go in now and there was a 19th group
team
so army special forces national guard
team that was operating down in helmand
that
had a real bad situation going on with
their partner force like we used the
term catastrophic loss of rapport
as being like mission abort because we
work through partner force they were
right at that point where
the machine gun barrels were essentially
being pointed inwards with the commando
element they were working with so it was
it was that was horrible
so we needed to get spun up even though
on that trip we weren't falling directly
under the sodif
we were falling under a separate task
force for that deployment
task force
gave us over to the sodif to be the
answer to this problem
as like a temporary solution so we were
getting spun up the second we literally
the second we landed
and it was it was game time
um
so did you guys go take over for them
we didn't take over but we went down
there and uh
assisted them
to get the situation under control
for a couple weeks when you look at that
from a leadership perspective what was
wrong
i'm going to piss off a lot of national
guide guys on this but this is my
opinion is
national god sf teams provide an
enormous value uh across the operational
continuum
where i've seen it work the best is when
they take
national guard sf guys and they attach
them to active duty odas
in 2012-13 we had a national god medic
that was attached to us for that
duration of that deployment that always
works out great when you have an
organic national god oda
and you put them into a combat
environment this is i'm generally
speaking
they just don't
have the time that they train together
to the same level that we do as in the
active side
to bring that same level of tactical
capability to a fight and
they're hamstrung oftentimes because
they group these teams together kind of
as of a hodgepodge of different dudes in
the unit to send them over
so
you don't have that organic chemistry
that you have with an act on an active
duty side
so from just a management and
operational perspective
they're fighting upstream because of
that dynamic and when you put them into
a hostile environment
like in helmand
and
you're given that type of mission
it can be uh
it can be really tough it can be hard
for anybody and if you haven't done a
good work up together it's going to be
even harder yeah
uh
you also you know you get over there and
there's like new challenges for you one
of them you talk about is getting in and
out of an mrap and you go through this
whole thing you're like
if you don't know what an mrap is it's a
it's a mind resistant vehicle but
they're freaking tall because they want
them off the ground as high as they can
be so that the the explosion if it's
underneath it dissipates so they're you
you're climbing a ladder to get in there
you say i can recall one of the most
frustrating tacks was getting into and
out of a mine resistant ambush protected
all terrain vehicle
to get in and out of these trucks one
must climb up four feet with the use of
a couple metal steps as with most
military vehicles the matv is designed
for function not comfort or
accessibility of course getting into and
out of one of these was simple as a
two-legged dude but in 2015 it was
anything but
to say this was frustrating would have
been an understatement this was also
something i did not even consider during
my train up to get back onto a team but
it was a challenge nonetheless i began
drilling over and over again in and out
trying different foot placements trying
different hand placements how i shifted
my weight then i did the same with kid
on then with a rifle over and over and
over again i had a teammate videotape my
reps so i could watch the tape and check
for deficiencies or wasted movement
i'd put the i had them put me on a
stopwatch over and over i checked my
time against one of my teammates to
compare i focused solely on the task at
hand i wasn't thinking about all the
other tasks i needed to master and i
certainly wasn't thinking about the
bridge just this one piece of the puzzle
focus rep after rep until i've felt i
was sufficient i repeated this process
throughout the entire deployment even
after i displayed enough capability to
my leadership where they felt confident
confident putting me on more and more
operations that's like one little thing
which no one would think about
and it's a freaking challenge for you
and you had to figure out how to do it
yeah because by the time i got to the
team man they were they were already
past their collective training phase
they'd already finished pmt they were
basically just
getting gear prepped taking some leave
and then heading into the box
so i had just like six weeks on the team
before we were back in afghanistan so
these tactical tasks you know they would
have been fleshed out in training if i
was with the guys leading up i didn't i
didn't have that time so things became
real on the ground the first time i
tried to climb into a
a matt v or an mrap and i'm like how the
hell do i even do this
you know
so that's just an example and you know
it's this a list of tasks that i i
performed the same way and i you know
down time
in between training and ops i would just
identify one of these things that i knew
needed work and i would just like go
crazy and just do it a thousand times
and like if i do this a thousand times
i'm gonna figure out how to do it
if i do it a thousand times i'm gonna
find a way to do it i just need to do it
a thousand times so like how do i do
that i'll do it a hundred times a day
you know for a hundred days or whatever
ten days
and what was your what was your mission
on this deployment what were you guys
doing so we were running the catego uh
which is an afghan commando unit that's
their tier one unit
that was um
established by kag years prior that they
handed off to us to run
so that's their premier um direct action
ct force so we were running those guys
based primarily um
up out of the kabul area
not kabul propa but in that vicinity
uh so we had we moved around the
basically the entire ao and just running
da's mostly yeah
what was your op tempo like
it wasn't as busy as uh as the
deployment i had priya
um
because they were just more specific
point target raids based on higher
levels of intel and higher levels of
effects whereas on the ground prior we
were just like going out and like paving
the road a lot of the way so this was
more tied to like strategic
initiatives and directions so we'd maybe
have a thing
maybe once a week once every couple
weeks
but in that time there were a couple
massive ops that we were a part of that
took up
good chunks of time one of that was was
when kindu's uh
the taliban took it over
um
we were part of that as well so we ended
up shifting
to that ao and we dedicated like two
three months
to the response to that and then to the
rebuild of that ao
how many guys were in that force you
were working with
we had around a company size element
about 110 dudes
and the craziest thing about working
with these guys so these guys were built
you know by keg years prior they had all
like all the equipment they had all the
gucci stuff
same uniforms
they're rocking pvs31s like they got
like high-speed stuff and they're all
juiced up like they're like
they're pumping like sustanon in there
like daily
which you see that right when you meet
these guys it's like very strange it is
yeah even like the standard afghan
commandos they aren't that outfitted
that way they don't look that way we
meet up with these dudes for the first
time and they're these just yoked up
afghans rock and cry precision like
this is weird but what made it i i i
never got to a point where i was
comfortable was under nods
everyone looks the exact same
whereas normally i can tell the
difference between my teammate and our
partner force instantaneously
when you got guys that size rocking the
same gear we are i couldn't tell who was
who dang so we you know we had different
like mockings that we used as like ir
makings to try to help us figure out
where we were
but i was constantly uncomfortable when
we were doing night stuff which was a
good portion of it
because i didn't know who was who yeah
that's not feeling good no man i didn't
lie didn't like how were they they were
good in the field they were good yeah
they were good they were good i mean
you know it's an afghan partner force
but they were they were the most
proficient that i'd ever seen no they
were good
and so that that deployment pretty
straightforward doing a bunch of das uh
any any big lessons learned from that
one
i mean i was drinking through a fire
hose because not only with my
afghanistan for the first time as an
amputee
i'm dealing with all these tactical gaps
we were living out of rucksacks most of
that trip so i didn't get a chance to
really establish like a rhythm
in one location at one time because we
were moving around so much
so i had to adapt
my loadout package
for vehicles for half infill ops for
dismounted ops like where do i keep my
extra legs where do i keep all my
equipment how do i carry all this stuff
that i'm going to need if and when
something breaks down
it was a forcing function
to
think about how i would go about doing
that
so
for every deployment i've had since
it's pales in comparison because i
i jumped off like the massive cliff to
begin with so now if i go someplace and
i'm working out of the same location
it's like easy quite simple comparably
why do you gotta bring an extra leg
like what scenario are you bringing an
extra leg in the field
all the time at least one
i mean the technology in this thing is
great but
it breaks
like legs legs break you know this
thing's got a little microprocessor in
it we've got batteries
it's got an internal battery yeah
there's a little computer inside this
knee so i have to charge it
and then it runs like a computer
it doesn't power charge last four it
depends on the level of activity because
it goes into like a hibernation mode
like a computer if like right now it's
it's like sleeping
so depending on how much i'm moving will
determine how much battery life i have
but on an even on an active
schedule a fully charged knee you'll get
me like three days okay
and so you're bringing a whole extra leg
in the field
at least one
yeah sometimes more than one yeah so i
would usually carry one mechanical
backup knee on my person in my ruck
and then i'd have a back up once that
way the mechanical ones are a lot
lighter because there's no technology
built into it
mechanical knee maybe
i don't know eight pounds nine pounds
god this one weighs freaking nine pounds
is a lot when you're humping around bro
that's not fun no i'd rather have not
have to carry it but
i've broken so many of these things that
it's
it's really i consider it a requirement
so my standard loadout for like a
vehicle type movement a gaff would be
a mechanical leg in my ruck an extra one
of these that i'm wearing now in my
truck and an extra one of these in
another truck
in case my truck was
disabled or blown up yeah i'd have
another leg somewhere to go get and
put on you know it kind of sounds like a
pain in the ass but it's also like hey
if you got shot in your freaking uh
prosthetic you're like cool let me just
put on the other one well it's funny
one of the conversations i had with my
group command team uh
they were voicing their concerns like
well what happens if your prosthetic
breaks in the field
and i said well i have i can carry an
extra one if your leg breaks in the
field you're out
and they kind of got to chuckle out of
that but that's true
so you got good you got proficient um
and
have a good solid deployment
yeah successful and
we had a lot of visibility on us that
whole trip i mean all the way up to like
washington
because i needed approval from the usa
commander to be able to go
the socom commander was aware of it so
no sf team no soft team wants a lot of
people
checking it checking in on them and
paying attention to what they're doing
and answering phone calls from you know
three-star generals no oda or team
leadership wants that
my team leadership dealt with a bunch of
that because it was almost like people
were expecting and waiting for something
to go wrong for them to pull me out and
be like hey we tried it it didn't work
let's like get back to reality here and
like let's find out like a real solution
for this dude
but that didn't happen we had a
successful trip
uh
no no issues so it was just it was just
hectic because i was doing this vehicle
type thing
in all my free time so after that six
month pump
i was the most tired i've ever been in
my life
what's the uh i know you you wrote about
how there's like a limit to the amount
of time you can spend on it well how
long can you patrol for like a foot
patrol so i've done you know multi-day
missions um
it just you know it does start to take
its toll after a while because there'll
be a point where i have to take it off
at a minimum you know wipe down the
sweat maybe throw on some ana purse
print type stuff get it back on and go
so um
it just depends on those different
variables but there were times when you
know i'd be in the field out on
something for four or five days and as
long as i had you know a couple two
three hours during my rest cycle to kind
of let that fluid go back into the
residual limb and kind of plump back up
strap it back on and and be good yeah
well be in the field for a few days
that's freaking legit that's awesome
uh did you come home from that
deployment and what but go again
that's the deal yeah back from that trip
um standard training cycle for us
individual schools collective training
um into pmt and then uh the the next
year the year after that trip uh we were
over in somalia on our next thing which
was
a ct mission as well ctda mission just
different continent but very very
similar
doing the same thing doing the same
thing did you have a partner for us over
there yeah we had five oh damn
yeah we had a bunch of somalis uh we had
some kenyans we had some ethiopians
and you're training them and you're
going out did they're doing work you're
doing work with them
yeah we were uh we were we were
targeting uh al-shabaab this is a you
know al qaeda affiliate
we were targeting those guys
and it's good op tempo it was busy
um we were going out
once uh two three times a week
uh we're doing da's yep doing d.a
outstanding yeah we were down south the
other unit we were working with was uh
was further up north and we would just
like flip-flop to support each other
it was busy and uh
are you getting a flow now you said like
hey once you did that first deployment
to afghanistan where you're living out
of a rock are you in a pretty good flow
now where
you're you're starting to be able to
deal with your leg it's not that big of
a factor yeah so the two years i had um
like since walter reed you know the
first trip to afghanistan or the train
up afghanistan now i'm like two two and
a half years post injury
i learned a lot of lessons and
ways to maintain my prosthetic and my
body so i'm learning how to do this so
by the time 2016 trip came around
i was i was much more confident in my
tactical prowess and
insertion within operations
hell yeah uh and then what's after that
somalia deployment another deployment
that was 2016.
so i came back from that and that was
when i transferred groups from third
group to fifth group
um the reason i transferred because my
wife
she went down
a different career path and got orders
for fort campbell
so i transferred groups at this point we
were married
so to stay with her obviously i
transferred from third to fifth
one over there and then uh got
integrated with those guys and then my
next trip was into lebanon
check
uh and you're obviously still active
duty right now we'll kind of let that
one please our imaginations for that
that deployment over there um at what
point did you decide you were going to
try and get a commission become a
warrant
or what you guys call in the army of
chief yeah yeah in the navy i'm sure you
know this yeah a chief is an illicit guy
in the navy and
we still have warrant offs we have chief
warrant officers but what point did you
want to become a warrant officer yeah i
started looking at it actually when i
was in somalia um because i warrant had
to go home on emergency leave and i kind
of took up a lot of those tasks
for the detachment
when i got back from uh
from lebanon is when i dropped that is
when i dropped that packet and got
picked up yep so we
the sf warrant offices
we go to fort bragg to go to our school
whereas every other army warrant officer
goes down to fort rucka and goes through
the warrant officer course
we have our own our own program because
it's the sf warrant officer is wildly
different than all the other warrant
officer branches
you know there's only two combat
warrant officers and those are aviators
and then sf guys the rest those are
those are managers like they
you run a desk
right because you're you're an expert in
that particular system and your job is
the managing task
on our side of the house it's it's
different because you're on the team
so we have our own school so i went and
did that that was in 2019
yeah five months my five-month course
it's a lot of writing and briefing and
officer stuff and you loved every second
salute to the army and the special
operations for this whole thing this is
just for them keeping you on that path
opening those things up you becoming a
warrant officer like that's freaking
just outstanding that they that this
happened you know i mean look this stuff
could be easily be shut down like there
could be some
some senior officer that's like i don't
think this is the right thing to do and
boom you know so it's outstanding that
you
actually that the army allowed this to
happen
do i believe it should hell yeah of
course but i'm saying man you know some
of these some of these bureaucrats like
they don't think that way they don't
think like you think they don't really
think like i think so salute to the army
and to sf for
for
keeping that door open
freaking that's just outstanding
uh i know how one of my guys was ryan
jobe was blind he's blinded
and you know i i talked to the admiral
and i was like hey sir he he wants to
stay in and the admiral's like whatever
he wants he wants to stand he we got
jobs for him yeah that's freaking
outstanding
um you get picked up from warren and
then what's the next step
next step is going to my next attachment
as the assistant attachment commando and
i was notified the team i was going to
go to with about two weeks left of the
warrant officer course
and the second i was told the team
number
i knew the type of team it was gonna be
which was a maritime ops team a dive
team yep right an sf all the all the
teams that ended the number five
they're dive teams
so i just completed the warrant office
of course right first amputee to ever go
it was challenging as hell um
believe it or not it's you know there's
a lot of physical stuff
to go back a bit when i first got to
group
the warrant office on the teams
stereotypically were the out of shape
old guys that were never around
well the regiment realized that and they
completely re-altered the the actual
course to include a lot of physical
gaits that you had to pass
because they didn't want these old
crusty out of shape guys on teams
anymore if you're going to be a warrant
officer on the team you need to be able
to function as a team guy and every oda
has the assistant commander is a warrant
is that right
every oda doesn't have a warrant
but because it's a small community most
do and that guy is the assistant
detachment commando because the sfoda
the 12-man construct is designed to run
split team ops it's not just a random
number yeah so the captain takes one
section and the warrant takes the other
yeah if there's no warrant who takes the
other one the the sergeant the would
would be the team sergeant the team
sergeant yeah the senior enlisted guy
where does the captain get his
experience before he's the captain of an
oda team is he coming from infantry is
that where he gets his initial
experience as a leader like as a platoon
commander or something yeah most come
from the infantry they don't necessarily
have to have an infantry background but
they're i mean they're green even like
the most experienced
new captain
in today's world you're not seeing it
that much because there's not a lot of
combat but they get maybe one trip as a
platoon leader in the conventional unit
go to the captain's career course go to
the q course and then show up
and that level of inexperience is why
the sf1 officer exists because
their trajectory they get two years on a
team and then they're gone
so the most senior captain on the team
has been there for 24 months
like that guy just barely figured out
yeah his job what an oda does how he fit
within the overall picture
and then he's onto the next thing
the warrant is there you know we're
expected to do five six years on the
same detachment we're there to be that
strategic advisor to that leader that's
freaking legit so you get the dive team
assignment
or sorry i cut you off so you you were
saying that warrant officer school was
actually there were some there were some
challenges in warren officer school
wasn't a walk in the park no no it was
it was legit yeah it was tough so i mean
i got like two weeks left before i'm
gonna graduate and i'm just about the
top of this ridgeline like graduation's
inevitable at this point so
i'm feeling pretty happy about my you
know my performance and where i'm going
i'm excited and then i get the phone
call like you're going to this team
right here
and uh
i had the same response that everyone
every sf guy gets when he's totally
going to a dive team which is
[__]
okay because everyone knows
cdqc the combat diver qualification
course everyone knows that that is the
hottest school
within the army
by a mile physically and mentally and
most uh fearful of it most don't want to
go down that road
you know
yeah i had the same resp i had the same
response it was okay well
my celebration here was short-lived
because now i got to figure out how i'm
going to do this
yeah that sounds like uh
like i was giving all these props to the
army i guess we got to give more prop
they're like cool oh you want to be a
warrant cool oh you got one leg how's
dive school sound
yeah and it's i mean it's funny man
because i got back to the group i got to
my new battalion got assigned to my new
team and i met with the company command
team the next day and within the first
couple minutes of that conversation they
told me that no one had any expectations
of me going to dive school
oh
i had the same conversation with the
battalion command team a couple days
later and was told the same thing from
them
god which i found was interesting you
know and i i looked at them kind of
sideways
and they said listen this team is
they're a bunch of aggressive
savages to see it's the most senior team
we have in the battalion
they're hungry for combat they haven't
seen it yet
we need a strong leader on that team
there are only two warrant officer
candidates there were only two of us in
fifth group that went me and my buddy
me and my buddy mike had wildly
different experiences mike did a lot of
like interagency stuff and he was more
on the technical side of things and did
a lot of intel stuff my experience was
like all combat so they looked at both
of our packets and they're like we can't
send this guy to a dive team especially
this one
it's gonna have to be nick but it'll
work because he's a strong leader
they'll respect them it'll it'll help
keep things moving in a general
direction
dive teams are known for being
insubordinate aggressive
you know it's the it's it's the it's the
double edged sword for leadership
because you got a really high performing
detachment but you're gonna have to deal
with their aggressiveness and keeping
them within line in a garrison
environment
so they made it clear to me that that
was the reason why i was going and yet
they didn't expect you to be actually
going through dive school like that
wouldn't be a requirement necessarily is
what they're thinking in their eyes
that's what they were thinking i didn't
see it that way yeah you're just like
okay well i gotta go do dive school
it's
it's the one thing
that separates dive teams from every
other detachment is going through that
extra filter
and it's really irrelevant to the actual
execution of maritime ops it's just that
fine filter
to be able to push yourself through that
hell
and then you take 12 guys that have all
been through that and lump them together
they are going to be a high performing
attachment no matter the mission were
you in the water much growing up
a little bit but not much of a group in
new england you know so yeah i mean
spent time in the water but
i wasn't a swimmer but okay you know
never scuba dived before
nothing so this is not gonna be fun
no
no it's not gonna be fun at all
uh
you gotta start training for it right
like you got to start figuring out like
getting comfortable in the water is a
big deal do they normally pick guys that
were have some comfort in the water or
do guys volunteer for does anyone
volunteer for it some do it's rare for a
new a new dude to show and be like put
me on a dive team most are happy with
the little green hat in the head and
they want to just like chill and just
get to team stuff
it does happen it's not very often that
it happens i think the sergeants major
they they do ask if there's an open slot
on a dive team hey you know are you
comfortable with water do you spend any
time swimming
you know which i think brings value to
your success in cdqc
is more about your being comfortable in
the water not necessarily your ability
as a as a freestyle swimmer oh yeah it's
definite comfort in the water i mean i
haven't been through that school but in
in basic seal training you go through
some pretty significant dive
challenges and people
it pays to be comfortable in the water
you have to be yeah so i do think they
they have that conversation um but if
the answer is no and they needed another
diva it's like okay well
you're going anyway and you had to fight
against a med board again just kind of
like get a waiver to go to this school
yeah it wasn't a med board but i did
need a waiver approved to be able to go
because of my physical profile so there
had never been an amputee to even like
consider going
and now i'm kind of back where i was
where i had to fight the admin fight and
then also prepare myself physically and
mentally
so the admin side it worked out great
for me because i went through my die
physical which is the most in-depth
physical we have in the army they check
you for everything because it's just
such a high stress school
there's two phases i get through both of
those both are clean both are good to go
and then
our med clinic sends up the waiver
for me to be able to attend
administratively well that needs to be
approved by the swix surgeon who's a
full bird colonel
i said okay cool send it
i get a phone call about a week later
from some 910 area code number which is
north carolina
answer the phone and there's just some
dude on the other end of the phone like
yelling
and he's talking about
a one-legged guy who wants to go to dive
school and i think that someone had just
dialed my phone number by accident and
i'm overhearing a conversation about me
and i'm going hello who is this dude's
just yelling
talking real aggressively talking real
fast finally he stops i'm like who is
this
he's like nick it's it's mike
and uh
i said doc how you doing well mike
was the third group surgeon back when i
was in afghanistan
he was the first guy that operated on me
when i got flown into bagram
he had since been promoted to 06 and was
working as the swic surgeon so he and i
knew each other real well i didn't know
that that's where his job was
until he calls me
and i'm like oh no kidding okay
he's like i'm staring at you your waiver
it's in front of me right now
i said are you going to approve it he's
like yeah i already did i just i just
sent it back he's like i think you're
out of your mind
that you want to go do this but if you
want to go go ahead like good luck
so
you know ironic turn of events if it was
anybody other than him
who knows if that would have been
approved because that you are assuming
quite a bit of risk
uh both for him as the medical
professional and then the commander in
which he works underneath like they're
assuming that risk to send me to a
course like that as a student
he gave me the green light and then once
i had that i had already been training
you know physically my first day on the
team
i was in the pool
day one like i just met these guys it's
my first day in this battalion it's my
first day as a warrant officer and i'm
in the i'm in the pool you gotta get
like uh
thin legs or something [__] yeah so i
did you know and i went to my
prosthetist and i said i need a fin
and uh they make you know fins for
amputees it's not it's not like a new
thing he gave me this one
and things may be
i don't know three feet in length it's
small
and my teammates called him my finding
nemo finn it's just the difference
between my leg and this thing was just
so different but the concern was that
you know if it's if it's a longer lever
it places more force through
the socket what's actually attaching to
my body so we were concerned that if it
was too long i was generating too much
force it would rip the prosthetic off my
body so we went with the more secured
option even though it gave me less
propulsion
so that was what i had and uh you know i
just said you know roger that this is my
equipment i'm just going to figure out
how to make it work
really had to turn my left leg into just
an absolute tank because that's what was
propelling me for treading and for
underwater nav for all the thinning was
my left leg
that's what i used
uh
in the pool during our train up and you
know my teammates were phenomenal but at
the same time it was no one really knew
how to
do this with a guy with one leg so it
was a lot of trial and error and like
figuring it out
did that
and then uh i was in communication with
the leadership down at cdqc uh they
reached out to me once they were made
aware that an amputee was going to come
down
it was a third group dude who was
actually one of my instructors in the
queue course
was now the sergeant major down there so
he hit me up and was like
hey man just like keep me updated with
if you're modifying any specific
procedure i just need to know what that
is because my instructors don't like
know what this looks like you know so
you know like
maritime ops and especially in the
schoolhouse it's very procedural like
left foot here right foot here it's
broken down step by step by step to
increase efficiency and reduce risk to
keep it as safe as possible well for me
some of those steps just don't exist if
it's like put your right foot here well
like i don't have one so what am i doing
when everyone else is putting that right
foot over there right so just those
small little tweaks
is what my team and i were kind of
playing around with
and then i messaged that to the cadre
down there it was ultimately up to them
to decide if what i was doing
would meet their standard requirements
a couple adaptations with a couple
different things but uh
and then the cdqc journey what's the
attrition rate at that school
it varies from
up to like 60 percent there are some
classes they graduate like five guys
you know because if you just if you fail
they just send you back to sf you just
can't be on the dive team type thing
you usually will get
two or three attempts at it okay which
is quite common
for it to take a guy maybe twice how
long is the school six weeks
um
you got a section in here
you talk a little bit about this which i
had a lot of joy and laughter when i was
reading it
the combat diver qualification course or
dive school has several tests students
must successfully complete each is
designed with a purpose according to
years of data collection and lessons
learned from generations of previous
combat divers the most notorious is the
one man competency exam
during this test students are required
to wear a black blacked out mask to
simulate nighttime conditions and then
surge underwater for several currents
once the surge phase is complete the
students are placed at the bottom of the
pool and paired up with an instructor
who systematically removes the student's
air source regulator and in places a
series of deficiencies
so how do i breathe without a regulator
you don't you hold your breath
the student is required to trace the air
source line from its origination point
to the regulator while on a breath hold
in order to retrieve the air source and
breathe this process is repeated until
the exam is completed if this sounds
awful it is because it is just that
awful the one man competency exam is
widely considered the most difficult
test within dive school and is the
reason why so many do not advance in the
course there is however a method to this
madness
conducting underwater operations is
arguably the most dangerous task we do
within the military the ocean is
unforgiving a plethora of things can go
wrong and as with most operations
something will almost certainly will go
wrong given the fact that we as humans
require oxygen above all else to live
problems underwater can quickly turn
deadly during underwater operations it
is just you and your team at times
perhaps it is just you and your dive
buddy and if things really go bad it's
just you when a problem presents itself
you absolutely must be able to correct
it
and depending on the severity of the
issue time becomes a critical factor
every second counts pressure is at an
all-time high the stress of these
situations can be incapacitating the
only way to work through the situation
is to remain calm
good times
we have a test like that similar it's
called pool competency it's the same
thing they're just going to freaking
jack you up underwater yeah
it's not fun sounds no it's not fun
you gotta fight the demons
every survival instinct you have as
humans
you gotta battle through that yeah yeah
uh
but you made it through
yep you you made it through that that
dive things you failed a couple of times
i failed one man twice
how many chance do you get three
yes i blacked out underwater uh my first
two go-rounds and my blackout experience
they they tell you
you know you're gonna start to feel
yourself going like when you're being
choked out like things get soft and
start to feel yourself getting
comfortable like you're on the verge of
blacking out yeah i that doesn't happen
with me
mine is just continued increase in pain
and discomfort and then
you're out
and then i come to and i'm on the pull
deck what kind of are you using a like a
normal regulator like the kind with one
hose that you press a button and air
comes out of it
for this yeah you're using open water
tanks on your back with the standard
regulator yeah we have this in seal
training they have this
regulator from like
1968 or something
and it's got
two hoses one's an inhalation hose and
one's an exhalation hose
and it looks like you know if you look
at jacques cousteau diving in
1973 like that's what he's using
and it there's no button to press
it you have to drink the water out you
just suck the water out of it when you
put it back in your mouth and they just
take this thing and freaking it's insane
the only reason that this regulator
exists is for buds at this point oh they
use this they still use it wow they
still use it to this day um
it's cr it's crazy it's a crazy
evolution uh yeah but i've talked to
some of the people that that work at
that company and they were like yeah
that's the only people we make for i
guess there's i guess there's an
occasional person that will request it
if they're an underwater photographer
because the bubbles are behind your back
but other than that it's just these
because there's no reason to use it it's
the worst it's the worst piece of
equipment ever like for diving like they
probably made it and like a year later
like hey this is dumb fix it but that's
what we still use
uh not fun
um all right so you get done
you pass now you're a warrant officer
inside of a inside of your oda team
rack up another deployment where you go
on this one
the one after that uh we're in iraq
damn okay
doing a lot of diving in iraq were you
not much what year was that
no kidding last year well we went in in
uh december of 20. december 20 into 21.
i mean from what you can say without
going into classified material like what
was your general mission
advise assist i mean the iraq of today
is much different than the iraq of your
days
how did you like being the number two
guy in command
i enjoyed it yeah we did a couple uh
split team scenarios but then uh
because of what we were doing was pretty
routine
uh myself and my actual team leader we
would just swap out at times so i got
some reps at the detachment commander
thing so it was good and you like that
being in a leadership position very much
so it's it's difficult as a warrant
because
the way it was described to me was it's
a commandless
thankless selfless position you know
when you have that tripod of leadership
attachment commander the captain your
senior enlisted guy
and then the warrant officer
you know the the detachment command is
in charge of the team he runs the team
the senior enlisted guy the team
sergeant he runs the boys like they all
work for him the warrant exists kind of
in between that
and the way you influence as a as a
leader is more done through your actions
than it is about having one-on-one like
molding sessions with the individuals
because that's really the job of the
team sergeant so your approach to
leadership as a warrant
has to be a mature one
which is tough for a lot of us because
we're aggressive type a pipe hitters who
think we know exactly what right looks
like so you have to
stay back from that and lead through
supporting others and lead through more
of your actions than your
verbal
can be tough
and then
so where are you at right now are you
still at a team
i just came off the team and so where
are you stationed now i'm still fort
campbell still in fifth group uh i'm
just took over as the company operations
warrant
for our advanced skills company
so
when i was working in the combatives
committee it was underneath the advanced
skills company so now i'm amongst the
company level leadership where i work
alongside a major and a sergeant major
got it
uh you know that that kind of brings us
up to date for
this
for where you're at right um what you
got going on
you know that this is the thing though
about this book is
this book
this book objective secure it's not
it's not a memoir of your life it's not
it's not like hey here's a bunch of
stories
it's actually uh
it's actually like almost like a field
manual of how you can overcome things
and how you can achieve things in life
which
is is a pretty awesome book and looks
look
obviously i read some of the stories out
of it today because you relate oh this
event happened here's you know what
occurred here's what caused me to do
this here's where i learned this lesson
there's a lot of that stuff in there but
the actual book is i mean the the
subtitle the book is battle tested
guide to goal achievement right which is
freaking legit like hey
here's a guy that has gone through a
bunch of obstacles
and overcome those obstacles and he did
it not by luck not by miracles but by
figuring out how to assess these things
and how to overcome them
and you take the military
methodology that you learned from being
in special operations and you applied
that to your life and apply that to the
challenge you face and you
you outline that throughout this book
and that's why if you know if you're
listening right now just order this book
right now because there's so much good
information in it to help anybody that's
overcoming anything
that's facing any obstacles but
i've i would feel bad if i didn't at
least give people sort of a heads up
sort of some of the highlights that you
go over in the book um
so i just want to crack this thing open
and like just like i said just hit some
of the high points
of any of of how you live your life how
you overcame these things um the book is
called objective secure you start off
with objective security military brevity
term used during the execution of combat
operations meaning the location or
target has been isolated and contained
the assault force has eliminated all
known threats and the element is
prepared to move to the next objective
phase of the operations
of the operation reaching objectives
secured during a combat operation is a
good feeling it means we have a foothold
a location to reconsolidate establish
communications prepare stage and if
necessary fall back to
but this does not mean the mission is
complete
objective secure in our context here is
twofold first it is a victory a
milestone it marks the success of
achieving a necessary goal along the
route to mission accomplishment
second it is a tool a system a
methodology a process designed to
manifest our reality objective secure is
a philosophy and a blueprint that was
created in real time refined then
retrospectively analyzed following years
of trial and error years of failure
years of obstacles and years of
adversity it was forged by fire and is
battle tested
literally
objective secure
did you have that name out of the gate
for the book
no
not at all
i mean
i created this thing
the original
objective secure was about a nine page
microsoft word document that i slapped
together
as the result of
being asked the same question hundreds
and hundreds of times was how did you do
what you did
so
rather than answering those
every single time
email address
yeah i said you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna i'm gonna answer that question
put a little more thought into it
and that way i can just attach and send
it was about efficiency i created the
original one of these things purely out
of efficiency to answer the question to
provide that information to those that
were seeking it
it wasn't until years later i used it as
such for years it was until years later
that uh a good buddy of mine now my
business partner hit me up i was
actually still in dive school i had
about a week left and he called me out
of the blue and said
i think you need to write a book
and i said
get away get out of here what are you
talking dude i'm clinging by a thread
down here i'm exhausted
i can't even have this conversation with
you
we eventually circled back a couple
weeks later and i gave it some thought
and this is in the middle of 2020 covid
i got a lot of extra time and energy on
my hands gyms are closed the combatives
house is closed
we're doing this weird half on half off
work schedule you know remote lpd
sessions it was just a strange time i
had a lot of extra time and energy that
i otherwise wouldn't have had
so out of respect to him i gave him some
thought
thought about that microsoft word doc
and i said i actually kind of have
something and he said just keep going
with it and see what it turns into
so i sunk my teeth into it i became real
obsessed with it i really found out that
i actually enjoy writing which if you
had asked me that a week before this i
would have said no
no interest but i actually do enjoy it
but i didn't figure out the title until
maybe about the halfway point i started
thinking about it and then it kind of
kind of flipped yeah you got um
what
you the way you run your life and it
becomes really clear in the book i
haven't touched on these part of the
books yet but like
you're you're very calculating in
everything that you do this is what i
need to get done here's what and that's
what makes this so effective and
obviously it's worked
outstanding for you to be able to pull
off the kind of [__] that you've pulled
off
uh
that comes across um and one of the
things that one of the ways that you
break down the book is you use some of
the well you use
the way you learn things in the army and
one of the things that you talk about is
the the ethos
um the warrior ethos and here's part of
it
i will always place the mission first
now i realize the term mission has a
strong military undertone but it this
absolutely applies to everybody because
everybody has dreams that's what the
mission is it's a dream the long-term
goal the mission is what is waiting at
the end of the road missions are
impactful often life-changing but for
many the mission will remain just that a
dream
many do not reach mission success many
do not turn the dream into a reality
those who do are able to recognize the
need for something
sacrifice
a subset of discipline something we'll
get into later the act of foregoing what
we want
for what we need
so
you break these things down
so when we say i'm fast forwarding so
when we say i will always leave i will
always place the mission first what we
are saying is i will make the necessary
sacrifices and i will prioritize my time
and again i'm like jump you've got all
kinds of
applications of this where people read
and be like oh i think that might be me
right there oh i think he's talking
about me over here or oh i need to do
i need to do better on that thing so
this this this book is very practical
from that perspective
the next section i'll read is i will
never accept defeat
this statement has a somewhat obvious
meaning behind it resolve resiliency
and toughness the mentality is that if
you get knocked down seven times you get
up eight pretty pretty straightforward
let me read one little section out of
this our egos do not digest failure
easily
our egos want us to constantly project
strength ability and knowledge our egos
can prevent us from asking questions and
pushing our limitations
humility requires allowing ourselves to
become vulnerable to expose our
weaknesses things that are extremely
difficult for most and for individuals
who work in the special operations
community they're next to impossible
gotta stay humble
it can be tough
so when we say i will never accept
defeat what we are saying is strive for
failure and when you reach it
learn from it apply it
and keep moving forward
again a bunch of good examples you throw
in here about this
um
and all totally pragmatic
next one i will never quit initially
this sounds similar to what we just
talked about but upon further
examination we'll recognize the
difference
i will never quit is about avoiding
complacency it is not letting ourselves
get comfortable not celebrating too long
not accepting status quo and not growing
stagnant it is adopting the principle
that satisfaction doesn't exist
and that now
is the time to attack
check
a lot these things
have a lot more meaning
when determining the appropriate
rucksack
we need to think about the mission we
need to choose the right size rucksack
for the job choose one too small we'll
not be able to bring the necessary
equipment choose one too large and we
tend to fill the extra space with things
we want rather than only the things we
need ounces equal pounds next thing you
know we're humping 70 pounds instead of
60 pounds
at first this may go unnoticed but as
the miles continue
the extra 10 pounds take their toll
this will undoubtedly increase fatigue
and reduce focus and ability leaving us
less effective when it is time to go to
work
and this is what made me want to read
this same as with ounces
minutes become hours hours become days
days become weeks and before you know it
a year has passed with little to show
for it
um later in the book you got some of
your
time like you got your daily schedule
written out
it's like to the minute
yeah
there's no time being wasted for
freaking nick no man not when nick's on
the mission man we're nick's trying to
get back to an oda team there's not a
men there's not a second wasted
can't can't
i mean for one
just the the the the
gift of perspective with coming as close
to death as i did
driving in how precious
life is and how time is our most limited
resource and just to maximize the gift
of we have of minute to minute to minute
just that that perspective
was given to me
through what happened
and then when you've got you know big
goals
that's what it takes that's what it took
for me
anyway
well i think that's actually just what
it takes
not just for you but for anybody
i will never leave a comrade i will
never leave a fallen comrade we know the
obvious meaning behind this the meaning
reserved for the warfighter the
mentality that no matter what nobody
gets left behind
when we open the aperture a bit however
this tenant is speaking to a commitment
to doing whatever it takes
yeah there's not too many
there's not too many sayings that have
the word never in them right and that's
what this is this is like the the
commitment
you talk about this in this section when
we understand that everybody eventually
hits a decision point
and that when they do most give in our
decision point becomes an opportunity
man we were just talking about this the
other day like your life our lives are
just a bunch of decisions
they're just
they're just all decisions what are you
gonna do what are you gonna eat when are
you gonna get up what are you gonna do
today what progress do you make what
time are you gonna
waste you say it gives us a chance to
either extend our lead or make up ground
on our competition
through this understanding we will begin
to welcome these decision points we will
seek them we will find ourselves
intentionally pushing until we find
ourselves standing at the crossroads and
when we arrive when most would find
themselves conflicted we are not we
embrace it
so when we say i will never leave a
fallen comrade what we are saying is i
will do whatever it takes to make it at
times we have to ignore the brain listen
to the heart
and take the risk
it's
it's weird how many decisions you make
without even thinking about the fact
that you have a choice right you just
people just allow things to happen in
their lives sure oh that just you know
oh what are you doing today uh
you know what i mean what are you doing
today oh you know
like no that's not part of the plan
that's not part of the plan
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
work
nick knows what he's doing he knows what
he's doing on sunday
afternoon
at 13 40.
he knows what's up
uh
and this is where you break down
how we're gonna execute this
so like you just kind of talked about
the mindset through the warrior ethos
now you get into the execution of this
whole thing
phase one is the mission here's where we
identify the mission and again how many
people are going through life they don't
even have their mission identified i'd
say a lot you know i've talked about the
fact that i was very lucky because when
i was very young i
joined the navy and i just wanted to be
a good seal
and what
like that gives you you can make so many
decisions based on that you can make
you can do so much just on having a goal
like that
here's where we identify the mission
this is a long-term goal the dream the
what we are trying to accomplish the who
we aspire to become there's a reason why
this is phase one is
it is exceedingly important if we botch
this up
we may be making progress but progress
in the wrong direction
so if you're listening right now and you
don't know what your mission is you're
already you already got up a significant
problem you get a problem going on
because where are you going
where are you going right now
what is your mission
if you don't have a mission you need to
figure out what it is
100 percent
and yeah i think that the way that you
like
had that man you freaking woke up from a
coma without a leg and were like cool
i'm going back to an oda team there's my
mission
like this is what i'm doing
uh
design we must have a solid
understanding of our current situation
our mission our obstacles and how we are
going to advance this may sound
intimidating but don't let it overwhelm
you
and then you break out you know there's
another thing we didn't talk about uh we
didn't talk about the fact that
once you didn't have a leg you're like
all right
i need to be beneficial to my team in
other ways beyond just physical
you know you're gonna be able to hold
this standard and i would say you
probably could do a lot better than the
standard but you're like hey there might
be some deficiencies that i have because
i only have one freaking leg so i'm
gonna make up for that and you started
going to
some of the more cerebral parts of
special forces started going to schools
to learn
you know operational art and design
and and that way you had something else
to offer it was like almost like a
backup plan if you didn't have it all
physically which again i would i would i
would say you definitely have a
physically but if you had some slack
there you're gonna be able to make up
for it
yeah that was a conscious decision that
you made yeah that was tough uh to
accept that growing up as an athlete and
a fighter and you know being that door
kicker on the team is what my team
wanted of me it's what i enjoy doing
spend time in the gym the fight house on
the range
and everybody it was a win-win
accepting the fact that no matter how
hard i trained i was never going to be
as physically dominant as i was with two
legs
how can i make up the difference and
still be that asset
and this was in the hospital i was still
an inpatient status living in the
hospital going through surgeries when
this happened
and actually the you saw commander at
the time general cleveland he showed up
just to visit me
we had a conversation and that's what
opened up my eyes to
the other
skills within being an all-encompassing
green beret or an effective oda kind of
the softer side of our business you know
most of us come in because we want to
kick down doors and shoot bad guys in
the face but there's a lot of other
skills and tasks that enable that to be
able to happen
so i recognized it then
and
committed to it
in my own personal time so rather than
reading about exercise physiology or
nutrition i was reading about cultural
dynamics in afghanistan i was enhancing
my foreign language skills
i hated doing this stuff man i
absolutely hated it i loved the way i
spent my time with two legs i didn't
want to do this at all but i i believed
that it would work
i just forced myself to do it man which
i'm preaching to the
to the gospel or i'm i'm preaching to
the choir on this is like the discipline
to to execute on the tasks that you know
will bring value is the road to success
doing the thing whether or not you feel
like doing it or not and i know like
you're the
subject matter expert on this i've
learned a lot of this from you
personally during all of the stuff we're
talking about
it's like did the research i know this
will work or i'm confident this will
work yeah it sucks
but doing the things that suck is what
separates the average from the great so
diving myself into this road
operational and design was a school i
went to i needed a waiver to go because
i was in e6
and it's reserved for more senior
leaders who are going to be dealing with
like campaign planning and type stuff
but i went
as a as a tool to increase my cerebral
and intellectual capacity overall but
then i was able to leverage what i
learned in the course and apply it to my
mission
take take the lessons learned and
actually
use those techniques to outline my
day-to-day life and my operational
approach so it was it was multifaceted
what i was able to leverage by doing
that yeah it's almost like what we were
talking about earlier with leadership
and how leadership's a skill well you
know planning is a skill and
designing
courses of action to overcome obstacles
it's not just something you're born with
you can actually learn how to do it and
that's what you did you went learn how
to do it and here you look you applied
it in the field but here you're applying
it to your life
uh you go through this you go through
this phase diagram you got this all
these diagrams in here determine your
current situation
define the mission frame the problem
identify lines of effort you go through
this whole thing um
and then once you figure out what the
lines of effort are you talk about how
you're going to now attack those lines
you got the next phase which is research
access to information has never been as
readily available as it is today
never there's absolutely no excuse to be
uninformed
i don't know how it's just that an
excuse an avoidable reason we must set
ourselves up for success the key to this
phase however is to move quickly we
cannot get stuck here the research is
solely to get the wheels spinning and
provide some direction to advance down
our lines of effort
so you're and you give like examples of
this
uh what is it one of the examples you
give is hey i'm living in a crappy house
i want to get a new house here's the
things i can here's the problem here's
how i can make this happen
it's a campaign plan oh i gotta get a
cheaper rent right now so i can save
more money i got to get some additional
income like you go through it
another one you got in here is what is
it becoming an instructor right like
like these are things that you're doing
to
you you've actually taken these
methodologies and applied them to your
life
um
and it's not complicated
next phase is approach this is where we
create our approach we have already
determined our long-term goal our
mission our 300-meter target we have
also identified our lines of effort the
broad conceptual categories along which
we will advance in phase four we are
going to implement the list of tasks and
considerations we identified through
research the series of short-term goals
that exist between where we are now and
where we are trying to go along
our uh
lines of advance
this these of our objectives
are 25 50 100 and 200 meter targets
here is where we prioritize organize and
correlate along the timeline
so again there's another place where
people can get caught up right oh i
created a good idea i have a good plan
and then they don't execute on it they
don't they don't well not they don't
execute we're gonna get there but they
don't figure out what do i need to
actually do to get there like okay i see
that i want a new house
i know i need money how am i gonna get
more money that's what this is what are
you gonna what do you do what are you
gonna actually make happen here
freaking again
these things seem obvious
it's it's it's really not
that complicated and i think a lot of
people ask that question how to whoever
they look up to or learn from
wanting a complicated answer
because it just enables
the
excuse well this is just too complex
well he's a seal he's a green beret like
i can't i'm not either of those things
so this doesn't apply to me it's like
it's actually quite simple
it's not necessarily easy
but it is simple yeah uh the amount of
times i've been asked
how do you get up early in the morning
and my response is oh i set my alarm
clock or when it goes off i get out of
bed
that's legitimately what it is no that's
when your alarm clock goes off you get
out of bed
that's what you do
that must be it's simple not easy
simple
that freaking pillow a pillow grabs a
hold of echo charles over there man i
think
you get strangled by that big man you
can put chokeholds over there it's very
dangerous yes uh
here's another place people miss out you
gotta execute
phase five execute discipline discipline
is controlled behavior in other words it
is the combination of sacrifice and time
prioritization
warrior ethos one i will always place
the mission first with discipline we are
stopping ourselves from doing what we
like or want
to do and or forcing ourselves to do
things we need to do
that's another thing i i'll use that uh
answer sometimes like you know what you
need to do
actually know what you need to do just
not doing it
like you're not going to get better at
jiu jitsu not doing jiu jitsu you're not
going to get in good shape
by not working out you know what you
need to do
like you said i think there's people
that want you to say well there's a big
complex thing that we need to discuss
there's actually not
just stop doing it
just start doing
it uh
focus to remain disciplined we must
remain focused
this right here is essential we have our
plan it's broken down into a series of
objectives each objective has a series
of requirements and tasks that we must
accomplish to reach objective secure we
know there will be a host of challenges
and obstacles along the way we
anticipate setbacks we project failures
we are prepared
but what are we actually focusing on
during the process the reality of it is
it's our choice
picture you getting your purple belt
here by the way
2016.
check
how many times a week you train
now yeah i'm coming off of shoulder
surgery so um none but usually
two three days uh-huh yeah what happened
to shoulder
i told my labrum doing jiu jitsu
no this was just wear and tear but it i
completely dislocated it back in 14 in a
jiu jitsu tournament
shredded the labrum
put it back together wait 2014
isn't that when you were still a white
belt
yeah i think i in this particular
tournament i just belted blue yeah
there's a lot of people that were
unhappy the day they saw you in the
freaking bracket
you know what i'm saying well i mean
especially it's you know it's a weight
class yeah
right so i mean from from the waist up
if you looked at me versus my opponents
like there's no way these guys are in
the same
weight class [__] how much do you weigh
right now right now i'm probably
what would you weigh if you had your
other leg
yeah that's no really no that's 45
pounds of leg it's just not there
anymore wait so you said right now you
weighed you weigh well right now about
215 215.
yeah that's messing up some people some
people have bummed out where they see
that bracket
they're looking at you going there's hey
get a scale
yeah and i you know when i was in the
hospital i learned a lot from anthony
robles all-american wrestler born with
one leg at arizona state i read his book
unstoppable to help me with my training
and it's funny there's an excerpt in the
book from his mother who talks about how
when he was real young
the other parents would be like hey this
isn't fair he only has one leg like go
easy on him you know because he was
learning how to do it so they they
noticed that as a disadvantage and they
felt bad for him
well once he got real good
and beefed up his upper body it was the
complete opposite where now the parents
are going this isn't fair because he's
wrestling at you know 205 but really
he's got the upper body of someone who's
235. so it just it went complete 180.
it's like i can take advantage of this
yeah
damn
uh
you got a section in this part hard work
now that we choose to stay on track it's
time to put in the work
here's where the tangible gains are made
bottom line up front good things come to
those who work hard
great things however come to those who
are willing to do whatever it takes to
those who are willing to push themselves
to a higher level
we're going a little beyond hard work
we're going for you nick style
structure
our daily structure informs us of what
are we what we are doing and when this
is of course created based on many of
the objective secure considerations and
requirements and like any schedule this
provides us with some structure a guide
and and you got some uh
cool examples of of your freaking
schedule and stuff in here
um
i wanted to point this out cost of
ambition
we can quickly disregard those who
genuinely don't want to see
us succeed they are irrelevant so
there's no associated cost the haters of
the world
suffer from insecurity they lack
confidence they look to tear down
somebody rather than build themselves up
because it's easier they're weak ignore
and move on easy
our loved ones want our time because
they love us in the onset they are
genuinely supportive of the goal
cheering us on any way possible then the
realization sets in that in order to
accomplish this mission we are going to
have to prioritize the tasks necessary
to reach the objective along the way
this takes time
time that is spent elsewhere there's
going to be some friction here yeah
especially those that you know have
spouses kids this is where this is where
this gets tough yeah how old are your
kids right now five and 16 months that's
awesome
freaking outstanding
uh
fear they don't want to see us
disappointed manage your expectations
don't get your hopes out up this is out
of love big goals are inherently a long
shot we we have accepted the fact that
there will always be failures along the
way we have accepted the fact that it's
going to be painful
resentment
it's always good to think about that
number one to make sure that you're not
getting caught up in it
because this thing will eat you alive
man
and the biblical story of cain and abel
i've talked about this a lot
cain was so resentful of abel that he
literally killed his brother
just literally killed him his brother no
right we use the term brother in the mo
the strongest bond we can possibly have
with another human
and this guy killed his brother because
he was resentful
so you got to watch out for yourself and
you've also got to watch out for other
people when those around us see our
drive our work ethic or dedication they
too may feel obligated to perform
oftentimes as a positive chain reaction
accepted with gratitude and resulting in
output this may also however have a
negative response
it is not a catalyst for performance
they can they cannot refuse to
reciprocate which results in a feeling
of laziness or lack of ambition
similarly
some have also attempted to achieve the
goal themselves and were defeated our
success will affirm their inability to
do the same in both cases rather than
being a source of motivation we can
become a source of resentment
we must also be aware of the flip side
the same coin when our ambition and
determination are not reciprocated by
those around us our loved ones it can
result in our resentment towards them
you gotta watch out for that one
sneaky
sneaks up on you no you know it's uh
one of my buddies was trying to seth
stone was trying to go he's like hey i
want to go to i want to go to uh
princeton there was like a program to go
to princeton while you're in the seal
teams
and he asked me like hey do you think i
should go i was like hell yeah man and
he's like well some of the other guys
are telling me don't go it's not gonna
be bad for my career i was like bro
how's it gonna be bad for your career to
be a seal officer that went to freaking
princeton and has a degree in uh
international policy like who said that
and i think it's the same thing people
just didn't want him to get that little
extra little
thing going on his life a little
resentment coming through yeah maybe
watch out for that one
community to put it bluntly if we hang
around with losers we'll become a loser
that one's kind of kind of speaks for
itself
i think the classic is you are the
average of the five you spend the most
time with you know which i don't think
is nice like statistically
accurate but anecdotally and common
sense-wise that makes sense to me for
sure for sure and by again i'm
you've got all kinds of backing up data
and stories and information to
to explain these things i'm just trying
to hit the high point so people know
that when they get this book they're
gonna get a legitimate
guide on how to how to live
uh consistency unfortunately it's easy
it's easy to be great for a day
anybody can do it but the other 364 days
that make the difference and this is
truly the most challenging aspect of
execution consistency
that catches a lot of people off guard
discipline hard work and consistency how
can you stop someone who is willing to
stay on track despite temptation someone
who's willing to sacrifice and put in
hard work someone who is willing to
dedicate himself or herself on a daily
basis how can you stop someone who is
willing to do whatever it takes
the answer is you can't
phase six track there's no reason to
over complicate this one it's simple
this is simply keeping track of what you
are doing and how you are doing
it's a diary really for all my alpha
tough guys out there you will likely
refer to this as a log
but that's all it is we are logging our
actions what we're doing how we're doing
it how what's the oldest law you got
logs from your freaking college workouts
oh yeah i go back down decades yeah no
yeah old school yeah
i've got some i've got some old old
i have the little right in the rain
notebooks
and so i've got that i just always track
a workout in and i've got probably
what is it 20 22
i might have
15 years worth
of i could pull up i'm gonna have to
check that one i pulled i had to pull it
up right we had a we had a little
situation unfold a little situation
well we we uh
we there was a guy that uh did a did a
video about me being on steroids
and i've never done steroids um and
you know he kind of broke down he had
broken down like what we had said on
this one particular video where we were
we were kind of just having fun
bullshitting back and forth and you know
talking about echo skinny knees
and
a lot of people thought that was funny
and anyways you know this guy uh his
name
he's got a video uh a thing called more
plates more dates
uh good good dude his name is derek
anyways he made a video and he just did
like an assessment i competed in jiu
jitsu i like he just did an assessment
it's like oh yeah he's probably on trt
and probably juiced at one time and i
just we just made one back and said like
hey no actually i i haven't and i i i
realized that there was things that i
said
that made him think well oh jocko says
he can you know squat 405 for 20 reps
which i kind of like i don't know if i
actually said yeah or 10 reps or
whatever it was but i i'd said it
bullshitting with echo on the podcast it
was even a real podcast we were just
kind of like it was before
so was that i said i worked out four
times a day like there's some little
clip where i'm like oh four times a day
and i had to clarify well what i mean is
like oh on a good day i lift i run i go
to jiu jitsu and i surf
those are all some physical those are
all tiring right but they're not like i
i didn't do
some crazy workouts so anyways um
while we were doing that i kind of went
back and just kind of reviewed
you know just to get some real numbers
out there where i said hey here's what
here's an actual number this is the time
so that's why that's like the last time
but i got just like stacks of these
little notebooks you know
but uh
journaling
you're talking about journaling over
there man yeah man some alpha males are
gonna get freaking distraught that's why
that's why i talk about it as much as i
do because what are you gonna do you're
gonna you're gonna call me a [__]
[Music]
i mean we're like really you know that's
not like ego talking it's like one i
don't care yeah and two like okay good
luck with that but like journaling
logging is a huge part of my day to day
yeah and i'm like i'll scream that from
the rooftops and it's always good like
you i i since i track my since i write
down i can't track is a strong word for
me
but
what i like about it is over time if
you're not careful you can start to
like let some things slide a little bit
you know you're like well you know i
only really need to do this or
i only need to really do that or what
can i actually do oh this is good enough
i think
and i had i had this conversation with
the bert soren from sorenex you know
what i'm talking about
and i was like man there's exercises
that i do just to make sure that i don't
lose that capability like whatever it is
whatever that exercise is muscle ups
like overhead squats like i had her
elbow for a year man i could not do an
overhead squat couldn't do it
maybe it wasn't a year but you know in
my little log book it says elbow still
hurt you know what i mean can't do
overhead squats so i know what's going
on i know why i'm not doing it
um those little
things to put in there do you use any
like the uh electronic tracking devices
of your sleep or your whatever no not
yet no not yet i mean the technology
seems to make a lot of sense
uh
i haven't i haven't found a gap yet
where i may need to know that i got
one two five hours of sleep at 75
percent efficiency like
i think i don't know what difference it
would make like it's time to get up
period so let's say
my watch says i only got you know 40
quality sweet it's like it doesn't
matter yeah actually i was talking to jp
and he said so he was doing my buddy jp
um
and he said that he started sort of his
attitude would adjust based on what his
he stopped wearing it because it's it
would say
oh you need more rest and he'd be like
oh this workout's good and he and he
said he took it off bro he's like i'm
not doing this no because it doesn't
matter like you just said hey i'm up
this is the workout i have to do i'm
gonna go do it when you see hey you're
only at 27 recovery
man
come on start to feel it
uh phase seven assess
this is where we analyze the state of
our situation and identify areas of
progress stagnation and or regression
again how often are we going through
life
without actually assessing where we're
at what's going on what's our status
what adjustments do we need to make
like
this seems so obvious
but
guaranteed guaranteed i would actually
say most people aren't assessing where
they're at
maybe they do it
oh you know when they do it is uh what's
the new the new year right
the new year
the resolution yeah they're like hey you
know i need to do this now
but
this is something you should be doing
all the time where are you at
i used to tell the uh i used to trick
though when i taught uh
the young junior officers one of the
little tricks i would play myself what's
the most important piece of information
that you need on the battlefield
and they would be like where the enemy
is how many weapons they have how many
there are and i'd be like no the most
important thing you need to know is
where you are
so that's what that's about assessment
where are you at so you can make changes
to your course
and get it corrected honesty is what's
critical with this which a lot of us
struggle with man especially with social
media like what people project
oftentimes isn't real
and you get so conditioned to projecting
this facade that you believe it yourself
that's gonna hurt
you in order for this to have any kind
of significance of value you need to
have that internal no [__] dialogue
where you can be honest with yourself
like where am i currently at forget
about my last instagram post
which has 17 filters on it i took 57
different attempts for the perfect angle
forget that and your caption that was
very enlightening i'm sure forget that
look yourself in the mirror like what is
my current status and be honest with
yourself yeah you're gonna [__]
yourself and forget about all this it's
not gonna matter yeah
it's one thing that's nice about jiu
jitsu you can't [__] your partner
you can't it doesn't work
this just doesn't work
that's that's another reason for me like
i have those log books in my workout so
i can say man you know what
i don't really need to do that i oh wait
a second let me look at what i see what
i was doing two years ago oh i was
actually doing this many reps or this
many sets or whatever
and that's what it oh and it keeps me
keeps me honest actually absolutely no
no
um
phase eight repeat has the goal changed
if the answer is yes then repeat the
process that means go all the way back
to the beginning and do this assessment
again if the answer is no repeat the
process with specific and intentional
adjustments
based on the identified lags or
deficiencies boom execute back to work
move out continue to gather the data
stay the course trust the process we
cannot make brash decisions odds are
there are variables within our equation
that are working the only way to
determine what is creating positive
effects through small incremental
adjustments over time it's hard
this separates the average from the
greats
if it were easy everybody would do it
repeat repeat repeat the process does
not stop focus
it is worth it
so
again those were the highlights to this
uh
this guide
this this methodology
the sort of military
the military planning
wrapped around what you could use for
everyday life
freaking legit man thank you
freaking legit thank you um
so
that's kind of that kind of gets us up
to speed right
how many years you've been in the army
for right now 15
i guess you're going to stay for 20
at this point man yeah it would have to
take something real convincing to get
reality try yeah i don't know what the
hell would get you out of the way at
this point
um
you got any are you starting to look at
what you might do after the military
yeah so i mean it's
i'm going to continue to write because
again i found out that i actually enjoy
it
so i got a few projects i kind of work
on well you did spend seven years in
college so you've got some
extra lots of experience at it
got some lessons learned yeah a little
bit
um
so continue to write because i enjoy it
and then
i'm not working for anybody else ever
again after after 20 years
i'll work with a lot of people but i'm
going to choose who i work with but the
days of people telling me what to do
will be over
once i get that dd214 in my hands
so i see myself doing you know
consulting
um speaking workshop seminar type stuff
and you know i got a small
crew around me now that are that are in
line with that
you know successful buddies of mine and
some family that
i that are doing well in life but feel
unfulfilled
you know my buddies you know they work
for like salesforce and they make a ton
of cash they live in manhattan
wildly successful but it's like
do i want to look back on my deathbed at
80 and been like i sold a lot of
software and i had a i had a really nice
house or do i want to do something to
sink my teeth into something that i'm
proud of that gives me some fulfillment
so just turning that into uh from what
is now a nights and weekends kind of
side thing into just what i do full-time
uh
where will you raise your family once
you get out it's a good question my wife
and i are having this conversation right
now
uh
i would like to go back up north um
[Music]
but i want land
as well so i'd like to be able to live
ideal for me maybe is like western or
central mass where i can get
my family because it's all about what
culture do i want to raise my kids in
that's the conversation her and i are
having you know
i think that there's a lot of value i
grew up in more of an urban environment
where there's the the edgy
fast thinking wittiness that comes the
expression is with new york if you can
make it here you can make it anywhere
because it's tough
you take someone from that environment
that culture
put them into a much slower environment
like tennessee where i'm at now yeah
they'll probably be frustrated because
things are moving at a slower pace but
they're gonna do well
because they can move fast and talk fast
and think fast where if you take someone
who grew up in some you know backwoods
area and threw them in manhattan they're
just
overwhelmed by events so i'd like to be
able to give my kids a taste of that
high tempo environment but i don't want
to necessarily like live in that
environment yeah i think there's i think
there's a good uh if you can get somehow
get both those get your kids in both
those environments
where they spend some time where they're
like in the city scenario and they spend
sometimes where they're out in the
country scenario
because
you know you also have those kids that
like
they're out in the field and there's
like a rattlesnake and they just like
grab a stick you know hold the thing's
head down pick it up swing it up against
the tree and kill it you know you're
like that's pretty legit absolutely so
you get
you can again you can kids are their
minds don't get developed
even remotely to the capacity that
they've got you know so if you can get a
little bit of that both you know you get
them in the city sometimes where they're
comfortable with that you get them in
the country sometimes where they're
comfortable with that
i think that
i think that's optimal yeah you know
same thing man get some space you know
get a little range set up out there some
quiet some lands made tvs
some you know some hiking trails do some
outdoorsy stuff but then you know i'm
two and a half three hours outside of
boston where i can go in yeah you need
you might need to go to new hampshire or
maine or something for that kind of
scenario i could see that because i
don't see you having a range anywhere in
your backyard in massachusetts is that
even possible
uh
legally
it may be tough
it might be tough if you had the land
yeah but that type of dynamic i think is
the goal for both of us right you know
right
but you gotta you also have man you got
some roots in boston man where you want
them to have you want them to have a
boston accent i try to indoctrinate them
into that now you know and they you know
my oldest is five he doesn't have like
i'd say a tennessee accent yet but he
uses some of the vernacular down there
you know the y'all and the
and the whatever and i'll i'll correct
him on how to pronounce words with an
accent you know because he's learning
how to read and write and he's like you
know c a
ah he's like you know car and i'm like
it's car yeah
say it again
he's like no dad it's car i'm like
my wife is like would you leave him
alone where's your wife from originally
milwaukee
they kind of have not much of an accent
right it's kind of like a chicago thing
it's a little chicago it's like yeah
don't you know it's kind of like
minnesota that sort of thing southern
canada
type thing
hers isn't isn't really that dick some
of her family is
right on now
uh awesome man um i think that's
probably a pretty good place echo
charles yes sir you got any uh got any
questions well i was gonna ask about
jiu-jitsu but we kind of talked about it
you know what would you want to ask just
you know how's the training what uh uh
when are you getting back to training
because your shoulder and stuff right
yeah man i'm probably about another
eight nine weeks out before the docks
will clear me from that and it'll be a
slow progression back
but i'm not training jiu jitsu like i
used to um i did de-prioritize it
um where i was real heavy into it and
competing and like real aggressive and
like enhancing my skill and my technical
capacity
now i get in there a couple days a week
just to just to keep a finger on the
pulse and enjoy it kind of open matt's
style and i help with the instruction of
my my son who's in jiu jitsu now as well
yeah that's kind of a natural
progression for a lot of people right
especially when you get kids and you
know all this stuff it's like
you keep jiu jitsu but you
de-prioritize it a little bit yeah that
makes sense how's your kid like jiu
jitsu
he struggles with it a bit because it's
there's a lot of free time where they're
trying to teach some real technical
stuff and he doesn't do well when he's
told to just sit there and like pay
attention
he's five he's five i
very seldom because i taught kids
classes for a long time now including my
own kids classes
if five is young man
it's almost like when they're five you
should have a half an hour class
because you just get them out there and
keep it fun
they already know how to wrestle like
it's it's it's a natural thing so if you
just say put some rules around what they
already know
some very basic rules
they'll have fun and the funner you can
make it man the better off you're gonna
be and you know i i'm sure you've heard
me talk about this before but like i
pushed jiu jitsu too hard on my kids
when they were younger uh like competing
they trained seven days a week that's a
lot yeah
seven days a week and we were just i was
just talking about with my kids the
other day
it'd be like on saturday we'd get here
we'd get to this gym at eight o'clock in
the morning
and like i would teach their striking
class and then i'd bring them up and
teach the jiu jitsu class and then i
would train
for two hours or two and a half hours so
they'd be here
just in this gym
ages like five through
eight
for like five six hours saturday and
sunday
that's aggressive
it's not uh not the best protocol
i would have been done a better job now
look they're coming back to it i mean
one of my daughters is like training
she's training more than that right now
you know she's getting after an echo
knows yes sir echo almost lost his arm
to her the other day she's getting
hostile every time i come in here she's
here yeah no matter what time by the way
how old is she
21. oh yeah but she wrestled in high
school and stuff like she's down for the
cost but um
but yeah you can't get two
you can't get two you gotta let you
gotta make them love it yeah we scaled
it back it was twice a week and now
we're doing like one and then we brought
in some gymnastics and he does like this
little crossfit like kids class thing
it's just it's just there's more
movement
with those things which is good for him
well this was the main point i want to
make my uh my son had a friend because i
would like try and get every kid in the
neighborhood to train jiu jitsu and my
son had a friend who i brought him into
he was five he hated it i brought him in
when he like literally a year later he
was six hated it he was seven hated it
he was eight hated it and finally when
he was like nine
all of a sudden it clicked and he was
like oh i understand what all this means
and what what this could help me with
and it you know and he started training
all the time and it wasn't like he was
then
five years behind my son
you know what i mean like the kids are
only gonna learn so much and they can
learn so rapidly that once they get
engulfed in it they'll catch up pretty
quick right so you don't have to worry
like this is a wasted year yeah go
freaking full go freaking full nick
lavery on them like you missed a
training opportunity
right that's a good that's actually a
good point yeah because they'll be able
to make up for it and if they if they're
into it man that's worth
that's worth it um
look we can find you people can find you
machine nick.com that's it
uh you have a youtube channel
you have instagram which is nick
nick dot machine dot lavery labors
l-a-v-e-r-y
uh
any closing thoughts nick
i appreciate the invitation man i uh
you're in this book you didn't you
didn't read the pots where i mentioned
you yeah i know absolutely dude i
totally appreciate it it feels weird you
know i bet it does no it's fine but just
a level of gratitude to the lessons i
learned from you and from these works
you know once i did
realize
that leadership is more as a skill
although some people may be
genetically enhanced
based on character traits it's a skill
that requires reps like anything else
and uh
you were the first dude that i found the
first mentor i found when i realized
that i had that gap and that there was a
difference and i drove down that road so
a lot of my uh
operational and
personal successes are from your works
and the way you message that
so i'm a i'm a fan so it's
an honor to be here and just spend some
time with you man so i appreciate it no
that's awesome and um
you know my last job
in the seal teams was running training
and there was
it was so rewarding i kind of already
mentioned it but having guys come back
from combat
and say hey we got out of this situation
because of what you taught us
and now having been doing this stuff
you know the amount of feedback that i
get like that man it's just
it feels good to pass that information
on and you're gonna get the same
feedback you know on your story on the
lessons you learned on the methodology
you put forth in your book so uh i
appreciate you taking that and and
running with it
and
it that's that's what we got to do you
know we got to take care of uh the next
generation so i appreciate it man that
means a lot and yes it was a little i
did purposely avoid the parts of the
book
but all good man uh
i want to read one last thing um
just because i think it closes out the
message really solid from the book i was
not genetically gifted with any
astonishing talents i don't come from a
family of wealth i make mistakes
constantly i lose focus i procrastinate
i waste time i feel pain i experience
fear i bleed
i am not cut from a different cloth i am
not from another planet
i am a human same as you which means we
have the ability to choose
it doesn't matter what we do for a
living how much money we have in the
bank the size of our house the
disability we live with who we care for
who cares for us the car we drive if we
have a car at all how popular we are or
how much we can bench
it does not matter
we must simply decide
this is what i believe
this is who i am going to become
and i am willing to put it all on the
line
to achieve it
so
there you go man um
you're living proof of those words
thanks for joining us man um thanks for
sharing your
your story your strategies for victory
and uh most important thank you for your
continued service and sacrifice
you set an example for all of us and the
next generation that's coming up is
going to be looking at you
and knowing that they can get things
done
and
it's an example
you know not just how to live
but how to live right so thanks brother
i appreciate it bro
and with that
nick lavery the machine machine has left
the building appropriate yeah fully
appropriate right yes
you're no you're not like well that's
got no
what a freaking stud man
um in the in the classic hackworth sense
of the word
you know what hackworth
yeah no awkward that's the way he
describes there's two categories of
people
oh studs and duds
hopeless in the heart but like like the
most
the best thing he can describe he goes
this guy was a stud that's like his big
his big statement but um yeah man nick
just amazing uh human
out there
crushing
and
what a beast man
here's
small point of contention which you just
alluded to before you hit record
he says he has no not genetically gifted
he's a little bit genetically i was
gonna say i was gonna chime in
you were sounding good i was like well
yeah you are
a monster yeah he's a he's a massive
monster of a human being
yeah and then but then also thinking
about 300 pounds as a bouncer
bro how tall he say he was six five six
he said he shot up to six five i was
looking at him i'm evaluated i'm
thinking six five six six that's what
i'm saying that's not a small human no
giant
and uh you can get by you can get by
with that in life
but then you can go next level
yeah
and he's not like a sloppy
like two you know even how big he is
he's not like and i'm not saying all
because i'm not saying that but there's
a difference between just being big and
sort of lurchy and maybe sloppy and like
a six five
stud as it were yeah it's insane and he
was for sure that so i can imagine him
eating with a diet uh coach and all this
stuff i didn't do a good job i didn't do
a good job of capturing the fact of like
the discipline
that he imposes in his life to achieve
these goals look it kind of is clear
that you have to but you know he's you
know this how many calories i'm getting
at this time this is what i'm doing here
this is the workout this is the stretch
and this is mobility this is the time
you know
zero four hundred reveille zero four
twenty eight you know in the gym zero
five
twenty one starting cardio
zero six ten
first calorie intake 700 via egg you
know like that kind of thing
bro he said something or the one part
that really i was like bro that's so
true if you can just remember that
because you know he mentioned tunnel
vision at one point he mentioned tunnel
vision right about when he was just
thinking about his own goals kind of
thing
i was like bro i think
that that's like an asset that tunnel
vision because that's really a big part
of what discipline is not getting
distracted by
other stuff including like your own
feelings right so you guys both you guys
are talking about like when you wake up
in the morning you just do it just do it
you're not distracted about how you feel
how much sleep you may or may not have
gotten um you know the weather or all
the stuff whatever you're just not
distracted by that you just sort of do
it right so technically distraction is
kind of the main enemy of discipline and
he mentioned it how it was like
i was just like tunnel videos i was like
yeah that is huh if you can maintain
tunnel vision and leverage that bro you
can kind of do anything and this is the
part where i was like bro that's so true
i hope to remember this
in at times that'll benefit me where he
was like he's talking about getting in
and out of the the the vehicle right
where he's like having trouble so he's
just practicing
he's like if i can do this a thousand
times i'll be good i'll be good good to
do it yeah i'll be good i was like
probably that's so true
and you know and we know it like we know
it but it's like okay so you need these
guys
like uh what's the group the acrobat
group like a cirque du soleil or
something or you know whatever you
called it yeah
and they do these things you're like how
the heck can they just nail that it's so
precise or whatever but then you think
about it in those terms or if it's like
yeah let me do this a thousand times let
me do this ten thousand times let me do
this i mean probably even more than that
just do it that many times and it's just
so automatic just like anything else you
do not anything else but like a lot of
stuff you already do as a human like
walking
by you ever consider bro what you your
body has to do to just stand up and walk
like your little feed and all this stuff
so it's like man you just got to put it
into perspective it's like yeah you just
apply that to like kind of hard stuff
and probably you can do it but you got
to maintain that tunnel vision though in
a way yeah and the tunnel vision you got
to watch out for because he got tunnel
vision just focused on himself but i
what i liked the power when he was like
oh when it was about me he was working
hard
when he realized it was about his
teammates and his teammates kids and
wives yeah he's like i can get another
freaking rep
watch this you know what i'm saying yeah
so
you know
you are much
less likely
to allow yourself to let your friend
down
than to let yourself down you know
that's why people need a workout buddy
right like hey are you gonna be there
yeah i'm gonna be i'm gonna be there you
don't want to let your friend down so
you show up they recommend that if
you're having trouble getting it done
get a workout buddy
so he had that like amplified times 1000
because it's him
wanting to be able to
execute
the job to take care of his teammates
yeah that's what this is about so
freaking neck awesome
uh awesome guy man just an awesome guy
hey uh
look
no matter where you are
in life
you know you can do a little bit better
nick is a
good example to all of us say you know i
could probably do a little bit better
everything that i do
every single thing that i jocko willing
do is a little bit easier for me because
i got two freaking legs
can you imagine jumping off a four-foot
thing
in order to be able to do your job that
you want to do you jump off this
four-foot platform you gotta land in a
pistol with another random
prosthetic leg sticking out and stick to
landing and stick it by the way yeah
that's what i'm talking about
so
what you know
they said in the book if you're around
nick you have no excuses well we're
around nick man
nick's out there think about that right
now good so nick's out there so the
pistol squat thing sticking the landing
jumping off the four foot thing sticking
landing in a pistol pistol squat even if
you're not that like
impressed with that what if you were
six five
freaking two you know two fifteen one
leg though yeah seems saying like he
would have been 250 the equivalent of
like a 250. see him saying now do it
way way more impressive
uh so we're doing better
if you want to do better you're gonna
need to work if you're gonna do work
you're gonna need to recover if you're
gonna need to recover you need the right
fuel you need the right fuel to work
sometimes that's true i'm on some fuel
right now some taco fuel i drink some go
it feels good with you i feel good
so jockofield.com you can get some
fuel
supplementation supplementation you can
get mulk you can get joint warfare
go read the reviews on joint warfare and
then press click order because it makes
you feel good yeah way better i i had a
jiu jitsu sesh that was slightly more
intense than maybe i was i was used to
or whatever no no problem but my elbow
and shoulder
so i had to double up the joint where
it's a good move
hey that's my life man
energy drinks which we use the term
in its own category separate from the
poison that you may have been drinking
this is energy drinks that are good for
you actually give you energy and now
they taste good
they may not have tasted they might have
been not they may not have been to your
liking before now they will be we fixed
it
we took input
we're not over here like no no we took
input want it to taste better now it
tastes better now it tastes freaking
delicious so we're up there
uh jackalful.com you can get the drinks
at wawa you can get this stuff at
vitamin shop you can get it at atb i owe
everyone a list of where you can shop
for this stuff i'll get it out there i'm
sorry jockofield.com go get some
originusa.com we didn't even talk really
too much with uh nick about jiu jitsu
but he did he did talk about how jiu
jitsu was like a huge part of his
recovery and what he did you should be
doing jiu jitsu and you may
you may have previous to this podcast
had some kind of an excuse yeah as to
why you couldn't train because you have
this and you have that and you have the
other thing
so you don't have an excuse anymore nick
was a white belt
he he didn't have he doesn't have a leg
and he got his black belt yeah and
competed by the way and competed so yeah
yeah and that and so come on there's a
as far as like you know you want to go
hard into jiu jitsu there's different
levels which to me are 100 all of them
are 100 acceptable
if you just want to train recreationally
you just you want to train and go hard
and see you know and for your rank or
whatever or you want to train to be a
competitor
no they're all all legitimate all viable
all viable
you do them all it takes a lot more to
do them all you see insane and this
[__] did it all so
you are correct there is no excuse yup
we have no excuses so train jujitsu
originusa.com get yourself an
american-made ghee and while you're
there get yourself some american-made
jeans get yourself some hunt gear we got
some good gallon gear coming out we're
gonna sell it all
um we're gonna make as much as we can
next year we'll make even more
the pieces are freaking great so
origin usa.com
support america
and support yourself by getting awesome
stuff and don't forget that we have a
store what's that store called jungle
store oh there you go yeah just like
chocolate podcast jocko store same thing
can you get this just like choco fuel
yeah yeah it's true yep yeah you want to
represent on this path
varying levels of representation
available by the way but yeah we got
some new stuff on there discipline
equals freedom standard issue shirts
mm-hmm
yesterday yeah so you really was
representing heart it was impressive but
yeah if you like some stuff get some
stuff there's something called the shirt
locker if you didn't know this is what
it is
subscription service
shirt even i have to admit at this time
currently
i'm looking at your shirt which is a
shirt locker shirt yes and i must say it
is pretty solid it's squared away yeah
yeah pretty solid it's nicely done man
this one is one of the there's like six
shirts that are kind of the crowd
favorites and everyone kind of like asks
about this is one of them yes sir yeah
that's a good one but yeah a lot of good
stuff on there but yeah jocklestore.com
subscribe to the podcast go to
jockowunderground.com we've been we just
we just recorded a couple of those
we have our own little platform
just in case things go totally sideways
we don't control the platform that
you're listening to us on right now
unless you're on draco underground.com
which in which case we're all good
but
they could shut us down they could stuff
there's people there's some of these
platforms stick advertisements into the
middle of our podcast did you know that
yeah
i don't know they just insert
they just insert up a a damn commercial
oh for a thing so we're in here talking
about wars talking about combat talking
about loss of lives oh here's an
advertising thing
so we don't like that jocko
underground.com there's no freaking
commercials on there
uh eight dollars and 18 cents a month if
you can't afford it it's okay
email
assistants at jocko underground.com we
can get you hooked up we just we just
want to make sure that we can continue
to do what we want to do with freedom
uh youtube channel
psychological warfare
that's a little mp3 thing which we owe
another one which i've been thinking
about actually yeah so that might come
to fruitionflipsidecampus.com dakota
meyer out there getting after it books
nick
lavery
objective secure just go on to amazon
and order it right now it's a little
guide book on how to live your life
check it out only cry for the living by
holly mckay who risked her life to write
a book
by some miracle she made it out of syria
and iraq and afghanistan and she
taught interviewed all kinds of people
on all sides of the conflict
if you want to know about it go get that
book she's been on the podcast a couple
times i've written a bunch of other
books
check those out
echelonfront
echelonfront.com it's a leadership
consultancy we talk about leadership we
teach leadership
go to ashlandfront.com if you need help
with leadership and if you don't think
you need help
it's your first indicator that you need
help with leadership
uh we also have the online training
academy just like jiu jitsu you got to
keep training
you got to do it every day
extreme ownership.com check out the
extreme ownership academy and also from
the charity perspective if you want to
help out veterans
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got an incredible charity organization
and if you want to help out or you want
to donate you can go to america's
mightywarriors.org
also
check out micah thinks organization he's
a seal
he's taken veterans into the wilderness
and repairing their their soul
actually they're repairing their own
soul he's facilitating i guess i would
say heroes and horses.org
once again if you wanna check out
nick
machine
nick.com you can find him there
nick machine lavery
uh on instagram so it's
nick.machine.lavery and he's got a
youtube channel as well he said he's
gonna start putting on more youtube
stuff so check that out and then of
course for
for echo and and me we're on the twitter
or on the gram or on the facebook
ecos i'm at jocko willing and when you
go in there
watch out because the algorithm is going
to try and grab you by the throat
and thanks to all the military out there
for risking your life liberty and
pursuit of happiness for us and a salute
to all the wounded vets
whose sacrifice is continuous
every minute every hour every day every
week every year
we thank you for your sacrifice and of
course thanks to nick
for coming out
for sharing his story with us
and
thanks to nick for teaching us
a better way to live
and also thank you to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service all first
responders
thank you for your sacrifice to keep us
safe here at home and everybody else out
there
just remember what nick had to say
when he's talking about the fact in his
book that he's not from a rich family
he's not genetically gifted which
that's a little bit of contention behind
that
but
listen
we know this he's now
been
physically
put into a situation where it certainly
was not a gift
so he's in a situation right now that's
more challenging than most of us have
and he makes mistakes and he feels pain
like everybody else but none of that
matters
none of that matters he's not
complaining about any of it
what matters is that we simply must
decide
what we're gonna do
and who we're going to be
so go make that decision
and then
get after it
and until next time
this is echo and jocko
out